[Music]
welcome to the simply learns youtube
channel we've been following the trend
of taking up a challenge to learn the
fundamentals and brush up the skills of
a trending technology within a week
data science week software development
week by simply learn are brilliant
examples to name a few
now this week is dedicated to learning
devops
this interesting week will help you
learn all the fundamentals and improve
your devops skill set but before we
begin let me tell you guys that we have
daily updates on multiple technologies
if you are a tech geek in a continuous
hunt for latest technological trends
then consider getting subscribed to our
youtube channel and don't forget to hit
that bell icon to never miss an update
from simply learn devops is a software
development and operations approach that
enables faster development and
deployment of software products and
easier maintenance of existing
deployments by eliminating the
compatibility various separating the
developers and operations teams should
you ask how well that's exactly our
first session in devops week without
further ado let's get started we shall
begin with having a basic understanding
of devops with a short animated video
after that we shall dive deeper and
understand what devops is all about
we shall see what is its relevance in
the present scenario
we shall learn different tools in our
learning journey the tools that we shall
see are
git
gradle maven selenium docker chef
ansible puppet nagios and jenkins
after we have a fair amount of knowledge
regarding devops and devops tools
we will look at the interview questions
that will increase our chances to crack
any devops interview
now without any further ado let's begin
with our animated introduction
meet tim
tim builds a robot in his lab
a climate controlled and pollution-free
environment
once he's done he drops the robot off at
his project partner mia's house mia
takes it out to her backyard to ensure
that the robot meets the requirements
but here is where the problem arises the
change in the environment causes the
robot to malfunction
mia is now really annoyed and she has a
lot to correct and it seems to her as
though tim didn't really do much
this wall between them leaves a poor
robot to bite the dust
well what if we broke this wall tim and
miana work together in a common space
tim develops each block of functionality
of the robot which is then immediately
checked by mia both are now working
simultaneously instead of waiting on the
other to finish their task as and when a
feature is ready for use they are put
together to build the final product they
develop a common mindset and share ideas
to further speed up the process they use
several tools which can automate every
stage this means that the robot is now
ready sooner with less iterations and
manual work from an organization
perspective tim would be the developer
while mia the operations their union is
the core of the devops approach devops
has several stages and set of tools to
automate each of these stages let's have
a look at these tim first puts down a
plan
in terms of software this could mean
deciding on the modules and the
algorithms to use
once he has the plan he now codes the
plan with tools such as git tim has a
repository for storing all the codes and
their different versions this is called
version control
next this code is fetched and made
executable this is the build stage tools
such as gradle and maven will sort this
out now before deployment the product is
tested to catch any bugs the most
popular tool automating testing is
selenium once the products are tested
mia must deploy it the deployed product
is then continuously configured to the
desired state ansible puppet and docker
are some of the most common tools used
that automate these stages
now
every product is continuously monitored
in its working environment
nagios is one such tool that automates
this space and the feedback is fed back
to the planning stage
and finally we have the core of the
devops lifecycle the integration stage
tools such as jenkins is responsible for
sending the code for build and test if
the code passes the tests it's further
sent for deployment this is called
continuous integration
let's now have a look at an organization
that has adopted the devops approach
which of the below sequence of steps
would they follow to develop a software
leave your answers in the comment
section
keep an eye out for the right answer on
the comment section or our youtube
community giants such as amazon netflix
target etsy and walmart have all adopted
devops and seen a considerable increase
in delivery and quality
in 2014 an hour of downtime for netflix
would cost it two hundred thousand
dollars
it became absolutely crucial that
netflix prepared themselves for any sort
of failure and so they took to the
devops approach and implemented it in
the most unique way they developed a
tool called simeon army this tool
created failures and automatically
deployed them in an environment that did
not affect the users
the team would troubleshoot these
failures and this gave them enough
experience to deal with any degree of
collapse with everything being automated
and happening simultaneously
organizations can now deliver at a much
faster pace so considering the benefits
of devops and its divergence from the
traditional methods would devops be the
future uh we're going to go through what
we need to be able to do to go to devops
what the arguments are and why you need
to do devops and they will actually go
through all the individual tools you
need to be able to successfully
implement devops within your
organization in addition to that we're
also going to take time and go through
each of those tools so you get a good
understanding of a step-by-step
instructions on how to do basic setup of
each of those tools so let's get started
so what was devops before so what was
the process that we took for doing
delivery before devops well it was a
model called waterfall and waterfall was
a very traditional approach to actually
building out solutions and the reason
why it's called waterfall is that you
bring out all the individual
requirements and individual sections of
a project and they cascade off each
other so if we look at the breakdown we
have requirements design and we have
implementation we have verification we
have maintenance you'll have user
acceptance testing and this is all based
on the software development lifecycle
model or sdlc and it's been around for
quite some time and it's still used by a
lot of companies today the challenge you
had with the waterfall model is that it
really is a very long drawn out model
for actually building and delivering
solutions so it took a very long time to
actually um write code and then deploy
the code and it was very difficult to
actually identify problems within the
code and provide feedback to the
development team on what to fix and this
really was a very time consuming we're
talking about months sometimes years for
projects to actually go through a
waterfall model process so along came a
new method of being able to do delivery
and it's called agile and the agile
approach is a way of being able to take
the actual work that's done in a
waterfall model and compress it down
into small iterations and what we would
do is a fundamental change is that you
would actually take uh teams that would
disparate and as part of the individual
cascades within a waterfall project you
actually bring them together so you have
your requirements team in person design
developer and release management team
all together in one group working on an
iteration the great thing about agile is
that you took a process that was weeks
or months or even years in length as it
was with waterfall and you reduce it
down to two or four week sprints
depending on the cadence for your team
uh typically you have a two week sprint
and then the goal is is that at the end
of each sprint or sometimes every other
sprint you would do a software release
and so that customers were getting the
software much faster the problem that we
still ran into though with um agile is
fundamentally similar to what we were
having with waterfall uh you have your
devops person working on code on their
system and you'll be working great on
their computer and then you have the
operations person who's migrating the
code from the developers environment the
test environment to for the production
environment and you would run into
issues where the code simply doesn't
work and there's a lot of reasons why
that would happen the actual developer
environment would often be very
different or would have different
dependencies in it so the the hardware
the the software there may be additional
applications that were installed on the
operating system that simply hadn't been
transferred over to the operations
environment and so what you would have
is a disconnect between the developer
environment and the operations
environment making it difficult um to
actually roll out code so you'd run into
a program where that when you rolled out
code you'd have to have a rollback plan
in case the code wouldn't work in
production and so each release became an
event where everybody got very stressed
about the actual event of releasing code
because you didn't know whether it was
going to work so devops really looks to
address and solve a lot of these
problems so the keyword that you'll
often hear with
devops is continuous integration and
what that means is essentially that as a
developer is working on their code the
code is constantly being tested against
not just the actual code itself with
unit testing but the environment with
which it's going to be released in and
the goal from a devops model is that the
breakdown of communication that happens
with waterfall and agile where dev
developers and operations teams aren't
working in the same environment is being
removed and you're able to provide a
continuous and contiguous environment
between the developer and the apple
actual operating model so the reality is
when the developer is working on their
code they're actually working in an
environment that is identical to the
production environment and so when the
actual operations person comes to
actually do releases for the code and
you can see some teams are doing as many
as 20 to even up to 50 releases to
production environments every single day
you're able to guarantee that the actual
code itself will work and releases go
from being a stressful event to a
byproduct of good testing and good setup
and structure for how you actually build
out your solutions so what we're seeing
here so the goal is that as a developer
and as an operations person that the
code is working continuously in both
environments you have continuous
integration and continuous delivery so
simply put what we're able to do is
we're able to eliminate the problem of
the operation environment not being in
sync with the development environment
and this is a
improvement on agile this is not to say
that waterfall or agile are wrong as
delivery models what it is is just a
maturity of the ability to deliver
solutions and devops is just another
rung in that maturity curve using tools
that are available to us now that five
ten years ago simply weren't available
so the goal is for you as a team to move
to a devops model where you can
implement continuous releases on your
software as long as you're using the
tools that are available and the good
news is those tools are open source
tools so let's go through
some of the benefits of why you'd want
to go and use devops so you know
essentially what's in it for you so
let's over the next few slides we're
going to go through what is devops we're
going to go through the benefits of
devops so in the last few slides you've
actually seen you know what is devops
and the benefits of devops along with
the life cycle but we're also going to
start digging into the tools that you
have that are useful for devops and
we're going to focus in on seven tools
that can provide an end-to-end
infrastructure for delivering devops
solutions with there are significantly
more tools available on the market but
these are seven of the most popular uh
for each of their categories so devops
really is an essential collaboration
between the development team and the
operations team these are teams that
have in past being somewhat at uh
conflict with each other and what you
have now is an opportunity where those
teams can now work continuously with
each other the expectation with devops
is that it will continue to mature
indeed you're actually even seeing some
groups which are now called devsecops
where they're integrating security as
part of the delivery between the
development team and the operations team
the bottom line is a devops engineer is
highly in demand the demand for devops
engineer is literally going through the
roof with salaries going up
exponentially around that so let's dig
into some of the benefits of devops it's
not just a new catchphrase it's actually
got significant value and how you can
speed up delivery of your software so
the benefits of devops are really broken
up into a number of key areas first of
all we have continuous delivery of
software which allows you to
continuously release new features with
the security and understanding that the
software going out is of high quality it
allows the teams that are working on the
software delivery within your
organization to more effectively
collaborate with each other so that
you're all talking from the same page
and understanding of what needs to be
delivered the deployment process itself
moves from being an event where there's
a lot of stress and there's a lot of
contingency plans to being a much easier
deployment the efficiency within the
actual code that you're writing the
ability to scale up using the different
tools are available allows you to be
able to bring in and scale up and reduce
the teams you have running the software
as needed errors can be fixed much
earlier and more quickly and can be
caught before anything gets pushed out
to the production environment and
fundamentally what we're looking for is
improving the security of the actual
releases so the actual concept of
security is center to all the work
you're doing and then finally what
really allows you to
reduce the number of errors is that
there is much less manual intervention
you there is a greater reliance on
scripted environments that you can
actually test and validate for their
security reliability and uptime
efficiency so let's talk a little bit
about the life cycle of a devops so the
very first step that you'll take is to
actually build out a build and test
environment and this is a continuous
building test environment and this is
managed with the first step of your
source code once you move through that
and you're looking at continuous
integration which means that every time
somebody checks in their code they're
validating that the code actually can
run in the production environment once
you've actually then passed the end
continuous integration and the testing
that you have with your code you're
looking at continuous deployment if the
code works and is available to be
released into the production environment
let's go ahead and release it and once
you actually have release code then you
want to be able to validate that your
environment is working efficiently you
may release code that is a new feature
within your application
and customers may then gravitate
immediately to that new feature if they
do you want to be able to ensure that
the code is working and more importantly
that the infrastructure is there to
support and then finally you're looking
at software released as a continuous
event and then you go back to the
beginning you start working on more code
you run it through your build
environment and continuous integration
deployment continuous monitoring and
keep that cycle moving so let's dig into
the tools that you as a devops engineer
would need to learn if we break down the
environment that we have all the way
from source code management to software
release and there are a number of key
tools that you want to be able to use so
for instance source code management and
get is an open source tool that you
would want to use for managing your code
the continuous build and test
environment will be managed with mavin
and selenium integration with the
environments that you're working on is
managed through jenkins the actual
deployment to your production
environment will be managed with
products such as ansible and docker and
then the monitoring of your network
would be used with tools like nagios the
thing that you have to remember with all
these tools is that they're open source
tools there is no licensing that you
have to purchase uh some of the tools
will have a pro level licensing that you
can choose to select but to get started
all of these are open source tools you
can actually start using for free right
now we are going to dive deep and
understand the top 10 reasons why you
should learn devops so what is devops
devops is a collaboration between the
development and operation teams which
enables continuous delivery of
applications and services to our end
users
before devops there was a lot of
communication gap between the
development and operation teams the code
that used to work fine on the
development side would create a lot of
errors on the operation side this in
fact led to a lot of issues the biggest
issue was the delay in project delivery
the solution to this was devops in
devops the operation and development
engineers participate together in the
entire lifecycle from the design through
the development process to the delivery
of the software to the end users
it enhances the process to deliver the
software faster and a software of high
quality if there is any bug or error it
is fixed at the right time rather than
dragging it to the last phase let's now
look into the 10 reasons why you should
learn devops
so at number 10 we have technical
cultural and business benefits of devops
let me explain each benefit one by one
so first we have the technical benefits
continuous software delivery is the most
important process of delivering the
software in smaller increments to ensure
that the software can be released at any
time with this approach of devops the
team will always be ready on delivering
anytime it has the benefit of having
less complex problems to fix the code is
tested at every stage and both the
development and operation teams make
sure that the complexity is reduced to a
great extent devops also has the benefit
of faster and easier resolution to every
problem if any bug or error is found at
an earlier stage it is fixed and then
moved on to the next stage hence this
way at the final stage there will be
zero or minimum number of bugs
moving forward let's look into the
cultural benefits of devops
the workload is divided equally between
all the employees so no individual is
under the pressure to code test debug an
entire software this results in a team
that is happy and more productive since
devops is a collaboration between the
development and operation teams if any
issue arises on one side the team is
always ready to help and the employees
are engaged to make sure that the
software is as the end user requires and
hence is delivered at the set date
devops helps in increasing the
professional development opportunities
finally let's look into the business
benefits of devops the basic principles
of devops that is automation continuous
delivery and quick feedback cycle aim to
make the software development process
faster and more efficient being an
extended version of agile methodology
devops ensures that the complete
software development lifecycle goes
smoothly by promoting collaboration
between the teams devops offers
continuous feedback so that the errors
are fixed in time and the releases are
done faster these days the development
teams need to break down the
inter-departmental constraints and
collaborate as well as communicate in a
dynamic round-the-clock environment
devops gives a way to improve the
business agility by providing an
environment of mutual collaboration
communication and integration across the
various teams in an iit organization all
the team members are responsible for
meeting the quality and timeline of the
software deliverables with devops
organizations can improve the deployment
frequency recovery rates and hence
result in a lower failure rate with
every new release it is possible to
ensure the reliability and stability of
an application when applications perform
flawlessly in the market organizations
reap the benefits of greater customer
satisfaction at the ninth position we
have work with good developers per code
is all too common sadly users arrive at
the realization when it's too late the
fact is some developers are good at what
they do while others have poor coding
skills a team of software developers
consists of excellent good average and
poor developers it is important that the
bad codes generated by many developers
need to be stopped else it may increase
the production time devops helps in
reducing the bad code limits as the bad
code cannot go to the next phase until
it is fixed also a team member who is
terrible at coding could be good at any
other different roles and vice versa
re-tasking team members earlier in the
process prevent wastage of time and
resources so in this way devops
eliminates bad developers and ensures
that the team comprises of good
developers next at eighth position we
have increased efficiency due to
increment in efficiency level it results
in speeding up the process of
development and also makes it error-free
devops can also increase efficiency
through automation there are many ways
to automate tasks in devops devops
allows engineers to focus on those tasks
which are not automated there are
certain tools of acceleration that
increase the efficiency they are the
cloud-based platforms or other scalable
infrastructure which help in increasing
the access of the team to the hardware
resources and hence speeds up the
process of testing and deployment
operations with the use of build
acceleration tools the code compiles
faster they may be a process that helps
in embedding parallel workflows into the
continuous delivery chain so that the
delays are avoided
moving on at seventh position we have a
better organizational culture with the
help of devops there has been an
improvement in software development the
development and operation teams are more
focused on performing together rather
than having separate goals the team is
more focused on production if both the
teams are combined it will result in
innovative ideas in a very efficient and
effective manner there is improved
collaboration and communication between
the team members devops facilitates
better understanding among the team
members and this understanding increases
worker morale
next at the sixth position there is
faster release of software it is true
that devops makes the process of
software development agile hence it
leads to the timely release of the
software companies can quickly study the
behavior of users and incorporate the
changes to come up with a better product
this in turn helps the organization to
stay competitive there is a reduction in
rollbacks and failure rates regarding
deployment and the time that is taken to
recover with better products devops
reduces the time for cycles of
development and also ensures a faster
rate of innovation at position 5 we have
better knowledge of software delivery
lifecycle once you get to know about
devops you will get a lot of information
about the software delivery lifecycle it
is divided into main phases like
planning analysis design implementation
testing and integration and maintenance
in the plan phase initially there should
be a plan for the type of application
that needs to be developed getting a
rough picture of a development process
is always a good idea in analysis a
detailed study of requirements is done
to check whether all the requirements
are available or not the list of all the
requirements like human resources
hardware software required to accomplish
this project successfully will be
clearly analyzed and listed out here in
the design phase the whole project is
divided into modules each module into
sub-modules by drawing some diagrams
using unified modeling language a pseudo
code will be prepared at this phase in
the implementation phase the application
is coded as per the end user
requirements coder now has the task to
do the coding developers will develop
the actual source code by using the
pseudo code and following the coding
standards the testing and integration
phase is the most important step of the
application development here the
application is tested and rebuilt if
necessary the multiple modules of codes
from different programmers are finally
integrated into one then finally the
application is developed and delivered
to the end users the final phase is
maintenance once the client starts using
the developed software then the real
issues start coming up in this stage the
team is required to fix the issues roll
out new features and refine the
functionalities as required at the
fourth position we have boost product
quality the concept of devops does not
allow mistakes in the stage of
methodology when both the operation and
development stages are done correctly
with no errors then it will result in a
release of better and improved product
qualities this leads to a cleaner more
efficient code and hence increases the
software quality with each release
the devops process brings better quality
to the development process and reduces
the chances of unplanned work at the
third position we have exposure to
trending technologies and advanced tools
devops works with a variety of tools few
of them are nagios chef docker git
selenium puppet kubernetes ansible and
many more you will get a chance to
understand and use all these tools and
learn how to design develop deploy and
maintain an app or software with the
help of these tools apart from that by
knowing all things about such software
and tools you can increase your chances
of getting hired by the best companies
at the second position we have increase
your professional credibility by
obtaining a devops certification you can
increase your professional credibility
this certification will help you to let
the others know that you have sufficient
skills in
monitoring a software's performance
easily write and code with scripts
enhancing the software security to a
greater extent providing the best it
hardware you will be able to
troubleshoot various issues in the
software and finally you will be able to
connect softwares databases and much
more to ensure effective functionality
42 of companies are now preferring open
source jobs and want candidates with
devops skills so if you want to become a
part of developing the devops job market
then this is the perfect time to start
getting devops training and finally the
top reason to learn devops is to get a
perfect job and increase your salary
devops is a very popular career choice
now researchers have also shown that in
the coming years devops will be the main
hiring criteria for 46 percent of the it
companies however they are not
sufficient experts who can match the
requirements that's why there are
massive opportunities for candidates
seeking devops jobs besides when it
comes to salary you can earn a lot of
money on an average a divorce
professional gets a pay of 99
604 dollars per annum in the united
states
and a divorce professional in india gets
an average salary of 6 lakhs 2 000
rupees per annum
now let me recap and call out all the 10
reasons for learning devops once again
at number 10 we had the technical
cultural and business benefits of devops
at number nine we had work with good
developers at number eight we had
increased efficiency at number seven we
had a better organizational culture at
number six we had faster release of
software then at fifth position we had
better knowledge of the software
delivery lifecycle
at the fourth position we had boost
product quality and at third position we
had exposure to trending technologies
and advanced tools at the second
position we had increasing professional
credibility and finally at the top
position we had get a perfect job and
increase your salary now let me tell you
how simply learn can help you learn
devops so that you can start your career
in it
so guys this is the official simply
learn website and i'm going to show you
the different types of devops courses
simply learn offers so first is devops
engineer let's go ahead and look into
that this is a masters program
and it has seven plus real life projects
you can see the course curriculum here
that is git and github training devops
certification training devops on aws and
more
you can see the learning objectives
the tools covered here are maven ansible
chef puppet solstack
apache jenkins team city and many more
you can see the course curriculum
and you can see the electives that you
can choose
okay let's go back and look at another
certification
we had the devops certification training
so here you have 56 hours of blended
learning over 10 industry projects with
integrated labs 24 hours of live demos
and you have flexibility to choose the
classes the skills covered are devos
methodology version control systems
continuous integration and deployment
tools and jenkins team city maven and
many more
so you can see the benefits here the
annual salary of a devops professional
the companies that are hiring devops
professional
then we can see the course curriculum
we have introduction to devops version
control systems
continuous integration continuous
deployment
then we have software and automation
testing frameworks we have
containerization with docker and much
more
and you can see the various tools that
are involved in this then we have our
industry projects
so guys in this way simply learn can
help you get a devops certification
we'll start by downloading and
installing git on our system we'll then
have a look at the git bash interface
we'll type in some basic git commands
next we'll create a local repository
that is we'll create a repository on our
local machine we'll then connect to a
remote repository and finally we'll push
the file onto github first things first
we need to download and install git so
download git for windows and i'll select
the second link
so
2.19.1 which is the most latest version
of kit that's the one we want for
windows system choose your version so
mine is a 64-bit system and it's
downloading so this will take a while so
git is finally downloaded now we need to
install this on our system
click here
run
so go to next we don't have to change
this path uh just so just click on in
quick launch and on desktop
next
next again next nothing to change here
either
and install
so now git is getting installed on our
system
so we don't need to view the release
notes we just want to launch the git
bash
so let's just tick that and then click
on finish
and your git bash interface appears here
so we are on the master branch the first
thing we do is we'll check the version
for our git so the command is git dash
dash version
and as you can see version 2.19.1
on our windows system which is exactly
what we just downloaded we'll now
explore the help command so let's just
type git help config so config is
another command and as i hit enter the
manual page for the second command
opened up which is config so what help
command does is that it provides the
manual or the help page for the command
just following it
so in case you have any doubts regarding
how a command is used what a command is
used for all the various syntax of the
command you can always use the help
command now there's another syntax for
using the help command itself which is
git config dash dash help enter this
does the exact same thing as you can see
now that we looked at the help command
let's begin by creating a local
directory so mkdir
test
now test is my new directory i'll move
into this directory so cd test
great so now that we are inside our test
directory let's initialize this
directory so git
init is the command for initializing the
directory and as you can see as you can
see the path here this is the local path
where a directory is created so i'll
just show you the directory test
and it's completely empty
what we do now is we'll create a text
file within this new directory that we
created so new text document and i'll
just name this demo i'll open this and
just put in some dummy content so hello
simply done
save this file and go back to your bash
interface
let's just check the status now so git
status and as you can see
our file has appeared it's visible but
nothing is committed yet so this means
that we have not made any change to a
file through the git tool itself so the
next thing that we are going to do is we
will be adding demo to our current
directory the next command that we will
be applying is the commit command and
when you add certain files to the
current directory the comment command is
applied on all the above directories so
git commit minus m and a message that
will appear once the file is committed
so as you can see one file is changed
and one insertion i'll just clear the
screen next thing we need to do is we
need to link our git to our github
account so the command for doing that is
git config
global user dot username
and this will be followed by our
username so let me just show you my
github account
so this is my github profile and my
username is
simplylearn.github so guys before you
begin this procedure just make a github
account
type in my username here simply learn
github and enter and there you go a git
is successfully linked with github next
thing we do is we'll just open our
github
and we'll create a new repository
give a repository name so i'll name it
test underscore demo and create
repository
great so our repository is created this
is our remote repository what we do next
is just copy the link and then go back
to your bash interface
now we need to link our remote and our
local repository
so get remote origin and then paste
the http link and now that our local
repository and our remote repository are
linked we can push our local file onto
our remote repository so the command for
doing that is git
push origin master as we are on the
master branch
and that's done so now let's move back
to github i'll just click on test demo
and as you can see here our local file
has been pushed to our remote repository
with that we have successfully completed
our demo all right let's talk a little
bit about version control systems so you
may have already been using a virtual
control system within your environment
today you may have used tools such as
microsoft's team foundation services but
essentially the use of a version control
system allows people to be able to have
files that are all stored in a single
repository so if you're working on
developing a new program that such as a
website or an application you would
store all of your version control
software in a single repository now what
happens is that if somebody wants to
make changes to the code they would
check out all of the code in the
repository to make the changes and then
there would be an addendum added to that
so um there will be the version one
changes that you had then the person
would then
later on check out that code and then be
a version two and added to that code and
so you keep adding on versions of that
code the bottom line is that eventually
you'll have people being able to use
your code and that your code will be
stored in a centralized location however
the challenge you're running is that
it's very difficult for large groups to
work simultaneously within a project the
benefits of a vcs system a version
control system
demonstrates that you're able to store
multiple versions of a solution in a
single repository now let's take a step
at some of the challenges that you have
with traditional version control systems
and see how they can be addressed with
distributed version control so in a
distributed version control environment
what we're looking at is being able to
have the code shared across a team of
developers so if there are two or more
people working on a software package
they need to be able to effectively
share that code amongst themselves so
that they constantly are working on the
latest piece of code so a key part of a
distributed version control system
that's different to just a traditional
version control system is that all
developers have the entire code on their
local systems and they try and keep it
updated all the time it is the role of
the distributed vcs server to ensure
that each client and we have a developer
here and developer here and developer
here and each of those our clients have
the latest version of the software and
then that each person can then share the
software and appear to peer-to-peer like
approach so that as changes are being
made into the server of changes to the
code then those changes are then being
redistributed to all of the development
team
the tool to be able to do an effective
distributed vcs environment is get now
you may remember that we actually
covered git in a previous video and
we'll reference that video for you so we
start off with our remote git repository
and people are making updates to the
copy of their code into a local
environment that local environment can
be updated manually and then
periodically pushed out to the git
repository so you're always pushing out
the latest code that you've code changes
you made into the repository and then
from the repository you're able to pull
back the latest updates and so your git
repository becomes the kind of the
center of the universe for you and then
updates are able to be pushed up and
pulled back from there what this allows
you to be able to accomplish is that
each person will always have the latest
version of the code so what is get get
is a distributed version control tool
used for source code management so
github is the remote server for that
source code management and your
development team can connect their get
client to that
remote hub server git is used to track
the changes of the source code and
allows large teams to work
simultaneously with each other it
supports a non-linear development
because of thousands of parallel
branches and has the ability to handle
large projects efficiently so let's talk
a little bit about git versus github so
get is a software tool whereas github is
a service and i'll show you how those
two look in the moment you install the
software tool for git locally on your
system whereas github because it is a
service is actually hosted on a website
get is actually the software that used
to manage different versions of source
code whereas github is used to have a
copy of the local repository stored on
the service on the website itself get
provides command line tools that allow
you to interact with your files whereas
git help has a graphical interface that
allows you to check in and check out
files so let me just show you the two
tools here so here i am at the git
website and this is the website you
would go to to download the latest
version of git and again git is a
software package that you install on
your computer that allows you to be able
to do version control in a peer-to-peer
environment for that peer-to-peer
environment to be successful however you
need to be able to store your files in a
server somewhere and typically a lot of
companies will use a service such as git
hub as a way to be able to store your
files so git can communicate effectively
with github there are actually many
different companies that provide similar
service to github git lab is another
popular service but you also find that
development tools such as microsoft
visual studio are also incorporating git
commands into their tools so the latest
version of visual studio team services
also provides this same ability but
github it has to be remembered is a
place where we actually store our files
and can very easily create public and
shareable is a place where we can store
our files and create public shareable
projects you can come to github and you
can do a search on projects you can see
at the moment i'm doing a lot of work on
blockchain but you can actually search
on the many hundreds of projects here in
fact i think there's something like over
a hundred thousand projects being
managed on github at the moment that
number's probably actually much larger
than that and so if you are working on a
project i would certainly encourage you
to start at github to see if somebody's
already maybe done a prototype that
they're sharing or they have an open
source project that they want to share
that's already available and in github
certainly if you're doing anything with
azure you'll find that there are
thousands
thousand azure projects currently being
worked on interestingly enough github
was recently acquired by microsoft and
microsoft is fully embracing open source
technologies so that's essentially the
difference between git and github one is
a piece of software and that's git and
one is a service that supports the
ability of using the software and that's
github so let's dig deeper into the
actual git architecture itself so the
working directory is the folder where
you are currently working on your git
project and we'll do a demo later on
where you can actually see how we can
actually simulate each of these steps so
you start off with your working
directory where you store your files and
then you add your files to a staging
area where you are getting ready to
commit your files back to the main
branch on your git project you will want
to push out all your changes to a local
repository after you've made your
changes and these will commit those
files and get them ready for
synchronization with the service and
will then push your services out to the
remote repository an example of a remote
repository would be github
later when you want to update your code
before you write any more code you would
pull the latest changes from the remote
repository so that your copy of your
local software is always the latest
version of the software that the rest of
the team is working on one of the things
that you can do is as you're working on
new features within your project you can
create branches you can merge your
branches with the mainline code you can
do lots of really creative things that
ensure that that a the code remains at
very high quality and b that you're able
to seamlessly add in new features
without breaking the core code so let's
step through some of the concepts that
we have available and get so let's talk
about
forking and cloning and get so both of
these terms are quite old terms when it
comes to development but forking is
certainly a term that goes way way way
back um long before we had distributed
cvs systems such as the ones that were
using with git to fork a piece of
software is a particular open source
project you would take the project and
create a copy of that project and but
then you would then associate a new team
and new people around that project so it
becomes a separate project in entirety a
clone and this is important when it
comes to working with git a clone is
identical with the same teams and same
structuring as the main project itself
so when you download the code you're
downloading exact copy of that code with
all the same security and access rights
as the main code and then you can then
check that code back in and potentially
your code because it is identical could
potentially become the main line code in
the future now that typically doesn't
happen your changes are the ones that
merge into the main branch but also but
you do have that potential where your
code could become the main code with git
you can also add collaborators that can
work on the project which is essential
for projects where particularly where
you have large teams this works really
well when you have product teams where
the teams themselves are self-empowered
you can do a concept what's called
branching and get and so say for
instance you are working on a new
feature that new feature and the main
version of the project have to still
work simultaneously so what you can do
is you can create a branch of your code
so you can actually work on the new
feature whereas the rest of the team
continue to work on the main branch of
the the project itself and then later
you can merge the two together pull from
remote is the concept of being able to
pull in services software the team is
working on from a remote server and get
rebase is the concept of being able to
take a project and re-establish a new
start from the project so you may be
working a project where there have been
many branches and the team has been
working for quite some time on different
areas and maybe you kind of losing
control of what the true main branch is
you may choose to rebase your project
and what that means though is that
anybody is working on a separate branch
will not be able to branch their code
back into the mainline branch so going
through the process of a get rebase
essentially allows you to create a new
start for where you're working on your
project so let's go through forks and
clones so you want to go through the
process so you want to go ahead and fork
the code that you're working on so let's
use this scenario that one of your team
wants to go ahead and add a new change
to the project the team member may say
yeah go ahead and you know create a
separate fork of the actual project so
what does that look like so when you
actually go ahead and create a fork of
the repository you let you go and you
can take the version of the mainline
branch but then you take it completely
offline into a local repository for you
to be able to work from and you can take
the mainline code and you can then work
on a local version of the code separate
from the mainland branch is now a
separate fork collaborators is the
ability to have team members working on
a project together so if you know
someone is working on a piece of code
and they see some errors in the code
that you've created none of us are
perfect at writing code i know i've
certainly made errors in my code it's
great to have other team members that
have your back and can come in and check
and see what they can do to improve the
code so to do that you have to then add
them as a collaborator now you do that
in github you can give them permission
within github itself that's really easy
to do super visual interface that allows
you to do the work quickly and easily
and depending on the type of permissions
you want to give them sometimes it can
be very limited permissions it may be
just to be able to read the files
sometimes it's being able to go in and
make all the changes you can go through
all the different permission settings on
github to actually see what you can do
but you'll be able to make changes so
that people can actually have access to
your repository and then you as a team
can then start working together on the
same code let's step through branching
and get so suppose you're working on an
application but you want to add in a new
feature and this is very typical within
a devops environment so to do that you
can create a new branch and build a new
feature on that branch so here you have
your main application on what's known as
the master branch and then you can then
create a sub branch that runs in
parallel which has your feature you can
then develop your feature and then merge
it back into the master branch at a
later point in time now the benefit you
have here is that by default we're all
working on the master branch so we
always have the latest code the circles
that we have here on the screen show
various different commits that have been
made so we can keep track of the master
branch and then the branches that have
come off which have the new features and
they can be many branches and get so get
keeps you the new features you're
working on in separate branches until
you're ready to merge them back in with
the main branch so let's talk a little
bit about that merge process
so you're starting with the master
branch which is the blue line here and
then here we have a separate parallel
branch which has the new features so if
we're to look at this process the base
commit of feature b is the branch
f is what's going to merge back into the
master branch and it has to be said
there can be so many divergent branches
but eventually you want to have
everything merged back into the master
branch let's step through get rebase so
again we have a similar situation where
we have a branch that's being worked in
parallel to the master branch and we
want to do a get rebase so we're at
stage c and what we've decided is that
we want to reset the project so that
everything from here on out with along
the master branch is the standard
product however this means that any work
that's been done in parallel as a
separate branch will be adding in new
features along this new re-based
environment now the benefit you have by
going through the rebase process
is that you're reducing the amount of
storage space that's required for when
you have so many branches it's a great
way to just reduce your total footprint
for your entire project so get rebase is
the process of combining a sequence of
commits to form a new base commit and
the prime reason for rebasing is to
maintain a linear project history when
you rebase you unplug a branch and
re-plug it in on the tip of another
branch and usually you do that on the
master branch and that will then become
the new master branch the goal of
rebasing is to take all the commits from
a feature branch and put it together in
a single master branch it makes it the
project itself much easier to manage
let's talk a little bit about pull from
remote suppose are two developers
working together on application the
concept of having a remote repository
allows the code to the two developers
will be actually then checking in their
code into a remote repository that
becomes a centralized location for them
to be able to store their code it
enables them to stay updated on the
recent changes to the repository because
they'll be able to pull the latest
changes from that remote repository so
that they are ensuring that as
developers they're always working on the
latest code so you can pull any changes
that you have made to your forked remote
repository to your local repository the
command to be able to do that is written
here and we'll go through a demo of how
to actually do that command in a little
bit good news is if there are no changes
you'll get a notification saying that
you're already up to date and if there
is a change it will merge those changes
to your local repository and you get a
list of the changes that have been made
remotely so let's step through some of
the commands that we have in get so get
in it initializes a local git repository
on your hard drive git add adds one or
more files to your staging area get
commit dash m commit message as a commit
changes the get command commits changes
to head up to the git command commits
changes to your local staging area get
status checks the status of your current
repository and lists the files you have
changed get locked provides a list of
all the commits made on your current
branch get diff use the changes that
you've made to the file so you can
actually have files next to each other
you can actually see
the differences between the two files a
git push origin branch name so the name
of your branch command will push the
branch to the remote repository so that
others can use it this is what you do at
the end of your project git config dash
global username will tell get who you
are by configuring the author name and
we'll go through that in a moment get
config global user email will tell get
the author of by the email id get cloned
creates a get repository copy from a
remote source and get remote add origin
server connects the local repository to
the remote server and adds the server to
be able to push to it get branch and
then the branch name will create a new
branch for you to create a new feature
that you may be working on
git checkout and then the branch name
will allow you to switch from one branch
to another branch git merge branch name
will merge a branch into the active
branch so if you're working on a new
feature you're going to merge that into
the main branch a git rebase will
reapply commits on top of another base
tip and get rebase or reapply commits on
top of another base tip and these are
just some of the popular get commands
there are some more but you can
certainly dig into those as you're
working through using get so let's go
ahead and run a demo using get so now we
are going to do a demo using get on our
local machine and github as the remote
repository for this to work i'm going to
be using a couple of tools first i'll
have the deck open as we've been using
up to this point the second is i'm going
to have my terminal window also
available and let me bring that over so
you can actually see this and the
terminal window is actually running get
bash as the software in the background
which you'll need to download and
install you can also run git batch
locally on your windows computer as well
and in addition i'll also have the
github repository that we're using for
simply learn i already set up and ready
to go all right so let's get started so
the first thing we want to do is create
a local repository so let's go ahead and
do exactly that so the local repository
is going to reside in my development
folder that i have on my local computer
and for me to be able to do that i need
to create a drive in that folder so i'm
going to go ahead and change the
directory so i'm actually going to be in
that folder before i actually create and
make the new folder so i'm going to go
ahead and change directory
and now i'm in the development directory
i'm going to go ahead and create a new
folder
and that's gone ahead and created a new
folder called hello world
i'm going to move my cursor so that i'm
actually in the hello world folder
and now that i'm in the hello world
folder i can now initialize this folder
as a git repository
so i'm going to use the get command init
to initialize and let's go ahead and
initialize that folder so let's see
what's happened so here i have my hello
world folder that i've created and
you'll now see that we have a hidden
folder in there which is called dot get
and we expand that we can actually see
all of the different subfolders that git
repository will create so let's just
move that over a little bit so we can
see the rest of the work
and now if we check on our folder here
we actually see this is users matthew
development hello world dot get and that
matches up with hidden folder here
so we're going to go ahead and create a
file called readme.txt
in our folder so here is our hello world
folder and i'm going to go ahead and
using my text editor which happens to be
sublime
i'm going to create a file and it's
going to have in there text hello world
and i'm going to call this one readme
dot txt
if i go to my hello world folder you'll
see that we have the readme.txt
file actually in the folder what's
interesting is if i select the git
status command what it'll actually show
me is that this file has not yet been
added to the commits yet for this
project so even though the file is
actually in the folder it doesn't mean
that it's actually part of the project
for us to do that we actually have to go
and
select
for us to actually commit the file we
have to go into our terminal window and
we can use the git status to actually
read the files that we have there so
let's go ahead and use the get status
command and it's going to tell us that
this file has not been committed you can
use this with any folder to see which
files and subfolders have been committed
and what we can now do is we can go and
actually add the readme file so let's go
ahead and select at git
add so the git command is add readme dot
txt so that then adds that file into our
main
project and we want to then commit those
files into the main repositories history
and so to that do that we'll hit the the
get command commit and we'll do a
message
in that commit and this one will be
first commit
and it has committed that project what's
interesting is we can now go back into
readme file and i can change this so we
can go
hello get
git is a very
popular version control
solution
and we'll
we'll save that
now what we can do is we can actually go
and see if we have made differences to
the readme text so to do that we'll use
the diff command for get so we do get
def
and it gives us two
releases the first is what the original
text was which is hello world and then
what we have afterwards is what is now
the new text in green which has replaced
the original text
so what we're going to do now is you
want to go ahead and create an account
on github we already have one and so
what we're going to do is we're going to
match the account from github with our
local account so to do that we're going
to go ahead and say get config
and we're going to do dash and it's
going to be a global user dot name and
we'll put in our username that we use
for
github in this instance we're using the
simply learn
dash
github account name
and under the github account you can go
ahead and create a new repository name
in this instance we call the repository
hello dash world
and what we want to do is connect the
local github account with the remote
helloworld.get account and we do that by
using this command from get which is our
remote connection and so let's go ahead
and type that in open this up so we can
see the whole thing so we can type in
git
remote add
origin
https
backslash backslash
github.com
world dot get
that creates the connection to your
hello world account
and now we want to do is we want to push
the files to the remote location using
the get push command commit get push
origin
master
so we're going to go ahead and connect
to our local remote github
so i'm just going to bring up my
terminal window again and so let's
select git remote add origin
and we'll connect to the remote location
github.com
simply
learn
dash
github
slash
hello
dash world dot get
oh we actually have already connected so
we're uh connected to that successfully
and now we're going to push the master
gesh so get push
origin
master
and everything is connected and
successful
and if we go out to github now
we can actually see that our file was
updated just a few minutes ago
so what we can actually do now is we can
go and fork a project from github and
clone it locally so we're going to use
the
fork tool that's actually available on
github let me show you where that is
located
and
here is our branching tool it's actually
changed more recently with a new ui
interface
and once complete we'll be able to then
pull a copy about using the fork's new
http url address
so let's go ahead and do that
so we're going to go ahead and create a
fork of our project now to do that you
would normally go in when you go into
your project you'll see that there are
fork options in the top right hand
corner of the screen now right now i'm
actually logged in with the default
primary account for this project so i
can't actually fault the project as i'm
working on the main branch however if i
come in with a separate id and here i am
i have a different id and so i'm
actually pretending i'm somebody else i
can actually come in and select the fork
option and create a fork of this project
and this will take just a few seconds to
actually create the fork
and there we are we have gone ahead and
created the fork
so you want to set clone or download
with this and so this is the
i select
i'll actually give me the web address i
can actually show you what that looks
like i'll open up my text editor
this doesn't correct
i guess that is correct
so i'm going to copy that
and
i can fork the project locally and clone
it locally i can change the directory so
i can create a new directory that i'm
going to put my files in and then post
in that content into that file so i can
now actually have multiple versions of
the same code running on my computer
can then go into the fault content
and use the patchwork command
to actually
so i can create a copy of
that code that we've just created and we
call it that's a clone and we can create
a new folder that we're actually putting
the work in and we could for whatever
reason we wanted to we could call this
where folder patchwork and that would be
uh maybe a new feature and then we can
then paste in the url of the new
directory though it has the forked work
in it and now at this point we've now
pulled in and created a clone of the
original content
and so this allows us to go ahead and
fork out all of the work for our project
onto our computer so we can then develop
our work separately
so now what we can actually do is we can
actually create a branch of the fork
that we've actually pulled in onto our
computer so we can actually then create
our own code that runs in
that separate branch
and so we want to check out um the the
branch and then push the origin branch
down to our computer
this will give us the opportunity to
then add our collaborators so we can
actually then go over to
github and we can actually come in and
add in our collaborators
and we'll do that under settings and
select collaborators and here we can
actually see we have different
collaborators that have been added into
the project and you can actually then
request people to be added via their
github name or by email address
or by their full name
one of the things that you want to be
able to do is ensure that you're always
keeping the code that you're working on
fully up to date by pulling in all the
changes from your collaborators
you can create a new branch and then
make changes emerged into the master
branch now to do that you would create a
folder and then that folder in this
instance would be called test we would
then move our cursor into the folder
called test and then initialize that
folder so let's go ahead and do that so
let's call create a new folder and we're
going to first of all change our root
folder and we're going to go to
development
and we're going to create a new folder
we'll call it test and we're going to
move into the test folder and we will
initialize
that folder
and we're going to move some files into
that test folder
call this one test one
and then we're gonna do file save as
this one's gonna be test
two
and now we're gonna commit those
files okay add
that kit add and then we'll use the
dot to pull in all files
and then git
commit
dash m
files
committed
make sure i'm in the right folder here i
don't think i was
and now that i'm in the correct folder
let's go ahead and
and
commit
and it's gone ahead and edit those files
and so we can see the two files that
were created have been added into the
master
and we can now go ahead and create a new
branch and call this one git
branch
test underscore
and let's go ahead and create a third
file to go into that folder
this is
file three
into file save as
we'll call this one
test3.txt
and we'll go ahead and add
that file
to git
add
test3.txt
and
we're going to move from the master
branch to the test branch
git
check
out
test underscore
branch
i switched to the test branch
and we'll be able to list out all of the
files that are in the tech in that
branch now
and we want to go through and merge the
files into one area so let's go ahead
and we'll do git
merge test underscore
branch
and it's well we've already updated
everything so that's good so otherwise
it would tell us what we would be
merging
and now all the files are merged
successfully into the master branch
there we go all merged together
fantastic
and so what we're going to do now is
move from master branch to test branch
so get
check out
test underscore
branch
and we can modify the files the test3
file that we took out
and
pull that file up
and we can
now
modify
and we can then
commit
that file
back
in
and we've actually be able to then
commit the file with one changes and
obviously it's the text free change that
was made
now we can now go through a process of
checking the file back in switching back
to the master branch and ensuring that
everything is in sync correctly
we may at one point want to rebase all
of the work is kind of a hard thing you
want to do but it will allow you to
allow for managing for changes in the
future
so let's switch to it back to our test
branch
which i think we're actually on we're
going to create two more files
let's go to our folder here and let's go
copy those
and that's created
we'll rename those tests
for
and
fi
and so we now have additional files
and we're going to add those into
our branch that we're working on
so we're going to go and select
git add
dash a
and we're going to commit those files
get
commit
dash
a
dash m
adding
two new
files
and it's added in the two new files
so we have all of our files now we can
actually list them out and we have all
the files that are in the branch
and we'll switch then to our master
branch we want to rebase the master
so we do get rebase
master
and that will then give us the command
that everything is now completely up to
date
we can go
get
checkout
master to switch to the master account
this will allow us to then
continue through and rebase the test
branch and then list all the files that
are all in the same area
so let's go
get rebase
test underscore
branch
and now we can list and there we have
all of our files listed incorrectly
choose from over 300 in demand skills
and get access to 1 000 plus hours of
video content for free visit scale up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
now we will be talking about that how
exactly we can make use of maven here in
performing various kind of operations
whether it's a build compilation with
this kind of stuff there so let's talk
about it why exactly we use maven here
now meven is something which
is a kind of a build tool which is there
for most of the job-based projects here
so this tool also helps us in building
up the source code by downloading some
couple of dependencies these
dependencies are something which is
being configured by the developers which
a developer feels that uh the project is
dependent on and he requires those
dependencies to be downloaded so uh this
tool is specifically used to build and
manage any kind of a job-based project
whatever the complexity of the topic or
the project is there so this tool will
be able to handle that particular
requirement or that project
so it simplifies the uh day-to-day work
of a java developer and helps them in
their projects for performing daily to
daily activities
right now meven also helps us in getting
the specific jar files for each and
every project so if you are going you
can pretty much make a jar file var file
or er file any kind of a package
mechanism you can follow for your maven
there so to download the dependencies we
don't have to actually go to the
official website of each and every
software you can easily get it uh the
dependencies of each and every
third-party bin race on the
mvnrepository.com this is a website
which is present on which if you visit
you will be able to download the
dependencies which is required by your
project or by your
specific
project over here so it totally depends
on how exactly you want to download and
you want to get together a specific
repository over here so
mvnrepository.com is the one if you
visit you will be able to download and
go through all the jar files dependent
jar files as independences which you
require for your current project
right so now what exactly is a maven all
about so let's see on that part
so
maven is a popular open source build
tool which is uh developed by the apache
group and the primary uh ownership of
this tool is to build publish and deploy
several projects at once movement is
written in java and it can be used to
build projects written in c shaft scala
ruby etc so apart from java these are
the different programming languages or
the tools which is supported by the
maven here for performing the build
activity so the tool is used for build
and management of any kind of a java
based project it simplifies the
day-to-day work of a java developer and
helps them to automate most of the
compilation or build uh perspective
tasks on the projects
right now maven is a kind of a
bomb-based project so it also known as
an project object model and it focuses
on of simplification and standardization
of the building process in the process
it take cares of all the followings here
omitted and standardized here so all
these particular mechanisms is can be
followed as such over here so that we
can have a good
standards and the simplifications
implemented as such here now in this one
we are going to talk about that how we
can work on maven installation on
windows and ubuntu platform here so
first of all we'll do it on the windows
platform here and we'll see that how the
installation really works so for this
one i will be doing the installation
into my local system now before even
going for maven maven is in kind of a
build tool which is available there
primary for performing any kind of build
automation for the java based projects
now since it's used for java we also
require the jdk installation onto our
system so for that both of the
installations we will be covering over
here and we'll see that how the
installation really works as such over
here right so before even going for
maven we have to install the jdk onto
our windows machine so that we can
proceed with maven because maven
requires the jdk installations to be
there now there are two ways of getting
installation either you go for the exe
file or you'd extract the binaries of
jdk to a directory and then set up the
java underscore home path for that but
if you are using the executable that
will perform the path configurations for
you also so in that case you don't have
to reconfigure it again and again so
that's what we are going to see here so
first of all we will try to do the
installation of jdk so for that we'll go
to the website of jdk and then we have
to click on this one to access the maven
installations part here so that's what
we are going to do so let's proceed and
let's open the chrome and try to go
through these two urls so that we can do
the installations one by one
so here i have to just search for jdk8
download so
it will show me the url for oracle.com
so here you will get the jdk for the
different platforms for different
operating systems now here what you can
see here that you have the
configurations in which you have the jdk
installation so we have to so here i'll
go for the windows 64 version because
that is something i will be using to do
the installation so this is the complete
executable link so here you can download
so we are downloading the sdk a to you
251 so
just search for windows 64 yeah this is
the one so let me click on this one
let me quickly log into the web page so
once the login is done you will be able
to see that it's trying to download the
exe file so that was for the jdk for the
java now for the maven i am going to go
for the
maven download over here so in this one
the maven ripple link is there maven dot
apache dot o rj is the link for this one
now here we have the different options
you can see here that the binaries of
like archive is there then sources
archive is there so depending on the
installation which you want to perform
you should be able to download that file
and it works there so let's first
install the jdk portion and then we'll
go with this one
so we'll click on this one also anyways
because uh it's something we have to
anyways do it so we'll click on this so
that this maven is also getting started
install or downloading over here so once
both of them are downloaded we will
proceed further with the setup so let's
wait for another one minute to do this
one
so the apache movement is kind of
downloaded over here so we wait for the
jdk download also over here
so next five ten seconds only left out
so first jdk will be there and then
maven installation configurations will
be there so for me one we just have to
extract into a directory and give the
mvn home path into the
properties uh into the variables so that
it can pick it up over there okay so we
have to extract the zip file for maven
give the path and then we will travel
check with the maven command whether
it's working fine or not so let's try to
install the executive so we'll open the
directory where the executables are
there so first of all we'll install the
jdk so we'll double click the installer
for jdk it's all for around 200 mb so
the complete jdk will be installed
so we have to just go for next now when
you go with the installer so usually the
java home parts and all that stuff is
already configured so you don't really
have to change the passwords or java
home any kind of variable you have to
put it up all those things will be
automatically cleaned up
so it's running the installation
close
so then we have to extract the maven so
we have to extract this directory
because here the maven complete
executables and libraries are there so
we just have to extract it and place
into a directory so that we can further
on
use it and access the path so once the
access is done
yep so this is done there so i can
rename it to like maven so i can rename
it like to ask me one and i can cut it
down and put it into the c drive here
now this is the maven home path which is
going to be there right so all i have to
do is that i have to close this one and
this one and this one and this
so what we have to do is that we have to
really go to the system properties so
that we can extract it so i'm going to
open the system properties over here
properties now here the advanced system
settings now in this one we will be
setting up the parts the environment
variable will go now here if you scroll
down you will see all the different
parts which is available there as such
over here
now if we want to see that if the java
is fine or we require for jdk also so
all we have to do is that we have to
open the cmd prompt window r we are
providing so using the window r i'm
opening the run window where i can say
like cmd now in this cmd i'm going to
say like java
hyphen version so java is there so which
means that we don't have any problem as
such
now i'll just go here and set up a new
one called mvn underscore home so here
the same path so you can browse for
directory also but i am using the
ambient home over here in this one
now i have just added that and in the
path variable in the last we have to
actually
add the
bin directory also so that uh whenever
we run the mvn command so that should
also be resolved so mvn underscore home
is not the only variable which you will
be configuring in fact you will be
confirming the path variable also that
you can go ahead and put up a new
directory entry for the cmd here so cmd
till the cmd directory you will go there
and whatever the executable is there you
should be able to resolve that
so for that again you have to open the
window are cmd prompt
java hyphen version
and then you can run mvn iphone version
here
when you run the mv and hyphen version
it will let you know that which
particular java runtime you are using
1.8.0 underscore 251 that the same one
which we have configured and it also let
us know that where exactly the
executable is there and we can now
proceed further with the execution of
the maven pail so you just have to check
out your source code or go to the
directory where source code is there and
you can run the mvn claim install so
that will ultimately go for the build
process so this is the way that how we
can do the installation of maven on the
windows platform now since this is done
now we will go ahead with the second
installation where we are going to do
the installation of maven and jdk on to
the ubuntu machine so for that we will
log into the particular cloud lab of
simply learn lms so let's log into the
lms here so now we are going to do the
installation of uh jdk and maven on the
ubuntu virtual machine here so for that
we will log into the lms so let's log
into that so this is the uh elements
over here here i have already started
the lab here so all i have to do is that
i have to just click on this link here
so it will open the lab into a new tab
it's a gui mode of ubuntu server so
which we will be using to configure it
so uh here uh first of all i can open
the chrome browser also so let me open
the browser here so that i can download
the maven executables as such over here
so jdk we can do it using the package
installation so uh using the app
executable we will be doing the
installation
so i have to just open the terminal here
so once the terminal is opened you have
to log in through the root id now why we
require root id so that we should be
able to do the package installations and
other configurations so that requires
root access
now once that is done you have to run
the
particular
app update command
next you have to install the uh
installer so the oracle installer we
have to install now uh once the setup is
done so let's down install the latest
package over here for eco oracle hyphen
java 14
hyphen installation so this will install
the jdk 14 over here so for that
configurations now at the same time
we'll go for maven download also
so here um
we'll go for download maven so this is
the tar file for executable so i'm going
to copy this
url here
and uh over here we'll say yes
yes
so now uh the java should be configured
and could uh should be set up over here
in this one so what we really need to do
is that we need to run the java command
to see that if the installation is done
properly or not so let's open the
terminal again another terminal so that
i can perform the steps related to maven
so i have got the url so i'm going to
the opt directory which is always an
optional directory where we can do the
setup and all those configurations
so i'm going to run the wget command and
then the url which i have downloaded so
this should uh download the tar file
over here of maven now once that is like
done so i have to extract it so uh tar
hyphen x v z f and the tar file name
this is the target zip file so i have to
use tar hyphen xp zf parameter over here
to extract it now uh what exactly i have
got i have got the apache maven
directory over here so i'm going to
rename it in order to rename it what we
need to do we need to actually go for uh
the particular move command so move
whatever the existing folder you have
and then i'm going to rename it with the
maven directory now once that is done
i'm going to the maven directory and
this is the path or maven underscore
home path which is available as such
over here in this one so here all the
bin directories executables all this
stuff is there so now i can use it like
mv underscore home and the same
configuration just like we did in the
window so here also it the same process
we have to follow so java hyphen version
should be let me know that which version
is deployed so 14.01 version is deployed
over here so for java i do not don't
have to set up the path again here
because i am viewing for the installer
so i don't have to set up the path
right so for maven now what exactly i
have to do i have to go to the edc
profile d now here i'm going to put up a
particular file now here you can see
that we have the jdk a file here which
means that the path variables and
everything is configured as such over
here so you can see that java underscore
home path all these variables are copied
here so i'm going to also create a same
file similar to this one here but in
this case what i'm going to use it that
i'm going to remove some of the values
so i'm going to have some of the
parameters added so in order to do it
effectively i can do the echo command
so that i can copy the things from here
and i can simply put up into the file
here so i'm going to have the path
variable added up over here now why i'm
putting up the paths because it's the
same configuration which we did over
there also so opt slash maven
slash pin so all the pin directory
should be added to the
specific path variable so i'm just
trying to create a file called maven dot
ss just like a jdk dot sh over here i'm
also creating similar kind of file over
here called maven dot sh now i'm not
going in the vi mode or other editors
because i just want to make you
understand that how i'm copying it the
content i'm taking the jdk dot sh as in
reference and putting up the details
over here in this one and then i'm going
to export mvn underscore home over here
which is related to like opt
slash
maven so this is what we are going to
put up over here
and then maven in the end me when this
is the file which you should be having
now why we are using it because of the
fact that it's being used or it will be
utilized in such a way that you can
perform the changes or whatever
configurations you want to perform this
will help you to set up the certain
parts like a path and ambient home so
that you can run these scripts as such
over here so i'm going to give the
executable permissions to this one
and that's it so now what exactly i have
to do is that i have to do the source
here
profile
dot d maven
once that is done i will be able to run
the mvn hyphen version over here and the
jdk part is already open so it's going
to refer to that part so this is the way
that how we configure the mi1 and the
jdk specifically on the ubuntu virtual
machine so pretty much that's it for
this demo in this demo we primarily
talked about that how we can do the
installation of jdk and maven on windows
and how we can do the similar task on
the maven on the ubuntu virtual machine
also here hello everyone welcome to this
demo in this demo we are going to talk
about it how exactly we can do the
installation of maven on the mac
operating system so here we are going to
talk about it how we can do for a
specific setup where we can do for the
installation of maven in a mac operating
system so let's see so there are two
ways of doing the installation here
first is through the
brew executable on the mac now this brew
utility on mac is just like app or yum
utility which is present in most of the
environments or most of the platforms
here but here we are using this brew to
do the installation of maven on the mac
operating system and again the next one
is just in a particular mechanism where
you should be able to have these set up
like you can download the binaries from
the apache website and then you can
export the empty underscore home and the
path variable so that you can start
using the maven executable so we'll talk
about these things and we'll see that
how exactly we can go for this setup so
let's log in uh to a particular
machine or mac operating system so where
we will be able to do all this activity
so this is the mac system which we have
here now in this one what we are going
to do is that we are going to open the
terminal so we are going to open a
terminal here so this is my terminal so
usually in mac you don't require any
other mechanism so the inbuilt terminal
is more than sufficient for doing this
stuff because it's similar to a linux
based platform here so i'm going to run
the command here so first of all i'll
just double check that if my brew
executable is working fine so i'll just
run the brew help command to see that if
my brew is working fine as such over
here in this one now i have the command
called brew install so that is a command
which we need to use now in this one we
have to actually give the
specific package which we want to
install so we will say like brew install
maven
so it will download the uh specific
executables on the system
from the website it will download the
maven executables so it will take some
time but ultimately it's trying to
download it under the particular tar
file so you can see here that it's
downloading the 3.6.3 dar file over here
so uh i can see that the installation is
done so the six point three version
should be installed over here so when i
do like maven uh mvn under hyphen iphone
version over here so you can see that
the uh three point six point three
version is deployed as such over here
now this is something which is done with
the purely command over here called brew
which really helps us to do any kind of
package installations not only may one
other packages also can be installed
pretty much with the help of this
executable
now in order to see the manual stuff
what we really need to do is that we
need to actually clean this uh specific
installation so that i should i will be
able to show you the manual installation
also over here so what i'm going to do
is that i'm going to run the command
called
brew
uninstall maven so that the maven
should be removed from your system so we
are just trying to remove the maven from
here and uh you can see that the maven
executable is not working as such over
here so which means that the maven is
uninstalled in this case but why i have
uninstalled here so that i should be
able to
go ahead and download some custom maven
over here in this one so i have opened
the browser here so i'll go for the
maven executable so we'll go for maven
download so that
we should be able to download a specific
the executable here so i'm going for
this directory so here uh 3.6.3 version
same is available here so i'm going to
download the bin dot dot gz which is
uh the file we have so this is also a
kind of a linux platform right so that's
the reason why uh here the tar file
should work perfectly fine so here i'm
going to the opt directory where we can
have all the optionals
related packages so if it is not there
so i can create a directory called
slash opt
so i can
log in with
root
so if you don't have the root access so
you can go for the applications in the
applications you can actually create a
directory called maven so here i can go
for maven
yeah
so here we will be downloading the var
file here so the uh dot gang file we are
downloading over here so i'll give the
path here so once the
var file or w gate command i am using to
do the installation but sometimes the
wgate is not available so i can go for
the brew install wgate also if that
package is available on video the
installation will be done so we'll try
to do the installation using grublucat
so that we will be able to get a tar
file generated or downloaded there are
other ways also you can download it from
the browser also yeah you can go to the
browser and here you can actually click
and download it and then you can
transfer it locally to this uh specific
directory also so both the possibilities
are there but i'm just trying to
download the double gate command so that
it will be easy for me to do the setup
and to do the download over here so i'm
going to run the same command again
so it will download the tar file so this
is the tar file which is available over
here so i'm going to
extract it over here
so once the extraction is done so i'm
going to rename it like to apache maven
so that i should not have any kind of
versioning or these kind of parameters
over here and the apache daughter
maven hyphen
this star file i'm trying to remove as
such over here so this is what i have
got as an end result over here now this
is the current directory in which i have
these uh applications and these setups
going forward over here so if i run the
mvn hyphen f1 version command
so that will not be giving me any kind
of output over here because
uh still i have extracted the tar file
but that is not the activity is not
complete i have to exactly set up some
environment variables so that i should
be able to run this mvn command so what
i really need to do over here is that we
have to
export certain variables
application slash me1
apache m1 so this is the home directory
which i'm trying to configure over here
and then next thing is that path
variable so i'm going to have we are
going to carry the path variable with
the folder so i'm going to have the
folder structure here
so
the bin directory we have to provide so
i'm going to copy here
and
paste and then i'm concatenated with the
bin here so now my environment variables
are established so my mvian hyphen
iphone version command as you can see
here is that you know it's being picked
up over here but it's saying that the
particular java runtime is not available
so i can go for java view install java
so that should be enough there to
install a java package there so you can
see that it says that it's already
installed so and up to date so that's
the reason why it's not able to do the
installation so i'm going to reinstall
open jdk
because what happens that when we do the
installation some environment variables
related to java should be formatted or
should be extracted over here right so
as you can see that uh here it's saying
that if you want to really use the
executable of java you have to
concatenate the path like this so let's
run that and uh then we can see that the
particular
executable of java will also be find out
over here so java hyphen version showing
that yes it's available there and now my
command
should be able to show me that yes it's
working fine the gdk was already
installed but the problem with that is
that since it's installed into a
particular location so you have to
actually override your path value so
that you should be able to see in that
directory and find out the java
executable so that i have got by doing
the installation i got the command over
there in the output saying that this is
the installation which is done and now
you just have to extract or you have to
just you know put that bar directory
into the specified path variable and
that's how you got the maven and java
both command lines working over here so
this is how you will be doing the maven
installations all together how the
overall installation of maven and the
jdk really works on mac operating system
now what exactly is a maven repository
all about
so maven repository is uh something
which
is a
kind of a directory or it's kind of a
location where we have all the jar files
packaged all together in a single
location so depending on the software
which you want to download the dependent
java files can be downloaded from there
so the metadata refers to the palm files
relevant to each project here this
metadata is what allows maven to
download the dependencies now there are
three type of repositories from where we
can download the dependencies the first
one is the local repository second one
is the remote repository and the third
one is the central repository so these
are the primary three type of
repositories which is available there
for a per specific maven over here
so whatever repository you want to
follow you want to access you can pretty
much access it and you can go with
that
right
now the local repository will be primary
present onto your pc that's the way that
how it's present there and the uh
particular remote repository something
which you can store on any remote
machine or remote server and the central
repository is something which you can
have it onto the internet so usually the
central repositories is something in
which we can actually host our different
kind of dependencies and the jar files
over there
so local repository on the machine of
the developer where the project material
is saved so all the particular
dependencies jar file will be available
on your local machine remote machine is
the location where you can actually
store all your particular dependencies
from where you can download these
dependencies whenever you require it so
this and repositories work similar to
the central repository whenever anything
is needed from the remote repository
it's first downloaded if into your local
repository and then it will be utilized
so if you feel that the dependency is
something which is not there in the
local it will be first downloaded from
the remote repository and then it will
be utilized or will be referenced onto
the local machine there
and central repository is refers to the
maven community repository there where
you will be able to see each and every
dependency present on that repository so
maven downloads the repositories from
here in the local repository whenever
they're needed or whenever required all
these dependencies are cached locally
from where it will be referenced in the
next or you know whenever we want to
refer that we will be able to do that
particular reference easily on that part
so this is the way that how the three uh
particular repositories or movement
repositories really helps us for
performing various kind of automations
as such here
right now what are the basic concepts of
maven here so some of the couple of
basic concepts which is present in maven
is like for the first time we have the
project object model so project bomb
reference to the xml file which has all
the information regarding the project
how this particular project should be
built up how the different build process
should be automated there it also has a
description of the project details
regarding the versioning versioning
information is also stored as such in
this xml file in this
particular form reference file as such
over here the xml file is which is there
in the project home directory so may one
is uh something which search for the
palm file in the current directory if
it's able to find that particular pom
file so it will execute or it will
proceed with the build step otherwise
they it will halt there itself so this
spawn file is very important because it
will act as a kind of a build script and
primarily the maven tool will be able to
process each and everything which is
configured as such in this
specific xml file there and according to
that only it will function or it will
proceed further
right now second thing is the
dependencies and repositories so
dependencies are usually refers to the
java files so the java libraries which
we need in our into our particular
project so while working on the project
we may be having the dependency on
couple of dependencies so these
dependencies we have to actually
download or we have to actually refer
and once these a particular information
or these details are referred so what
will happen that uh we need to download
these uh specific dependencies from the
particular maven repositories so if the
dependencies are not present in your
local repository then maven will try to
download it from the central repository
and cache it into your local repository
but first of all it will look on into
the local repository and if it is not
present in local then it will go to the
remote or the central repository
then we have built life cycles and phase
and goals there so build lifecycles
consist of the sequence of build phases
and each field phase consists of
sequence of goals here now each goal is
responsible for performing a specific
task when a phase is uh running all the
goals related to that phase and its
plugins are also used to following the
compilation preparing the artifacts
downloading the dependencies all
different things being done by the
plugins here
then we have the build profile so build
profiles refers to a set of
configuration values now generally we
have the generic build process for all
the environments all the particular code
base there but sometimes we do have some
kind of a differences there so that is
where we can go for the profiles because
a specific profile can have its own
configuration and whatever it's required
for the build process we can have
different different configurations
stored inside the maven build script
here
then different build profiles are added
to the pom files and which enables the
different uh build as such here so
depending on these profiles we can
actually decide that how we need to
proceed with the build process and how
the different kind of build automations
needs to be performed here
then a build profile helps in
customizing the build for the different
environments so that also we can perform
as such while workforming or while
working on the different components and
the different management here so a build
profile is something which you can
configure you can utilize and depending
on that build profile we will be
deciding whether to proceed further or
how to decide on that particular factor
so these are something which we need to
take care or we need to work according
to see which we can decide that how the
specific configurations and specific
automation needs to be performed here
now
usually when we go for the uh maven
there so we have to use some couple of
maven plugins now the goal of
using these specific plugins is to
automate some of the basic stuff like
compilation creating the var file
creating the java file so when we are
using the plugins we don't have to
configure the steps or write the steps
that how these uh specific plugins
should be installed or should be
referenced it's ultimately the uh
internal configurations which we are
looking forward or which we are using
while working on these specific plugins
so you can download some couple of
plugins using which we will be able to
decide that how a specific goals needs
to be achieved here
so maven has its own standard plugins
that can be utilized so if uh you know
want to go for a custom one so you can
do that but pretty much you can go for
the default one and uh you can pretty
much have some specific goals executed
with the help of these build plugins
now next thing is the maven architecture
so uh in maven what happens that uh
let's talk about the basic architecture
of maven here so
the maven executable when it's deployed
so it usually uh reads the palm.xml file
which is the build script here now once
the specific found xml file is being
read out so it will process the
components it will uh you know download
or it will process the dependencies
plugins life cycles phases and goals and
even the build profiles and uh if any
kind of interaction is required so it
will try to connect to the central
repository or remote repository and
according to that it will provide the
information and provide the details as
such so minimum repository is something
which is very important because it's
ultimately trying to connect to the
maven repository and try to achieve the
various kind of automation here so it's
very important because ultimately it's
trying to help us to go for the uh
complete end-to-end build automation
when we'll go for a specific palm-based
build automation
so um even executable read the palm.xml
file then download the dependencies
defined into the power xml file and that
dependencies are cached locally from the
remote or the central repository now
then create and generate a remote report
according to the requirement and execute
the life cycles phases goals plugins
etcetera so it will process the power
xml file then and whatever the plugins
and goals are the life cycles which is
configured there step by step each of
them will be executed into a sequence
here
now let's talk about the overall build
life cycle of the maven here so what
happens that uh the maven build life
cycle is something which is a kind of a
collection of different steps there and
this is something which is followed to
perform a build automation for a
specific project so they are pretty much
three steps which is being done so first
one is the default so it handles the
project deployment there second handles
the project cleaning which is a clean
there and then we have site so it
handles the creation of the project
sites documentation there
so these are the three built-in
particular life cycles which is
available there at the beaver level
which you can utilize to perform a
various kind of particular steps
execution for your project
all right so the build cycle has uh the
different build phases or stages there
because when we are performing a build a
variety of things needs to be performed
over here so the first one is the
compile then test compile is there so
compilation is there for the source file
and test compile is there for the test
cases test will execute the test cases
package will package the bundle then we
have the integration test to run the
integration test cases then we have the
verify then install goal is there and
the last one is the deploy which is
there to deploy the artifacts to the
artifact tree so all these things are
the different phases and the stages
which is being followed as per a
specific build here so during these
builds these are the different phases
and these stages which we normally
follow for performing the build
automation
now what is the exactly advantage of a
specific maven here so that is something
which we need to talk about that how the
particular automation needs to be done
or how we can actually go for the
configurations where we feel that yes we
want to perform or we want to
take certain benefits out of the
implementation of maven here so for that
what happens that we have to see that
the various kind of uh benefits the
first one is that apache maven helps
manage all the processes there such as
building documentation releasing and
distribution in project management here
so the tool uh simplifies the process of
project building it increases the
performance of the project and the
building process all together and the
task of downloading jar files and other
dependencies is also done automatically
we don't have to indulge in any kind of
download part as such manually over here
right and maven provides easy access to
all the required information so may 1
makes it easy for a specific developer
to build a project in the different
environments so we don't have to worry
about the environment we don't have to
worry about the infrastructure nothing
is required everything is available
there inside this package and you know
depending on the particular you can
write the source code on one machine and
you can pretty much do the build on
another machine and this is the reason
how the build automation really happens
on the first place because the developer
is writing the source code in one
location and the same code is deployed
onto the uh particular or built onto
this jenkins or any kind of build tool
there
right in maven you can easily add new
dependencies so you must write the
particular dependencies in the form file
so if you feel that you want to download
some particular dependencies so all you
have to do is that you have to put that
dependency into the
specific form.xml file there and
depending on that the execution will be
really performed and executed as a chair
right so let's talk about the demo now
so let's see that how exactly we can go
for this demo and we can perform the
various kind of automations
so this is the virtual machine which we
have here on which the maven is already
installed so we can run like mvn
so maven will be available as in
point 3.6.3 here now i'm going to run a
particular command called uh mvn
archetype generate here
let me create a directory here
our temp directory
and to perform this activity over there
so mvn
archetype
generate now once we run that so what
will happen that it will uh download
some of the binaries there because
uh ultimately what we are trying to do
is that we are trying to generate a new
project like a maven project so a couple
of uh particular plugins will be
downloaded by the maven executable so
that it can achieve that particular
execution so we just have to wait for
downloading all these values now here
it's trying to give us a particular
attributes like it's asking the
different attributes over here so what
exactly we want to configure so if you
want to configure you can provide that
details otherwise you can perform or
whatever the setup you want to perform
now here it's asking for the version so
uh which kind of version we want to
follow so i'm going to follow like five
here so i'll press five
then a group id which is there so uh
it's basically a kind of a group
mechanism so i can say like com
dot simply learn so that's the value
which i'm providing here artifate id i
can make it like a
sample project or something like that
i can do
so that will be the artifact uh
id which is there so
version i'm keeping the same only so
and uh yeah so package same here
so i just want to create so i'll just
provide the value called yes and enter
so with this what will happen that a
sample project will be created here
right so whatever the artifact id you
provided so according to that the
project is created in this directory so
you have to go into this directory and
see that what exactly the files are
created there so you have the power.xml
file now this form.xml file when i open
so you can see here that there are some
attributes like you can have the values
uh related to what version or group id
you want to follow so this is a group id
this is the artifact id so this is jar
file by default you can change it
according to your requirement then this
is the version and if you feel that you
want to do the changes to the name that
also you can perform here
so by default the junit dependency is
added but if you want to keep on adding
your own custom dependencies you will be
able to do that
now in this case if you run like mvn
clean install so it will be considered
as in particular maven project a
pawn.xml file is already there present
in the local directory so according to
that the execution of the steps will be
performed and according to that you will
be able to get some desired values here
so ultimately in the target directory
you will be able to see that some couple
of jar file or a specific jar file is
generated here so you can see that in
the target directory this jar file or
this artifact is generated here so this
is a way that how we can actually go for
a generic one like a new particular
project and later on you can depending
on your uh understanding you can keep on
adding or you can keep on modifying the
dependencies and that's how you can get
the final result there
so that's it for this demo uh in which
we have find out that how exactly we can
go for a particular project preparation
with the help of mvn executable
welcome everyone to this topic in which
we are going to talk about that what
exactly is the different maven interview
questions here now in this one we are
going to talk about what are the
different questions some couple of
questions we are going to go through and
we will try to understand that what
exactly the answers are
now uh let's talk about the first
question over here so what exactly is in
maven here so meven is nothing but a
kind of a popular open tool uh open
source build tool which is available
there now before uh maven there were a
couple of build tools which was present
like and and you know a lot of other
legacy tools was present there but
after that maven is something which was
uh released as an open source tool and
it really helps the organization to uh
automate some couple of build processes
and you know have some particular
mechanisms like build publish and deploy
off of different different projects at
once itself so it's a very powerful tool
which can really help us to do the build
automations we can integrate them with
the other tools like jenkins and you
know we can automate them we can
schedule the builds so a lot of various
advantages we can get with the help of
this tool here it's primarily written in
java and uh it can be used to build up
various other kind of projects also like
c sharp scalar ruby etc so all these
other typical tools can also be built up
with the help of this tool so this tool
is primarily uh used to do the uh
particular development and management of
the artifacts in the java based projects
so uh for most of the java based
projects nowadays this is the default
tool and it's already integrated with
the eclipse also so when you go for a
new wavelength project automatically uh
it will be created for a java project
you can use it for other languages also
but yes
default choice of java of of the java
programming language is maven build tool
only
now let's talk about next question so
what does the maven help with so may
when apache maven helps to manage all
the processes such as build process
documentation release process
distribution deployment preparing the
artifact so all these tasks is being
primarily taken care by the apache maven
so this tool simplifies the process of
project building it also increases the
performance of the project and the
overall building process so all these
things are something which is being
taken care by the specific maven tool
here so it also uses the particular uh
you know it downloads the jar files of
the different dependencies for example
if your
source code is dependent on some of the
apache web server uh jar files or some
of the other third-party jar files in
that case you don't have to download
those jar files and keep in some
repository or keep it in some lib
directory you just have to mention that
dependency in the maven and that jar
file will be downloaded during the build
process and will be cached locally so
that's the biggest advantage which we
get with maven that you don't have to
take care of all these dependencies
anywhere into your source code system so
meven provides easy access to all the
required information it uh helps the
developer to build the projects and uh
without you know even worrying about the
dependencies processes or different
environments or different because it's
an uh kind of a tool which can be used
in any platform linux or windows so they
don't have to do any kind of conversions
so all they have to do is that they have
to just add new dependencies and that
should be updated into the form file and
depending on that dependencies the
source code will be built up and they
don't have to refer any kind of
third-party jar files so they don't have
to play with the class bars during the
build process so no customizations is
actually required with this one now the
next question is that what are the
different elements that may one take
cares of so there are different kind of
elements which is being taken care by
maven so uh
these particular parameters are elements
are bills
dependencies reports distribution
releases and mailing list so these are
the typical different different uh
elements which is being taken care by
the maven during the build process and
during the preparation of the builds
here so all these things you can they
can explore they can extract on that
part and they can fully understand that
how they can work on all these different
different processes now next question is
that what is the difference primary
difference between the and and maven
first of all both of them are primarily
used for the javascript so and is the
older version and maven is something
which was launched after the ad here so
and has no formal conventions like so
which can be uh you know coded into the
build.xml file there but yes the maven
has convention so information is not
required as such in the palm.xml file
there so ant is procedural whereas maven
is declarative over here so and does not
have any kind of life cycle so it
depends on you that how you program the
and there but
maven is having a lot of life cycles
there which we can configure we can
utilize so the uh and related scripts
are not reusable because you cannot
reuse it and you have to do some kind of
customizations in order to work on that
but yes maven is not having much of the
project related any kind of dependencies
they can be easily reusable there
because there is nothing about the
palm.xml file it's just the artifact
name and the dependencies which is uh
something we can override or we can
change and then the same palm.xml file
we can reuse as such for the new project
also so that is where the reusability
comes into the picture now and is a very
specific build tool so we don't have to
there is no plugins as such which is
available there you just have to code
everything that what build process you
want to prepare
whereas in case of maven we have the
concept of plugins which can really help
us to understand that how we can make or
use of these plugins so that we can have
the reusability implemented so these are
some of the differences which is
available there between the ant and
maven here now next thing is that what
exactly isn't palm file all about so
palm file is nothing but it's kind of a
xml file which is available there and
it's have having all the information
regarding the project and the
configuration details so it primarily
used over here that how the
configuration needs to be done and how
the setup should be performed as such
here so palmettoxml file is the build
script which we prepare uh you can
prepare it uh using a particular
component or you can have a particular
mechanisms or if you feel that you want
to have some kind of setup so all these
things typically can be implemented can
be done with the help of build tools so
build tools can be really helpful for us
to do the automations and it can really
help us to understand that how some
build processes we can automate with
simply with the help of palm.xml file
here so the developers usually put up
everything inside these uh dependencies
in the palm.xml file here so this is the
file which is uh usually present in the
home directory it's in the current
directory so that once the build is
triggered it will be picked up from that
directory and according to the steps
according to the content of the palm.xml
file the build will be processed or will
be created here now what i'll include
into the palm file here so the different
components which is included into the
palm dot xml file here is the
dependencies
uh developers and contributors plugins
plugin configuration and resources so
these are the typical components which
is a part of a permanent xml file which
can be uh same for a lot of projects you
can do some customization and then the
same palm file can be reused for the
other projects also now what are the
minimum requirement of the elements
which is there for a palm for a palm xml
file so without which the pound.xml file
will not be validated and will will be
getting a kind of validation errors so
the minimum required elements are
project root
model version so it should be 4.0.0 the
group id of the project the artifact id
of the project and the version of the
artifact these are the minimum things
which we want to define so that we can
understand that what kind of artifact we
are trying to prepare or we are trying
to create here so these are the minimum
required elements which is required in
the palm.xml file without which the
validation of the palm file will fail
and the build will also fail here
now what exactly is the mint uh with the
term called build tool so build tool is
an essential tool is a kind of a process
for building or compiling the source
code here so it's needed or it's
required for the below for generated
processes if you want to generate the
source code if you want to compile the
source code you want to generate the
source code you want to generate some
documentation from the source code you
want to compile the source code or you
want to package the source code whether
it's a jar file it's a war file or it's
an er file so whatever the packaging
mode you want to select you will be able
to do it with the help of the particular
build tool here and if you feel that you
want to upload these particular
artifacts to the artifactory whether
it's on remote machine or locally there
so that also you can do it with the help
of this particular build tools here so
build tools can be helpful in doing a
lot of activities for the developers
now one of the different steps which is
involved to install maven on windows now
all you have to do is that you have to
just first of all download the uh tar
file from the maven apache maven
repository there once that is done so
what happens that you have to set up
some couple of environment variables now
if you download the java jdk using the
exe file in that case the java undisco
home will be configured automatically
but if it is not available and you're
not able to run the java command line in
that case you have to set up the java
underscore home and then similarly for
maven you have to go for the maven
undisco home that particular variable
you have to configure now once that is
done all you have to do is that you have
to edit the path variable so the bin
directory of the maven extracted folder
you have to put it up into the path
variable and once that is done what will
happen that you will be able to
check the latest version the version of
the maven over there if it is like some
old version again you have to extract
the latest version and do the steps all
together again so these are some of the
ways that in which you can actually go
for the installation or the
configurations of maven on the windows
platform
now what are the different steps which
is involved for the installation of
maven and ubuntu so ubuntu it's fine you
just download the package of java jdk
there once the jdk is installed over
there what you can do you can simply go
and say that yes i want to search for a
particular maven
package which is available there so once
the jdk is installed all you have to do
is that you have to configure the java
underscore home m3 underscore home main
and disco home and the path variable
once all the path variables are
something which is configured then you
will be able to check the latest version
like whether it's
the version is correct or we are getting
the standard version over here or not
over here so that's the main mechanism
that how we will be able to you know
configure the maven on ubuntu here now
what exactly is the command to install
char into the locals repository now
sometimes what happens that we are not
able to fetch like uh some dependencies
not present on the uh particular central
repository minimum repository or your
artifactory repository in that case you
have some third party jar which we want
to install locally onto your repository
so in that case we can go for the uh but
we can download the java file there and
then we can run the command called mvn
install install hyphen file and then we
are giving the path like hyphen d file
where the path of the file should be
provided now once that is done so what
will happen that in the local dot m2
directory this specific artifact will be
downloaded and will be installed there
so this is a mechanism where you will be
able to configure or you will be able to
set up the artifacts locally the java
file locally here in the local
repository so next question is that how
do you know that the version of the
maven being used here so the inversion
of the maven is pretty easy to calculate
so all you have to do is that you have
to just go for mvn and space hyphen
iphone version the moment you do that it
will let you know that what jdk or what
java version you are using and it will
also show you that what particular maven
version you're going to use here so all
that details you will be able to get
with that particular command here
now what exactly is the clean default
and frightened variable here so these
are the build cycles which is available
there in within maven so these are the
built-in build cycles so for clean what
happens that this life cycle will help
you to perform the project cleaning so
usually during the build there are some
files which is created into the target
directory so the clean life cycle is
essentially helping us to clean up all
that directory all that particular
target directory and when we talk about
the specific default so default
lifecycle handles the projector
deployment that is the default uh
lifecycle and site is something which is
uh you know helpful for creating the
site documentation you know it's kind of
a life cycle which is available there so
clean default and site are the different
life cycles which can perform different
different kind of uh attributes or
different tasks here next question
what exactly is a movement repository so
maven repository refers to the
directories of the package jar files
that contain metadata now the metadata
refers to the palm files relevant to
each project so here you can able to get
your artifacts uh stored there you can
download these artifacts also during the
maven build if you put up that
dependency you will there are different
kind of repositories which is available
there one is the local repository one is
the remote repository and one is the
central repository so these are the
different typical type of repositories
which we have where we can store the
artifacts also and from where we can
download the artifacts also whenever
required now the first one is the local
repository so local repository refers to
the machine of the developers itself
where all the project related files are
stored there now whenever we work on the
uh particular maven so there is an in
the home directory dot m2 folder is
created now usually whatever the
artifacts downloaded from artifactory or
from the maven repository it gets cached
locally there and once it is downloaded
next time it will not download the same
artifacts of the same dependency
altogether again so this local
repository is something which is
available locally on the developers
machine only so it contains all the
dependent jars which a particular
developer is downloading during the
maven build now remote repositories
refers to the repository which is
present on the server and uh from where
we will be downloading the uh particular
dependencies so the when when we are
running the maven build on a fresh
machine so usually over there the local
repository does not exist so in that
case what happens that the dot m2
directory is empty but the moment you
run the build what will happen that the
artifacts or the dependencies will be
downloaded from the remote repository
and uh once it is done once it's uh
downloaded it will be added or it will
be downloaded cached locally there and
it will be
helpful in the future run so that will
be
considered as a local repository because
all the artifacts all the dependencies
are downloaded there and central
repository is something which is known
as the maven community where all the
artifacts is available there so usually
we cache or we mirror these central
repositories as our particular remote
repositories because it could be a
possibility that these remote
repositories are something which we are
hosting into our organization and
central repository is something which is
available centrally for everyone to use
it so
these are something you know some kind
of repositories where each and every
artifacts will be stored and anyone will
be able to have the access to these uh
particular artifacts here so these
artifacts are every artifacts every open
source uh artifacts is something which
is available over there to these central
repository now how does the maven
architecture really work here so the
meeman architecture really works in the
three steps the very first step is that
it reads the palm.xml file here that's
the very first step second it downloads
the dependencies uh defined in the power
xml file into the local repository from
the central or the remote repository
here once that is done so it will uh you
know create or generate the reports
according to the life cycles which you
have configured whether it's a clean
install
site deploy package or whatever the life
cycle you want to trigger you will be
triggering that particular life cycle
and corresponding to that the build or a
specific task will be performed so these
are the three steps in which the overall
build or any kind of uh execution of
palmer xml file really happens here now
what exactly is the maven build
lifecycle so maven lifecycle isn't
nothing but collection of steps here
that needs to be uh followed for doing a
proper build of a project here so there
are primary three built-in cycles which
is available there default which handles
the project deployment clean which
handles the project uh cleaning there
and site which handles the creation of
the project sites documentation so these
are the three primary built-in build
cycles life cycles which is available as
such
now so build lifecycle has you know
different kind of phases or the stages
here because in the previous uh
particular slide we were talking about
what what are the different uh
particular build life cycles which is
available there but these are the
different phases like what are the
different step-by-step executions like
further deep down which is available
there inside a specific maven build life
cycle so here you can see that it's
compiling then the test compile test
execution is there then package
integration test to verify install and
the lastly deploy here so these are the
different build phases which is
available as such over here so what
exactly is the command to use to do a
particular maven site so mvn site is
something which is used to create a
maven site here now usually whatever the
artifacts is prepared that will be
prepared in the target directory so here
also you will be able to see a site
directory which is available there in
the target directory which you can refer
for the site documentations what is the
different conventions used while naming
a project in may 1. so usually it
involves three components
so the full name of a project in maven
includes first of all the group id uh
for example count at apache
com.example so these are some of the
particular way that where you can
provide the group id artifact id can be
exact project name like maven project or
whatever the project you are creating so
sample project example project so these
kind of things will be there in the
artifact id and lastly is the version
like which version of your artifact you
want to prepare like 1.0.0 hyphen
snapshot
2.0.0 so like this information you are
providing that what particular version
you are trying to configure here now
let's move on to the intermediate level
where we will be having a little bit
more complex questions related to the
maven here now what exactly is in maven
artifate now usually what happens that
when we do a build process as an end of
result of the build process we will get
some artifacts for example when we build
a.net project so there we will be able
to have exe or dll files as an artifacts
similarly in case of maven when we do a
build process there we get the different
kind of artifacts like depending on the
packaging mode like jar file
var files or the er files here so these
are something which is you know getting
generated during the build process
during the main process and you can
store them into your local repository or
you want to push them to the remote
repository it's something that totally
depends on you so maven is a tool which
can help you to create all the artifacts
whether it's a jar file whether it's a
var files or whether it's a er file here
and every artifact is having three
attributes the first one is the group id
the artifact id and a particular version
and that's how you will be able to
identify a full-fledged artifact as such
in maven so maven is not about only the
name of the jar file it's actually
referring to the attributes like crop id
the artifact id and the version of the
artifact here now what are the different
phases of the clean life cycle here so
clean is something which is being used
to clean the target directory so that a
fresh build can be triggered there so
there are three steps pretty clean clean
and post clean here so if you wish that
you want to override the particular life
cycle configurations and you want to run
some particular steps before the clean
activity so you can do it into the
pre-clean and if you want to do it like
some steps after clean then pour screen
can be utilized now what are the
different phases of the a site life
cycle so pre-site
site post site and site deploy so these
are the different phases which is
available there in the site life cycle
what is exactly we meant by the maven
plugin now this is the huge difference
between the ant and me one here because
in and we were not having this that much
support of the plugins and that's the
reason why we had to deal with all the
build configurations
so we have to simply put the overall
build process that how the build should
be triggered but that is not something
which is there in case of maven in maven
we have a lot of flexibility because we
can actually put up what exactly build
configurations we want to put here we
can put some features like important
features over here in maven and uh these
plugins we can utilize for example i
want to perform a compilation now i
don't really want to do any kind of for
configurations in this one so what i can
do is that i can simply use the
compilation plugin in maven and that can
really help me because
i don't have to unnecessarily write or
rewrite the configuration that how the
compilation should be done
it's something which is pre-configured
or pre-written in these plugins that i
can simply import the plugin and i can
do the build process or the compilation
process in a pretty standard mode so i
don't really have to do any kind of
workarounds with that and simply with a
small automations i will be able to
reach that how these maven plugins can
be integrated into my palmer xml file
and i can desire or i can have some
particular procedures and some steps
executed there so that's the biggest
benefit which we really get with the
help of maven plugins now why exactly
the maven plugins are utilized so to
create a jar files to create the war
files to compile the code files to
perform the unit testing to create the
project documentation and to create the
project reports so there are variety of
things in which we can actually use
these maven plugins through the
integrations within the palm.xml file
there so it's all about the plugins you
just import the plugin and that desired
activity will be performed there now
what are the different type of plugins
which is there so
you can have either build projects
for performing the build activities you
can have some build plugins for
reporting plugins also there which can
be only generated or utilized to
generate the reports to process the
reports and do any kind of formatting or
any kind of processing on the reports
here so that is where the reporting
plugins are utilized now what is exactly
the difference between the convention
and the configuration in maven so
convention is in particular process when
the developers are not required to
create the build processes so
configuration is when you know the
developers are supposed to create the
build processes
so the users do not have to rectify the
configuration in detail and once the
project is created it will automatically
create a structure so they must specify
every in case of configuration you have
to provide each and every details so
that's how the uh configurations really
happens because
you have to put every detail into the
power xml file and that's how the
particular configurations really work as
such so this is the huge difference
between the conventions and the
configurations here
now
so why exactly said that maven uses
conventions over the configuration may
maven pretty much does not puts any
efforts like on the particular uh
developers that they have to put each
and every configuration so there are
some ready-made uh plugins which is
available there and pretty much we are
making use of that so that in such a
case we don't have to worry about the
executions and we will be able to pretty
much work on that so conventions like
maven uses the conventions incident of
the configurations so the developers
just you know they don't just have to
create the human project the rest of the
particular structure will be can gear
automatically so they are not uh you
know expecting that the developers
should be doing the configuration work
and everything should be taken care in
such a way that you just have to start
the things and the rest of the things
should be taken care by the maven itself
so maven will be uh responsible because
they do the plugins it will be
responsible to set up the default
architecture the default folder
structures and all you have to do is
that you have to just
place the source code in the desired
folder structure here so that's
something which you need to do as on
particular developers so what exactly is
the maven order of inheritance here so
the order of inheritance is the settings
cli parameters
parent palm and the project bomb which
means that if you have some
configuration and settings that will be
the highest value then the cli
parameters are there then the parent
palm is there and then the project pump
so this is the way that how the
particular parameters or the
configurations will be picked up by the
may one so that's the order so what does
the build life cycles and the phases
imply in the basic concept of maven so
build life cycles consist of a sequence
of build phases and each build phase
consists of a sequence of goals when a
phase is run
uh all the goals related to that phase
and its plugins are also compiled so you
will be able to have a lot of particular
goals which is residing inside of phase
there and similarly life cycle is
nothing but a kind of a sequence of the
different phase so life cycle comes in
the top then it comes on the phases and
then it comes on the goals here now what
is the terminology called goal in case
of maven the term a terminology goal
refers to the specific task that makes
it possible for the the project to be
built and organized so it's something
which we can run so it's an actual
implementation which is going on there
for example in the build process in the
live build phase i have a different
goals like clean install
package deploy these are the different
typical goals which is available there
which i can execute into the main one
here so these are the different goals
like uh which we can execute and which
we can run during a maven build next
question is what is exactly meant by the
term dependencies and the repositories
in maven here so dependencies refer to
the java libraries which we usually put
up into the bound.xml file there now
what happens that sometimes our source
code is requiring some java files like a
secondary jar files for performing the
build process so instead of downloading
it and uh storing it into the class path
for during the build process we just
have to specify the dependency of that
artifact what dependency we need to put
and once that dependency is put up there
we will be able to have that jar file
downloaded and cached into the local
repository during the maven build
project
now if the dependencies are not present
in your local repository then maven will
try to download it from the central
repository and again if it is not uh uh
you know
it's something which is available which
is downloaded from the central
repository then it will be cached
locally into the local repository so
that's the cycle which is being
implemented and utilized during this
process
now what exactly is in snapshot in maven
so snapshot refers to the version
already available in the movement report
repository it signifies the latest
development copy that's what we do with
the case of snapshot here some even
checks for a new version of snapshot in
the remote repository for every new
build so during the build process like
uh you know a new snapshot version is
being downloaded and the snapshot is
updated by the data service team which
uh with updated source code every time
to the repository for each maven bit so
snap shot is something which we will be
using like very frequently we will be
updating to that and frequently we will
be updating the version to that and we
will try to explore and we'll try to do
the modifications now what are the
different type of projects available in
maven so there are thousands of java
projects which you know uh can be
utilized or we can be uh implemented by
my one here so this helps the as the
user that they as they no longer have to
remember every configurations to set a
particular project for example spring
boot spring mvc spring boot etc these
are the different projects which is
already available in maven so most of
the we have already discussed that uh
for the job-based projects maven is
something which is you know considered
as by default so a lot of organizations
are actually using it for you know
storing or utilizing it for the uh
particular maven project now what
exactly is the maven uh archetype over
here so maven octave refers to a maven
plugin that is uh entitled to create a
for project structure as per its
template these archetypes are just
project templates that are generated by
maven when any new project is created
there so this is something which we are
using so that we will be able to create
a fresh new projects right so let's go
on to the advanced level of this maven
questions now what exactly is the
command to create a new project based on
an archive type so mvn archetype
generate is used to create a new java
project based on the archetype now this
will take up some parameters from
as an end user from you and depending on
the parameters it will create the
palm.xml file it will create the source
directories uh inside that main java
test all these different couple of
directories directory structures will be
automatically created now why we require
this command so that if you are going to
create a project from scratch from the
uh from the day one this command will
help you to have all the folder
structures created and then further on
you can put up your source code and
those files as such in this folder
structure so that's how is the mechanism
that we will be able to see that how the
setup can be performed really over here
now what does maven clean implies now
movement clean is a plugin that suggests
that it's going to clean the files and
directories there so whenever we do a
build process usually in the target
directory we have some class files some
jar files or whatever the generated
source code which is available that will
be present in the target directory so
the maven clean is something which is
available which is going to clean all
these directories and why we are doing
this directly structure cleanup so that
we will be able to do a fresh uh build
process and there should not be any kind
of
issues as such over here so that's the
main reason why we are looking forward
for this uh particular mechanism or for
this uh particular changes as such here
now so what exactly isn't build profile
all about so build profiles refers to
the set of configurations uh where we
can have like typically two different
kind of build processes there so if you
feel that the same pom.xml file you can
use you want to run for different
different
particular configurations so that you
will be able to do pretty much with the
help of this component so build profile
is used to do a customization processes
so that you will be able to have the
process and you will be able to
perform the configurations and the
setups all together there so that's a
very important aspect to be considered
that which we need to uh discuss when we
talk about the build profile so build
profile whenever you feel that you want
to do some customizations and you want
to proceed with the setup so that's
where it's utilized next thing is that
what are the different type of build
profiles which is available there so the
build profiles can be done on for a
particular project like per project you
can do you can uh even do the build
profiles in the settings.xml file also
and if you feel that you want to do it
into the globalsettings.xml file so that
also you can do as such over here so
there are different ways in which you
can do the customization and once the
customization is done you will be able
to have the different ways of doing the
setups and the configurations over there
so what exactly is meant by the uh
particular system dependencies here so
let's talk about that also so system
dependencies refers to the uh particular
mechanisms where we feel that uh how the
dependencies should be uh you know
present there so that is something which
is having a scope of system there so
these dependencies are commonly used to
help maven know the dependencies that is
being provided by the jdk
system dependencies are mostly used to
resolve the dependencies on the
artifacts that are provided by the jdk
so these dependencies are somewhat which
is being utilized and used over here so
that we will be able to implement and go
ahead through the system dependencies
what is the reason for using an optional
dependency here so optional dependencies
are used to decrease the transitive
burden of some libraries so what happens
that when you download an artifact when
you put up a dependency so it could be a
possibility that some dependencies as in
particular optional can also be
downloaded now these are not always
required but yes sometimes what happens
that these are downloaded so that you
don't have to put uh each and every uh
artifact or dependency into the power
xml file for example you're trying to
download some apache tool and with that
some like three four jar files or three
four another dependencies are also
getting downloaded now if you are using
that dependencies that totally create
because you don't have to put that uh
list or that entry in the dependency
list in the pound or xml file and that
can really save your time but if you
feel that you don't want to have them
and you these are the optional ones and
you really want to
get rid of that so that also you can
exclude while downloading any kind of
dependencies so these are the optional
ones which depending on your requirement
you can utilize you can
process and if you feel that you don't
want to get it you won't want to process
it you can certainly ignore it and you
can get rid of that also now what is a
dependency scope and how many type of
dependencies scope are there so there
are different type of dependency scores
which is there which is used on each and
every stage of the build here so compile
provided runtime test system import
these are the different kind of
dependency scopes which we have using
which we can define that when exactly we
want to go ahead for a specific build
process so depending on your requirement
you can explore all these build scopes
and you can get benefits out of that
what is exactly an intransitive
dependency in maven so maven avoids the
need to find out and specify libraries
that our own dependencies require by
including the transitive dependencies
automatically so transitive dependency
says that if e depends if x depends on y
and y depends on z then x depends on y
and both there
so which means that you are not
dependent on one artifact you also need
the z artifact there with the y artifact
so that is what you need to do so that
you will get both the dependencies there
because this is normal that if you are
trying to
download some particular artifacts or
download some dependency and that
dependency is also dependent on some
other artifact or some other jar file
then you have to include both of them so
this is something which you will be able
to get so that you uh can easily
download all these dependent jar files
also and the maven build can be success
how can a maven build profile can be
activated so even build profile can be
activated through a different ways so in
explicitly using the command
command line you can talk about that
which profile you want to execute
through maven settings you can do uh
based on environment parameters os
settings and present and missing files
so these are the different ways in which
you can actually activate that which
particular profile you want to have so
profiles configurations can also be
saved in various situations and various
files and from there you will be able to
refer that which file you want to refer
as such now what is meant by the
dependency exclusion the exclusion is
used to exclude any transitive
dependency because you never know that
if you are trying to put up a dependency
uh entry in the power x1 file that
artifact is also further dependent on
another artifact so in order to feel in
order to see that you want to exclude
that dependent artifact which is being
automatically downloaded that also we
can exclude with the help of exclusion
so you can uh avoid the transitive
dependency with the help of dependency
exclusions here so what exactly is in
mojo so mojo is nothing but maven plain
old java object here so it's an
executable goal in maven and a plug-in
refer to the distribution of such mozos
so moses enable the maven to extend its
functionality that already is not
founded in so it's kind of an extension
which is there and using this we can get
some additional benefits and some
executions over there so what is the
command to create a new project based on
a hard drive
so again archetype is something which we
normally use to create uh the new
projects now you can give the parameters
in the command itself or you want it to
in in kind of an interactive mode where
it will take the parameters from the end
user and according to that the project
will be created onto hard drive or onto
server wherever you wish you want to
create you can create a new project
so explain about the maven settings.xml
file so maven settings.xml file contains
the elements that are used to define
that how the movement execution should
be there so there are different settings
like local remote central all these
different repositories are configured as
such over here now in this case what
happens that uh usually the
configurations are done in such a way
that it can you know go for the uh
executions it can go for the build
process and the complete executions can
be uh involved and can be achieved as
such here so all these executions are
something which we can really perform
and uh here we can put some credentials
how to connect to the remote repository
how to connect to remote repository all
that stuff is something which we talk
about over here what exactly is that
meant by term superbomb here so
superform refers to the default bomb of
maven so the moms of maven can't derive
from so it's nothing but a reference to
a parent bomb which is available there
that is a super pump so if you define
some dependencies in that super pump
automatically the uh child bomb will
also be able to inherit all those
dependencies so we can put some uh
executions like we can put some
configuration in the super pump so that
if multiple uh projects are going to
refer that they should be able to refer
that easily so that's the reason why we
primarily use the super pump so that we
can have the execution some processes
put up over there and all the other
projects should be effort to refer or
inherit from there so where exactly the
dependencies are stored so dependencies
are stored like in different locations
like you have the local repository
remote repository is there local
repositories on the local developers
machine and remote repository something
which is available on a server in form
of artifactory
now let's talk about the gradle
installation because this is a very
important aspect to be done because when
we are doing the installation
we have to download the cradle
executables right so let's see that what
are the different steps is involved in
the process of the cradle installation
so when we talk about the gradle
installation so there are primary four
steps which is available the very first
one is that you have to check if the
java is installed now if the
java is not installed so you can go to
the open jdk
or you can go for the oracle java so you
can do the installation of the jdk on
your system so jdk8 is something you can
most commonly use nowadays so you can
install that
once the java is downloaded and
installed then you have to do the gradle
uh download cradle there now once the
gradle binaries are executable
or the zip file gets downloaded so you
can add the environment variables and
then you can validate if the cradle
installation is working fine as expected
or not so we will be doing the gradle
installation into our local systems and
uh into the windows platform and we'll
see that how exactly we can go for the
installation of cradle and we will see
that what are the different version we
are going to install here so let's go
back to the system and see that how we
can go for the gradle installation so
this is the website of the jdk or for
java oracle java now here you have
different jdk so from there you can do
whatever the
option you want to select you can go
with that so jdk8 is something which is
most commonly used nowadays like its
most comfortable or compatible version
which is available so um in case you
want to see that if the jdk is installed
into your system all you have to do is
that you have to just say like java
hyphen version and that will give you
the output that whether the java is
installing to your system or not so in
case my system the java is installed but
if you really want to do the
installation you have to download the
jdk installer from this website from
this oracle website and then you can
proceed further on that part now once
the jdk is installed so you have to go
for the cradle installation because
gradle is something though which will be
performing the build automations and all
that stuff so you have to download the
binaries like the zip file probably in
which we have the executables and all
and then we have to have have some
particular environment variables
configured so that we will be able to
have the
system modified over there so right now
we have got like the prerequests as in
java version install
now the next thing is that we have to
install or download the executables
so uh in order to download the latest uh
gradle distribution so you have to click
on this one right now over here there
are different options like you want to
go for 6.7 now it's they're having like
binary only or complete we'll go for the
binary only because we don't want to
have the source we just want the
binaries and the executables now it's
getting downloaded it's around close to
100 mb of the installer which is there
now we have to just extract into a
directory and then the same path we need
to configure into the environment
variable so that in that way we will be
able to see that how the uh gradle
executables will be running and it will
give the
complete output to us over here in this
case so it may take some time and once
the particular modifications and the
download is done then we have to extract
it and once the extraction is done so we
will be able to go back and
have some particular version or have the
configurations established over there so
that let's just wait for some time and
then we will be continuing with the
environment variables like this one so
once the installation and the extraction
is done now we just have to go to the
downloads where this one is
downloaded we have to extract it now
extraction is required so that we can
have the setup like we can set up this
path into our environment variables and
once the path is configured and
established we will be able to start
further on that part and on the
execution so meanwhile these the files
are getting started let's see so we
already got the folder structure over
here and uh we will see that we will
give this path here there is two
environment variables we have to
configure one is the cradle underscore
home and one is the um in the path
variable so we'll copy this path here
so meanwhile this is getting uh
extracted we can save our time and we
can go to the environment variable so we
can right click on this one properties
in there we have to go for the advanced
systems settings
then environment variables
now here we have to give it like gradle
underscore home now in this one we will
not be going giving it till the bin
directory so that only needs to be there
where the griddle is extracted so we'll
say okay
and uh then we have to go for the path
variable where we will be adding up a
new entry in this one we will be putting
up till the pin directory here because
the gradle executables should be there
when i am running the cradle command
so these two variables i have to
configure then okay okay
and okay
so this one is done so now you have to
just open the command prompt and see
that whether the execution or the
commands which you're running is is
completely successful or not so
meanwhile it's extracting all the
executables and all those things it will
help us to understand that how the whole
build process or how the build tools can
be integrated over there now once the
extraction is done so you have to run
like cmd
you have iphone version to check the
version of the
java and then the gradle
underscore version is what you're going
to see
check the version of the cradle which is
installed and now you can see that it
says that 6.7 version is being installed
over here in this case so that's the way
that how we are going to have the cradle
installation performed into our
particular system
and in this one
we will be also working on some demos
and some hands-on to understand that how
we can make use of gradle for performing
the build activity so let's begin with
uh the first understanding that what
exactly is incredible all about
now griddle isn't kind of a build tool
which can be used for the uh build
automation performance and it can be
used for various programming languages
primarily it's being used for the
java based applications it's in kind of
build tool which can help you to see
that how exactly automatically you can
prepare the builds you can perform the
automations earlier we used to do the
build activity from the eclipse and we
used to do it manually right but with
the help of this build tool we are going
to do it like automatically without any
uh manual efforts as such here there are
like lot of activities which we will be
doing during the build process primary
there are different activities like
compilations
linkage packaging these are the
different tasks which we perform during
the build process so that we can
understand that how the build can be
done and we can perform the automations
uh this uh process also it's kind of a
standardized because again if you want
to automate something standards or a
standard process is something which we
require for that before we been going
ahead with that part so that's the
reason why we are getting this build
tool because this build tool helps us to
do a standardization process to see that
how the standards can be met and how we
can proceed further with that part
also it's something which can be used a
variety of languages programming
languages java is the primary language
for which we use the gradle but again
other languages like scala android cc
plus plus ruby these are some of the
languages for which we can use the same
tool
now it's actually using like it's
referring to as an trophy based domain
specific language rather than xml
because ant and maven these are the xml
based build tools but this one is not
that dependent on xml it's using the
groupie based domain specific language
dsl language is being used here
right now um again uh it's something
which can be used to do the build uh it
can further only be used to perform the
test cases automations also there and
then further on you can deploy to the
artifactory also that okay i want to
push the artifacts to the artifactory so
that also that part also you can get it
done over here so
primary this tool is known for doing the
build automations for the big and large
projects the projects in which the
source got the amount of source code and
the
efforts is more so in that case this
particular tool makes sense now gradle
includes both the pros of maven and and
but it removes the drawbacks or whatever
the
issues which we face during these two
build tools so it's helping us to remove
all the cons which we face during the
implementation of ant and maven and
again again all the pros of and maven is
implemented with this cradle tool
now let's see that why exactly this
griddle is used because that's a very
valid question that what is the activity
like what is the reason why we use the
gradle because
um the first one is that it resolves
issues faced on other build tools that's
a primary reason because we are already
having the tools like maven and and
which is available there but primarily
this griddle dual is something which is
removing all the issues which we are
facing with the implementation of other
tools so these issues are getting uh
removed as such second one is that it
focuses on maintainability performance
and
flexibility so it's giving the focus on
that how exactly we can manage the big
large projects and uh we can have
flexibility that what different kind of
approaches i want to build today i want
to build in different ways tomorrow the
source code modifies gets added up so i
have the flexibility that i can change
this build script so i can perform the
automations so a lot of flexibility is
available which is being supported by
this tool
and then the last one is like
it provides a lot of features a lot of
plugins now this is one of the uh
benefit which we get in the case of
maven also that we get a lot of features
but again when we talk about cradle then
it provides a lot of plugins like let's
say that normally in a build process we
do the compilation of the source code
but sometimes let's say that we want to
build an angular or a node.js
application now in that case we may be
involved in running some command line
executions some command line commands
just to make sure that yes we are
running the commands and we are getting
the output so there are a lot of
features which we can use like there are
a lot of plugins which is available
there and we will be using those uh
plugins in order to go ahead and in
order to execute those build process and
doing the automations now let's talk
about the cradle and move on because
again when we talk about me when like it
was like something which was primarily
used by the java but again when we are
talking about cradle so again it's just
uh being used primarily for the java
here but what is the reason that
we prefer gradle over the create maven
so what are the different
reason for that let's talk about that
part because this is very important we
need to understand that what is the
reason that gradle is preferred as an
better tool for the java as compared to
maven when we talk about for the build
automation here
now the first one is that the gradle
using the groupie dsl language domain
specific language whereas the maven is
considered as an project management tool
which is uh creating the palms or xml
file format files so it's being used for
the java project but xml format is being
used here and on the other hand griddle
is something which is not using the xml
formats and uh whatever the build
scripts you're creating that is
something which is there in the group
based
dsl language and on the other hand in
the pump we have to create the xmls
dependencies whatever the attributes you
are putting up in the main one that's
something which is available there in
the format of xml the overall goal of
the griddle is to add functionality to a
project whereas the goal of the maven is
to you know to complete a project phase
like to work on different different
project phase like compilation test
executions uh then uh packaging so
then deploying to artifactory so these
are all different phases which is
available there into the maven but on
the other hand gradle is all about
adding the functionality that how you
want to have some particular features
added up into the build scripts in
gradle there are like we usually specify
that what are the different tasks we
want to manage so different different
tasks we can
add up into the case of gradle and we
can override those tasks also in case of
maven it's all about the different
phases which has been happening over
here and it's in sequence manner so
these phases happens in the sync with
order that how exactly you can build up
the sequence there but in case of gradle
you can have your own tasks custom tasks
also and you can disrupt the sequence
and you can see that how the different
steps can be executed in a different
order so maven is something which is a
phase mechanism there but gradle is
something which is according to the
features or the flexibilities now gradle
works on the tasks whatever the task you
want to perform you uh it works directly
on those tasks there on the other hand
uh maven is something does not have any
kind of inbuilt cache so every time
you're running the build so separate uh
things or the plugins and all these
information gets loaded up which takes
definitely a lot of time on the other
hand gradle is something which is uh
using its own internal cache so that it
can make the
builds a little bit faster because it's
not something which is doing the things
from the scratch whatever the uh
things is already being available in the
cache so it's just pick that part and
from there it will proceed further on
the build automation and that's a reason
why cradle performance is much faster as
compared to maven because it uses some
kind of a cache in there and then helps
to improve the overall performance now
let's talk about the gradle installation
because this is a very important aspect
to be done because when we are doing the
installation
we have to download the cradle
executables right so let's see that what
are the different steps is involved in
the process of the cradle installation
so when we talk about the gradle
installation so there are primary four
steps which is available the very first
one is that you have to check if the
java is installed now if the
java is not installed so you can go to
the open jdk
or you can go for the oracle java so you
can do the installation of the jdk on
your system so jdk8 is something you can
most commonly use nowadays so you can
install that
once the java is downloaded and
installed then you have to do the gradle
uh download cradle there now once the
gradle binaries are executable
or the zip file gets downloaded so you
can add the environment variables and
then you can validate if the gradle
installation is working fine as expected
not so we will be doing the gradle
installation into our local systems and
uh into the windows platform and we'll
see that how exactly we can go for the
installation of cradle and we'll see
that what are the different version we
are going to install here so let's go
back to the system and see that how we
can go for the gradle installation so
this is the website of the jdk of a java
or record java now here you have
different jdk so from there you can do
whatever the
option you want to select you can go
with that so jdk8 is something which is
most commonly used nowadays like its
most comfortable or compatible version
which is available so um in case you
want to see that if the jdk is installed
into your system all you have to do is
that you have to just say like java
hyphen version and that will give you
the uh output that whether the java is
installing to your system or not so in
case my system the java is installed but
if you really want to do the
installation you have to download the
jdk installer from this website from
this article website and then you can
proceed further on that part now once
the jdk is installed so you have to go
for the cradle installation because
cradle is something though which will be
performing the build automations and all
that stuff so you have to download the
binaries like the zip file probably in
which we have the executables and all
and then we have to have have some
particular environment variables
configured so that we will be able to
have the
system modified over there so right now
we have got like the pre requests as in
java version install now the next thing
is that we have to install or download
the executables
so uh in order to download the latest uh
gradle distribution so you have to click
on this one right now over here there
are different options like you want to
go for 6.7 now it's a having like binary
only or complete we'll go for the binary
only because we don't want to have the
source we just want the binaries and the
executables now it's getting downloaded
it's around close to 100 mb of the
installer which is there now we have to
just extract into a directory and then
the same path we need to configure into
the environment variable so that in that
way we will be able to see that how the
uh gradle executables will be running
and it will give the
complete output to us over here in this
case so it may take some time and once
the particular modifications and the
download is done then we have to extract
it and once the extraction is done so we
will be able to go back and
have some particular version or have the
configurations established over there so
that let's just wait for some time and
then we will be continuing with the
environment variables like this one so
once the installation and the extraction
is done now we just have to go to the
downloads here this one is
downloaded we have to extract it now
extraction is required so that we can
have the setup like we can set up this
path into our environment variables and
once the path is configured and
established we will be able to start
further on that part on the execution so
meanwhile these files are getting
started let's see so we already got the
folder structure over here and uh we
will see that we will give this path
here there is two environment variables
we have to configure one is the cradle
and disco home and one is the in the
path variable so we'll copy this path
here
so meanwhile this is getting uh
extracted we can save our time and we
can go to the environment variable so we
can right click on this one properties
in there we have to go for the advanced
systems settings
then environment variables
now here we have to give it like gradle
underscore home now in this one we will
not be going giving it till the bin
directory so that only needs to be there
where the gradle is extracted so we'll
say okay
and
then we have to go for the path variable
where we will be adding up a new entry
in this one we will be putting up till
the pin directory here because the
gradual executables should be there when
i'm running the cradle command so these
two variables i have to configure then
okay okay
and okay
so this one is done so now you have to
just open the command prompt and see
that whether the execution or the
commands which you're running is is
completely successful or not so
meanwhile it's extracting all the
executables and all those things it will
help us to understand that how the whole
build process or how the build tools can
be integrated over there now once the
extraction is done so you have to run
like cmd
you have iphone version to check the
version of the
java and then the gradle
underscore version is what you're going
to see that you see check the version of
the gradle which is installed and now
you can see that it says that 6.7
version is being installed over here in
this case so that's the way that how we
are going to have the cradle
installation performed into our
particular system so let's go back to
the content let's talk about the credit
core concepts here now
in this one we are going to talk about
what are the different core concepts of
cradle are all about the very first one
is the projects here now a project
represents a item to be performed over
here to be done like deploying an
application to a staging environment
performing some build so gradle is
something which is required uh the
projects um the gradle project which you
prepare is not having multiple tasks
which is available there which is
configured and all these tasks all these
different tasks needs to be executed
into a sequence now sequence is again is
a very important part because again if
the sequence is not meant properly then
the execution will not be done in a
proper order so that's the very
important aspect here
tasks is the one in which is a kind of
an identity in which we will be
performing a series of steps these tasks
may be like compilation of a source code
preparing a jar file preparing a web
application archive file or er file also
we can have like
in some tasks we can even publish our
artifacts to the artifactory so that we
can store those artifacts into a shared
location so there are different ways in
which we can have this uh particular
tasks executed
now build scripts is the one in which we
will be storing all this information
what are the dependencies what are the
different tasks we want to refer it's
all going to be present in the
build.gradle file there build.gradle
file will be having the information
related to what are the different
dependencies you want to download and
you want to store this all these things
will be a part of the build scripts
now let's talk about the features of
cradle what are the different features
which we can
use in case of cradle here
there are different type of
features which is available there so
let's talk about them one by one so the
very first one over here is the high
performance then
high performance is something which we
can see that we already discussed that
in case you are using a large project so
gradle is something which is in better
approach as compared to maven because of
the high performance which we are
getting it uses an internal cache which
makes sure that you are using like you
are doing the builds faster and that can
give you a higher performance over there
second one is the support it provides
the support so it yes definitely
provides a lot of support on how you can
perform the builds and it's being the
latest tool which is available there so
the support is also quite good in terms
of how you want to prepare the build how
you want to download the plugins
different plug-in supports and the
dependencies uh information also there
next one is multi-project build software
so using this one you can have multiple
projects in case in your repository you
have multiple projects say so all of
them can be easily built up with the
help of this particular tool so it
supports multiple project to be built up
using the same gradle project and gradle
scripts so that support is also
available with this gradle build tool
uh incremental builds are also something
which you can do with the help of cradle
so if you have uh that only the
incremental changes and you want to
perform only the incremental build so
that can also be possible with the help
of a griddle here the uh build scans so
we can also perform the build scans so
we can use some uh integrations with
sonarcube and all where we can have the
uh scans done to the source code on
understand on how the build happens or
how the source code really happens over
there so that code scan or the build
scans can also be performed with this
one
and then it's a familiarity with java so
for java it's something which is
considered as and by default not even
java in fact android which is also using
the java programming language is using
the uh particular cradle over here so
that the build can be done and it can
gain uh benefits out of that so in in
all the manners in all the different
ways it's basically helping us to see
that how we can make sure that this tool
can help us in providing a lot of
features and that can help us to make a
reliable build tool for our java based
projects or any other programming based
project here right now let's see that
how we can onboard a java project with
the gradle here and uh for that we have
to go back and createdly something which
is already installed we just have to
create a directory where we can have
like how we can perform some executions
we can prepare some build scripts and we
can have a particular execution of a
gradle build happened over there so
let's go back to the machine okay so we
are going to open the terminal here and
we'll see that how we can create it so
first of all i have to create a
directory structure let's say that we'll
say like gradle
hyphen project now once the project is
created so we can go inside this
directory so to
create some cradle related projects and
preparing the files now uh in this one
we'll let's first create a particular
one so we will be saying like vi
build
dot gradle
so in this one we are going to put like
uh
two plugins we are going to use so we
are going to say like apply plugin
java
and then we are going to say like apply
plugin
application
so these two plugins we are going to use
and when we got this file over here in
this one so it shows like build.gradle
which is available there in this case so
two these files are available now if you
want to learn like you know what are the
different tasks so you can run like
gradle tasks command over there so
gradle task will help you know that what
are the different tasks which is
available over here by processing the
build scripts and all so um
this will definitely help you to
understand on giving you the output so
here all the different tasks are being
given and it will help you to understand
that what are the different tasks you
can configure and you can work over here
just like jar files clean and all that
stuff build compile then it is there
then all these different executions
assemble then javadoc then build then
check test all these different tasks are
there and if you really want to run the
gradle build so you can run like cradle
clean to perform the clean activity
because right now you are doing like a
build so before that you can have a
clean and then you can run a
specific command or you can run like
little clean build which will perform
the cleanup also and it will at the same
time will have the build process also
performed over there so build and clean
up both will be executed over here
and what is the status whether it's a
success or a failure that will be given
back to you now in this case in the
previous one if you see that when you
run the clean the cradle clean it was
only running one task but when you go
for the
build uh process when you run the gradle
clean build it's going to give you a
much more information in fact you can
also give me uh further information like
you can have the hyphen iphone info flag
also there so that if you want to get
the details about the uh different uh
tasks which we which is being executed
over here so that also you're going to
get over here in this one so you just
have to put like hyphen iphone info and
then all these steps will be given back
to you that how these tasks will be
executed and the response will be there
so that's a way that how you can create
a pretty much simple straightforward
project in form of gradle which can
definitely help you to run some couple
of cradle commands and then you can
understand that what are the basic
commands you can run and how the
configurations really works on there
right let's go back to the main content
right now let's move on to the next one
so in the next one we are going to see
that how we can prepare a griddle build
project in case of eclipse now we are
not using the a local system we are not
directly creating the folders and the
files here we are actually using the
eclipse for performing the creating a
new cradle project over here so let's
move on that part
okay so now the eclipse is open and i
have opened in this one the very first
thing is that we have to do the gradle
plugin installation so that we can
create new projects on cradle
and uh then we have to uh configure the
path that how the gradle plugin can be
configured on the previous uh
preferences and all that stuff and then
we will be doing the build process so
the very first thing is that we have to
go to the eclipse marketplace
in there we have to search for griddle
so once the search is done
it will show us the plugins related to
gradle so we have to go for
build ship
gradle integration so we'll click on the
install
it will proceed with installation it
will download it in some cases maybe
it's part of the eclipse as an in the id
so you can go to the installed tab and
you can see that also that if this
plug-in is already installed or not but
in this case we are installing it and
once the installation is done we just
have to restart the
specific uh once we have to restart this
eclipse so that the changes can be
reflected
so it's downloading
it's downloading the cradle here and
once that is installed we will be able
to use it over here in this case in this
scenario so we have to just wait for
that part so still downloading the jar
files
so once the jar file is done it's now
over the areas and downloaded so after
that we will be able to proceed further
on that download password so it's going
to take some time to download it and
once it's done we will be able to
proceed further now once the progress is
done so it's asking us for the restart
now
so uh before that uh we just have to
click on restart now and then the
eclipse will be restarted all together
again here so you can do it manually or
you can go for that options it just
require a restart so that the new
changes can be reflected over here so
the plugins can be activated and can be
referenced here now we have to just uh
put up like the
you know the configuration where we can
have the system so we can go for the
gradle configuration so we can go for
windows and then preferences
now in this case we have to go for the
uh for the ones in which the cradle
option is available there so cradle is
what we are going to select now user
home the gradle user home is what we
need to use right so you want to go for
the gradle you want to go for local
installation so so all these options you
can use you can if you go for the gradle
wrapper then it will be downloading the
cradle locally and it is going to use
the cradle w or gradlew.bat file but if
you already have an installation locally
so you can prefer that also right now in
the previous demo we have already got
the griddle uh extracted so we just have
to go for the
downloads and the downloads already
gradle is available so we are going to
select that part here so this is what we
are going to select
right so this represents that this is
the directory structure in which we are
having the mechanism so you can either
go for the pill scan so you can select
the build scan also so once this is
enabled then all the projects will be
scanned and will be you know published
and uh
it's in kind of additional option which
is available if you really want to
disable it you can disable it also and
you can go with this configuration
so uh this is where the particular
gradle folder is being put over here in
this case
and then you have to just click on apply
and
we just have to click on apply and close
so with this one the
particular execution is done now we will
be going for the project creation so you
can right click over here or you can go
to the file also so here we are going to
go for the job project and in this we
are going to have a gradle project so
cradle project is what we are going to
create here
and next
so we are going to say like cradle
project
and then
next
so once that is done so finish
so uh with this one when you create the
project so what will happen that uh
automatically there will be a folder
structure will be available there right
and uh there are some
gradle scripts which will also be
created there so we will be
doing the modifications to there and
we'll see that how the uh particular
gradle build script looks like and how
we can we will be adding some couple of
uh selenium related dependencies and
we'll see that how we can have more and
more dependencies added and what will be
the impact of those dependencies on the
overall project so that also it's very
important aspect to be considered so let
this processing be happen over there
it's just creating and uh some plugins
and binaries are getting installed and
getting downloaded so we'll see that
once the project is uh imported
completely executed over here and got
created we can extract that now if you
see here the particular option is
available about the cradle tasks so you
can extract it also and you will be able
to know that what are the different
tasks which is available there let's see
that in the build they are running like
build these are the different tasks
which is happening inside the build
process so gradle executions will be
also available over here in this case
and gradual tasks will be different it
will be represented over here in this
one so you just have to extract on the
gradle project okay this is the library
which is available now uh what happens
that you will be able to have like
settings.gradle in this one you will be
able to have like okay gradle hyphen
project is something which is available
there in this one so that's what we're
being referring
then we have over here as in these
folder structures which is created like
source main java this is the one source
test java is the one which is available
as in the folder structure
and so test resources are also available
here so the mean source main resources
are also available now in this case what
happens that these are the dependencies
project and external these are the
different dependencies are available
there so let's see let's add another
dependency over here in this one in the
build.gradle script and see that how we
can do that if we open build.gradle file
so you can see that these dependencies
are there like test implementation junit
is available there right and then we
have a implementations of this one which
is available now these jar files which
you put up it will automatically be
added up as in part of this one as in
part of the uh particular uh
dependencies over here and which means
that you don't have to store them as an
within the repository and automatically
they can be happened over there so let's
open a dependency page so we will be
going to mvn repository where we will be
opening a dependency link so this is the
dependency link here so selenium iphone
java is available and it can give you
the uh dependency for all the different
options now we have for maven this is
the one and for gradle this is the one
here so we have to just copy this one
and we have to use it as an dependency
so this is the group and this is the
name and the version which we are using
here now we have copied this one so we
will go back to the
eclipse so here we have to just put that
dependency
and uh we have to just save it so uh
this is something which is providing
like selenium dependencies which is
available so now we have to just refresh
the project
so right click over here then you will
be able to see the options in the gradle
saying that refresh gradle project now
once the moment you do that so you will
be able to do like for the first time
maybe it will take some time to download
all the dependencies which is related to
selenium but after that you will be able
to see like the dependencies will be
simply added up over here in this case
so you can see that all the selenium
related dependencies are added up for
any reason if you comment these ones
and you say like
synchronize again
so you will see that all the
dependencies which you are adding up
from the selenium represent from the
selenium perspective will be gone back
again
so this is the way that how you can keep
on adding the dependencies which is
required for preparing your build for
your source code and from there you will
be able to proceed further on the
execution part so that's the best part
about this cradle here so that's a way
that how we are going to prepare a
graded project within the eclipse and
now you can keep on adding like the
source code in this one and that's the
way that how the code base will be added
up over here right so that's the way
that how the uh particular uh executions
or this gradle project is being prepared
in case of eclipse selenium installation
is a three-step process so it has
certain prereqs the first prerequisite
you need to have java in your system so
we will be installing java first and
then we will be working with eclipse id
so we will be installing eclipse and
then we will install selenium for java
we will install the version java 8 and
for eclipse we have a version 4.10 this
was the last stable version which was
released in december last year so i'll
be using that version and selenium we
will download the latest 3.14 version
okay so let's get started with our first
step which is the java installation so
to install java let's go to the browser
and simply just search for java 8
download
so now you will see that there is an
oracle site which is listed there and
that is where you would be downloading
all your java package so go ahead and
click on that and for you to download
any jdk package from the oracle site you
need to create an account so if you
already have one you just need to login
using that account and then you can
download any of the jdks and if you do
not have one please go ahead create a
new account on the oracle login to that
account and then you can just download
the java it so since i already have an
account and i have already downloaded
the package but i'll show you how and
where to download it from so in this
page if you scroll down so you will see
this java development kit 8211. so this
is the version we'll be downloading it
so click on the accept license agreement
and then since we are working on the
windows system today so we will be
downloading this the windows package so
just click on that and it will get
downloaded in your downloaded folder and
as i said i've already downloaded the
packages so here it is what i've done is
i've just created a directory called
installers and i'm going to be keeping
all my installables here so here i have
a folder called java installer and this
is where my installable is so now that
we have this file so we will just go
ahead double click on it and launch this
installer the installer is launched and
just click on run so this will take a
few minutes to install java the
installer is launched now just click on
the next button here so here for the
installation directory you can change
the directory to the choice of whatever
drive and the folder structure you want
to i would like to leave it as default
here and we just go and click on next
and then the java installation is in
progress so let's wait until this is
completed it really shouldn't take too
much time maybe just a few more minutes
here
okay accept the license term just click
on next we leave the destination folder
as it is
so jdk8 is successfully installed on
your system so close the installer now
and let's go ahead and check whether the
installation is done properly so for
that what i'll do is i'll go to my
command prompt and i'll send just say
java minus version so it says java
version 1.8 and this tells us that the
java is installed successfully now after
this installation there are couple of
configurations which we need to do and
what are those configuration one is you
need to set the path variable and then
you we are also going to set a java home
directory so for that first let's go
ahead and check where is the java
installed actually let's figure out the
directory first so if you remember the
directory structure where the java got
installed was in program files java i
have there are certain previous versions
which had installed and then uninstalled
it so that is why you see some residuals
here sitting here let's not worry too
much about that instead let me go to the
latest one what i have installed which
is this okay and there is a bin folder
here and this is the path which we need
to set in our path variable so what i
will do is i'll just copy this path and
then
go to your control panel here go to your
where is my system yeah so click on the
system go to advanced system setting and
here in the environment variables find
the path variable okay and then say edit
now what are we doing here in the path
variable is we are going to add the java
bin directory to the path be very
careful whenever you are editing your
path variable do not overwrite anything
always go into the edit mode go towards
the end here and then just say control v
paste the path which you have just
copied from the explorer window that's
it now just say okay done so your path
setting is done so what's the next one
we need to do we need to add a new
environment variable called the java now
what i'll do for that is i just say new
i just type java home here
and what is the value of this we need to
set we need to set the same path but
without the pin directory so we just
need to set the path till your java
directory that is this so we'll just
copy the path again and paste it here
that is all just say okay click on ok
click on ok here and we are done so
again let's go to our command prompt and
just say java minus version
so everything seems to be fine so now
successfully we have installed java on
the system so what is our next
installation step what we have now we
need to install the eclipse so let's go
back to the browser again so to download
eclipse we will be downloading the
package from the eclipse.org so when you
go here to eclipse.r you can see the
latest version which is available and
the latest version available when this
video was made was 2090 0 6. so
especially with eclipse since it's an
open source i prefer to work with the
last stable version and so does most of
the developers do and hence that is the
reason why i have picked up the version
which is like last year's version which
is
4.10 which was released in last december
so you can always choose to go with the
latest version but then if there are any
issues and if you're like first time
working with the eclipse you're going to
get confused as where these issues are
coming from right so i would still
recommend that you use the last stable
version which is available with your
eclipse so now to get the last table
version what you need to do is go and
click on this download packages and here
if you scroll down this page you can see
here more downloads so there is a list
of all the previous releases of eclipse
which is available and this is what we
need to download so just click on that
4.10 version and then click on the os on
which you want to install eclipse for us
it is windows so i'll just click here on
the 64-bit windows and then click on the
download and you will be downloading the
complete package so once you download
this is what it will look like so let's
go back to our directory of installers
so this is the installer for the eclipse
which i got now what's the next step i
need to do just launch this installer
and install eclipse so i'll just say
double click on this i'll say run
so here you'll see multiple options here
for eclipse installation so depending on
your requirement you can go ahead and
install any of these packages so for us
we just need an eclipse id for java
developers so i'll select this and i'll
say install so again you'll have a
choice of directory where you want to
install so i have chosen d drive here
this is the default directory name it
takes which is ok we can leave it as it
is and then also you have an option to
create a start menu entry and desktop
shortcut so just leave the default
selection as it is and go ahead and
click on install so this will take a
while to install the eclipse
this is select all you can close this
window this is select all and accept it
okay so the installation has been
completed successfully so let's go and
click on this launch and let's see the
first window what
opens
when you launch the eclipse you need to
specify a workspace directory now what
is this workspace directory so this is a
directory or a folder wherein all the
java files or any programs or any
artifacts which you are going to create
through eclipse will be stored in this
particular folder so this could be any
location on your system so this is you
can go ahead browse the location and
change it so for in our case what we
will do is i'll go to the d drive and
i already have a directory so here i'll
create i'll just clear select this
folder and then create a folder called
workspace i'll say my workspace and then
i'll say launch so every time i open the
eclipse right so this is going to take
as my default workspace and all my
programs all my javascripts or my
automation scripts are getting are going
to be stored in this particular location
so we'll say launch
so this is a welcome window which opens
we can just close this
and there we go the eclipse is open with
a certain perspective so there are
certain windows here which we do not
need let's just close them so now the
first thing what you do after launching
the eclipse is go ahead and create a new
project so i'll say file new and since
i'm going to be using java with selenium
i'll say create java project so give a
project name let's say my first project
now you have an option here to select
the jre which you want to use so we just
installed this jdk 1.8 okay so i'm going
to click on use default gre otherwise
you also have an option to use a project
specific jr for example i could have two
different projects where one project i'm
going to be working with gre 1.8 and
there is another project which i want to
work with the latest java maybe java 12
and i can have more than one java
installed on the machine so this gives
me an option to select whichever java i
want to work with so if you have another
java installed here it will show up in
this list and you can just go ahead and
select that now since we have only one
java installed on our machine which is
java 1.8 i will say use default gre
which is 1.8 and i will click on finish
now if you observe this folder structure
the project which is created see all the
reference libraries to this particular
java have been created here now we are
ready to create any kind of java
programs in this project so now we have
successfully done the second step of our
installation which is the eclipse
installation after this we need to
install the selenium so again let's go
back to the browser and see what files
we need to download to install selenium
so let me go to my browser and here i
will be going to the seleniumhq.org
so if you are working with selenium this
particular website the seleniumhq.org
is going to be a bible everything and
anything related to selenium is
available in this website whether you
want to download the files whether you
want to refer to the documentation
anything regarding to selenium is
available here so what we want now is
the installables for selenium so here go
to the download tab now for you to
install selenium and start working with
selenium there are three things which
are required for you to download one is
a standalone selenium server so this is
not required immediately when you get
started with selenium however when you
start working with remote selenium
webdriver you would be requiring this
when you have a grid setup you will be
requiring the standalone server so for
that what you can do is you can just
download the latest version available
here so when you click on that it will
download the file into your download
folder so this is one particular file
which you need to keep next selenium
client and web driver language bindings
now in today's demo we will be looking
at selenium with java so that means my
client package of java is what i need to
download so whatever programming
language selenium supports we have
respective downloadables available with
that say if you're working with python
then you need to download your client
library for python and since we are
working with java you need to download
this package so simply what you need to
do click on this link and it will
download the java package for you which
are basically the jar files so we have
client libraries now and then there is
another component what we need now with
selenium you are going to be automating
your web browser applications correct
and you also want your applications to
run on multiple browsers so that means
your scripts the automation scripts
which you create should be able to run
on any browser selenium works with
multiple browsers like edge safari
chrome firefox and other browsers even
it has a support for headless browser
now every browser which it supports
comes with its own driver files now say
for example we want to say work with
firefox driver so that means for us to
start working with firefox browser we
need to download something called as a
gecko driver here and if you want to
work with chrome browser you need to
install the chrome driver so depending
on what browsers you will be testing
with go ahead click on each of this link
and download the latest driver files now
since we are going to be working with
firefox in this demo what i need to do
is i just need to click here on the
latest link so when i click on the
latest link it is going to take me to
this driver files so driver files are
specific to each of the operating system
so if you go down here you will see
there is a separate driver file
available for linux for mac and for
windows so depending on which operating
system where you'll be running your test
download that particular driver file and
this is the driver file i need because
we are working on windows machine so
these are the three different packages
which we need to download from the
seleniumhq.org for us to install selling
so let me show you the folder where i
have already downloaded all this so if
you see here selenium java
3.141.59 okay this is nothing but our
client library which we saw here let's
go back to the main page here that is
this so once i download this this is a
zip file after i unzip the file this is
the folder structure i see and let's see
what is there at this folder structure
so there are two jar files here and then
in the lips there are multiple jar files
and we will need all this to work with
selling it and then we also downloaded
the driver files so what i did was after
downloading those driver files for the
browser i created a directory here
called drivers and i've kept all my
browser drivers here so i have a driver
file downloaded for chrome i want to
work with firefox so i have a gecko
driver here and then for internet
explorer that's it so this is all we
need so once we have all this what you
need to do is go to your eclipse in the
eclipse right click on the project which
you have created and then go to the
build path and say configure build path
go to the libraries tab here now do you
see this jre libraries here this is what
got installed first and now similarly we
are going to add the selenium jars to
the slide british and how do we add that
on your right you can see this add
external jars click on add external jars
go to your folder where you have
downloaded your selenium which is this
select all the jar files which is
available so i have two jar files here
i'll just say click open again i will
click on add external jar now from the
libs folder i will select all this file
so select all the five jars and click on
open so you should see all the seven jar
files here so once you have this just
say apply and close now if you look into
your project directory here you will see
some a folder called referenced library
and this is where you will see all the
selenium charts here this is a very
simple installation in eclipse when you
want to install selenium you just need
to export all the jars of the selenium
into eclipse and now your system is
ready to start working with selenium
scripts all right so now let's just test
our installation by writing a small
selenium test script so for that what i
will do is i'll go to the source folder
right click new and i'll say java class
so let's name this as say first selenium
test and i will select this public
static void main and i will click on
finish all right so now let's uh create
a use case say we want to launch a
firefox browser and then we want to
launch the amazon site so these will be
just two simple things which we will be
doing in this test script so for me to
do that what i usually do is i create a
method for any functionality which i
want to create here so now i want to do
a launch browser so i'll create a method
here called launch browser
now whenever you start writing your
selenium scripts the first line what you
need to do is you need to declare an
object of webdriver class so here i'll
say
webdriver driver so now if you hover
over this error what it is showing it
says import webdriver from or dot open
qa dot selling in so if you remember
when we installed the selenium we
imported all these jars right so that
means so what whenever we want to use a
web driver we need to import this class
from these packages so just go ahead and
click on this import state done now next
step now for us to launch a firefox
browser it is a two steps process which
is involved here one is you need to set
the system property and then you need to
launch the driver so let's do that i'll
say system dot set property so use this
method set property so this takes two
arguments the key and the value bill now
what is the key i'm going to mention
here i'm going to be mentioning the
gecko driver and the path for the gecko
driver okay because since i'm working
with the firefox so in double quotes
i'll say
webdriver.geco.driver this is my key and
the value is going to be sorry the fully
qualified path for your driver files and
you know where we have kept our driver
files let's go to that driver files in d
colon i have selenium tutorial in
installers i have driver folder okay so
i'm just going to copy the complete path
from here ctrl c and
i paste it here control v along with
this i need to provide the file name for
the gecko driver which is
geckodriver.exe and let's complete this
step next so once i've set the property
i need to provide a command for
launching my firefox driver and how do i
do that i simply use this driver object
which i have created driver equal to
new firefox driver again similarly the
way we imported packages for web driver
we also need to import the package for
firefox driver so just hover over the
mouse over that and select import
firefox drive with these two statements
we will be able to launch the firefox
browser and as i said in our use case
what is the next thing we want to do we
want to launch say amazon dot in website
for that there is a command in selenium
which says driver.get
and you pass the url here so for me to
write the url what i usually do is i go
to my browser i open the website which i
want to work with in our case it's
amazon dot in and i just simply copy
this fully formed url go to my eclipse
and just paste it here now this ensures
that i don't make any mistakes in typing
out the url let's complete the statement
and we are done and now in the main
function i'll just create an object of
this and we will call this method so
i'll copy this class for selenium test
say obj equal to new for selenium test
and now i'll say obj dot this is a
function launch processor so let's save
this and execute this ctrl c right click
run as
java application okay so the mozilla
firefox has been launched now it should
launch your amazon dot bingo so there
goes our first test script which runs
successfully if getting your learning
started is half the battle what if you
could do that for free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
before you start understanding any
automation tool it's good to look back
into what manual testing is all about
what are its challenges and how
automation tool overcomes these
challenges challenges are always
overcome by inventing something new so
let's see how selenium came into
existence and how did it evolve to
become one of the most popular web
application automation tool selenium
suite of tools selenium is not a single
tool it has multiple components so we
will look into each of them and as you
know every automation tool has its own
advantages and limitations so we will be
looking at what the advantages are and
the limitations of selenium and how do
we work around those limitations all
right so let's get started manual
testing a definition if you can say a
manual testing involves the physical
execution of test cases against various
applications and to do what to detect
bugs and errors in your product it is
one of the primitive methods of testing
a software this was the only method
which we knew of earlier it is execution
of test cases without using any
automation tools it does not require the
knowledge of a testing tool obviously
because everything is done manually also
you can practically test any application
since you are doing a manual testing so
let's take an example so say we have a
use case you are testing say a facebook
application and in facebook application
let's let's open the facebook
application and say create an account
this is your web page which is under
test now now as a tester what would you
do you would write multiple test cases
to test each of the functionalities on
this page you will use multiple data
sets to test each of these fields like
the first name the surname mobile number
or the new password and you will also
test multiple links what are the
different links on this page like say
forgotten account or create a new page
so these are the multiple links
available on the web pages also you look
at each and every element of the web
page like your radio buttons like your
drop down list apart from this you would
do an accessibility testing you would do
a performance testing for this page or
say a response time after you say click
on the login button literally you can do
any type of tests manually once you have
these test cases ready what do you do
you start executing this test cases one
by one you will find bugs your
developers are going to fix them and you
will need to rerun all these test cases
one by one again until all the bugs are
fixed and your application is ready to
ship now if one has to run test cases
with hundreds of transactions or the
data sets and repeat them can you
imagine the amount of effort required in
that now that brings us to the first
demerit of the manual testing manual
testing is a very time consuming process
and it is very boring also it is very
highly error prone why because it is
done manually and human mistakes are
bound to happen since it's a manual
executions tester's presence is required
all the time one is to keep doing manual
steps step by step again all the time he
also has to create manual reports
group them format them so that we get
good looking reports also send this
reports manually to all stakeholders
then collection of logs from various
machines where you have run your tests
consolidating all of them creating
repositories and maintaining them and
again since it's all as a manual process
there is a high chance of creating
manual errors there scope of manual
testing is limited for example let's say
regression testing ideally you would
want to run all the test cases which you
have written but since it's a manual
process you would not have the luxury of
time to execute all of them and hence
you will pick and choose your test cases
to execute that way you are limiting the
scope of testing also working with large
amount of data manually is impractical
which could be the need of your
application what about performance
testing you want to collect metrics on
various performance measures as a part
of your performance testing you want to
simulate multiple loads on application
under test and hence manually performing
these kind of tests is not feasible and
to top it all up say if you are working
in an agile model where code is being
churned out by developers testers are
building their tests and they are
executing them as and when the bills are
available for testing and this happens
iteratively and hence you will need to
run this test multiple times during your
development cycle and doing this
manually definitely becomes very tedious
and boring and is this the effective way
of doing it not at all so what do we do
we automate it so this tells us why we
automate one for faster execution two to
be less error prone and three the main
reason is to help frequent execution of
our test so there are many tools
available in the market today for
automation one such tool is selenium
birth of selenium much before selenium
there were various tools in the market
like say rft and qtp just to name a few
popular ones selenium was introduced by
gentleman called jason huggins way back
in 2004. he was an engineer at
thoughtworks and he was working on a web
application which needed frequent
testing he realized the inefficiency in
manually testing this web application
repeatedly so what he did was he wrote a
javascript program that automatically
controlled the browser actions and he
named it as javascript test runner later
he made this open source and this was
renamed as the selenium core and this is
how selenium came into existence and
since then selenium has become one of
the most powerful tool for testing web
applications so how does selenium help
so we saw all the demerits of manual
testing so we can say by automation of
test cases one selenium helps in speedy
execution of test cases since manual
execution is avoided the results are
more accurate no human errors since your
test cases are automated human resources
required to execute automated test cases
is far less than manual testing because
of that there is a lesser investment in
human resources it saves time and you
know time is money it's cost effective
as selenium is an open source it is
available free of cost early time to
market since you save effort and time on
manual execution your clients will be
merrier as you would be able to ship
your product pretty fast lastly since
your test cases are automated you can
rerun them any point of time and as many
times as required so if this tool offers
so many benefits we definitely want to
know more detail about what selenium is
selenium enables us to test web
applications on all kind of browsers
like internet explorer chrome firefox
safari edge opera and even the headless
browser selenium is an open source and
it is platform independent the biggest
reason why people are preferring this
tool is because it is free of cost and
the qtp and the rft which we talked
about are chargeable selenium is a set
of tools and libraries to facilitate the
automation of web application as i said
it is not a single tool it has multiple
components which we'll be seeing in
detail in some time and all these tools
together help us test the web
application you can run selenium scripts
on any platform it is platform
independent why because it is primarily
developed in javascript it's very common
for manual testers not to have in-depth
programming knowledge so selenium has
this record and replayback tool called
the selenium id which can be used to
create a set of actions as a script and
you can replay the script back however
this is mainly used for demo purposes
only because selenium is such a powerful
tool that you should be able to take
full advantage of all its features
selenium provides support for different
programming languages like java python
c-sharp ruby so you can write your test
scripts in any language you like one
need not know in-depth or advanced
knowledge of these languages
also selenium supports different
operating systems it has supports for
windows macs linux even ubuntu as well
so you can run your selenium test on any
platform of your choice and hence
selenium is the most popular and widely
used automation tools for automating
your web applications selenium set of
tools so let's go a little more deeper
into selenium as i said
selenium is not a single tool it is a
suite of tools so let's look at some of
the major components or the tools in
selenium and what they have to offer so
selenium has four major components one
selenium id it's the most simplest tool
in the suite of selenium it is
integrated development environment
earlier selenium ide was available only
as a firefox plugin and it offered a
simple record and playback functionality
it is a very simple to use tool but it's
mainly used for prototyping and not used
for creating automation in the real time
projects because it has its own
limitations like any other record and
replay tool selenium rc this is nothing
but selenium remote control it is used
to write web application test in
different programming language what it
does it it basically interacts with the
browser with the help of something
called as rc server and how it interacts
is its uses a simple http postgate
request for communication this was also
called as selenium 1.0 version but it
got deprecated in selenium 2.0 version
and was completely removed in 3.0 and it
was replaced by webdriver and we will
see in detail as why this happened
selenium webdriver this is the most
important component in the selenium
suite it is a programming interface to
create and execute text test cases it is
obviously the successor of the selenium
rc which we talked about because of
certain drawbacks which rc had so what
webdriver does is it interacts with the
browsers directly unlike rc where the rc
required a server to interact with the
browser and the last component is the
selenium grid so selenium grid is used
to run multiple test scripts on multiple
machines at the same time so it helps
you in achieving parallel execution
since the selenium web driver with you
can only do sequential execution grid is
what comes into picture where you can do
your parallel execution and why is
parallel execution important because in
real time environment you always have
the need to run test cases in a
distributed environment and that is what
grid helps you to achieve so all this
together helps us to create robust web
application test automation and we will
go in detail about each of these
components so before that let's look at
the history of selenium version so what
did selenium version comprised of it had
an ide rc and grid and as i said earlier
there were some disadvantages of using
rc so rc was on its path of deprecation
and webdriver was taking its path so if
you look at selenium 2 version it had an
earlier version of webdriver and also
the rc so they coexisted from 3. onwards
rc was completely remote and webdriver
took its place there is also a 4 dot
version around the corner and it has
more features and enhancement some some
of the features which are talked about
are w3c webdriver standardization
improved ide and improved grid now let's
look at each of the components in the
selenium suite selenium ide is the most
simplest tool in the suite of selenium
it is nothing but an integrated
development environment for creating
your automation scripts it has a record
and playback functionality and is a very
simple and easy to use too it is
available as a firefox plugin and a
chrome extension so you can use either
of this browser to record your test
scripts it's a very simple user
interface using which you can create
your scripts that interact with your
browser the commands created in the
scripts are called selinese commands and
they can be exported to the supported
programming language and hence this code
can be reused however this is mainly
used for prototyping and not used for
creating automation for your real-time
projects why because of its own
limitation which any other record and
replay tool has so a bit history of
selenium id so earlier selenium id was
only a firefox extension so we saw that
ide was available since the selenium
version one selenium id died with the
firefox version 55 that was id was
stopped supporting from 55 version
onwards and this was around 2017 time
frame however very recently all new
brand selenium id has been launched by
apply tools and also they have made it a
cross browser so you can install the
extension on chrome as well as as an
add-on on firefox browser so they
completely revamped this ide code and
now they have made it available on the
github under the apache 2.0 license and
for the demos today we'll be looking at
the new id now with this new ide also
comes a good amount of features
reusability of test cases better
debugger and most importantly it
supports parallel test case execution so
they have introduced a utility called
selenium side runner that allows you to
run your test cases on any browser so
you can create your automation using
idec on chrome or firefox but through
command prompt using your site runner
you can execute this test cases on any
browser thus by achieving your cross
browser testing control flow statement
so initially in the previous versions of
idea there were control flow statements
available however one had to install a
plugin to use them but now it is made
available out of box and what are these
control flow statements these are
nothing but your if else conditions the
while loops the switch case and so on it
also has an improved locator
functionality that means it provides a
failover mechanism for locating elements
on your web page so let's look at how
this id looks and how do we install it
and start working on that so for that
let me take you to my browser so say
let's go to the firefox browser so on
this browser i already have the id
installed so when you already have an id
installed you will see an icon here that
says selenium id and how do you install
this you simply need to go to your
firefox add-ons here where it says find
more extension so just type in
selenium id and search for this
extension so in the search results you
see the selenium id just click on that
and now since i've already installed
here it says remove otherwise for you it
is going to give you an add button here
just click on the add button it will
install this extension once it is
installed you should be able to see this
selenium id icon here okay so now let's
go ahead and launch this id so when i
click on that it is going to show me a
welcome page where it's going to give me
few options the first option is it says
record a new test case in a new project
so straight away if you choose this
option you can start recording a test
case in which case it's going to just
create a default project for you which
you can save it later then open an
existing project so you can open if you
already
have a saved project create a new
project and close so i already have an
existing project with me for the demo
purpose so i'll go ahead and open that
so i'll say open existing project and i
have created a simple script what the
script does is it logs me into the
facebook using a dummy user mail your
sorry username and password that's all
it's very simple script with few lines
and this is what it's going to do so
what we will simply do is we'll just run
the script and see how it works for that
i'm just going to reduce the test
execution speed so that you should be
able to see every step of execution here
all right so what i'll do now here is
i'll just adjust this window and i'll
just simply say run current test all
right so i'll just get this side by side
so that you should be able to see what
exactly the script is doing okay so now
you are able to see both the windows
okay so now it's going to type in your
user email here there you go and now
it'll enter the password and it has
clicked on the login button so it's
going to take a while to say login and
since these are the dummy ids it is you
are not able to log in here and you are
going to see this error window fine that
is what is the expected output here now
on the id if you look here after i
execute the test case every statement or
every command which i have used here is
colored coded in green so that means
this particular step was executed
successfully and then here in the log
window it will give you a complete log
of this test case right from the first
step till the end and your end result is
it says fb login which is my test case
name completed successful let's look at
few components of this id the first one
is the menu bar so let's go to our id
all right so the menu bar is right here
on the top so here is your project name
so either you can add a new project here
or rename your project so since we
already have this project which is named
as facebook and then on the right you
have options to create a new project
open an existing project or save the
current project and then comes on
toolbar so using the options in this
toolbar you can control the execution of
your test cases so first one here is the
recording button so this is what you use
when you start recording your script and
then on the left you have two options
here to run your test cases the first
one is run all tests so in case you have
multiple test cases written here you can
execute them one by one sequentially by
using this run all test else what you
can do is if you just want to run your
current test this is what you would use
then id has this debugger option which
you can use to do a step execution so
say for example now whenever i run the
script it's going to execute each and
every command here sequentially so
instead if i just select the first
command and say do step execution all
right so what it does is the moment it
finishes the first command which is
opening of facebook right i think which
is already done here yeah all right so
once this is done it is going to wait
immediately on the second command and it
says pause debugger so from here you can
do whatever you would like to do in case
you want to change the command here you
can do that you can pause your execution
you can resume your execution here right
you can even completely stop your test
execution or you can just select this to
run the rest of the test case so if we
say run the test case what it is going
to do is it's just going to simply go
ahead and complete the com complete the
test case now there is another option
here which is you see the timer there it
says test execution speed so to execute
your test cases in the speed you want
say whenever you are developing an
automation script right and say you want
to give a demo so you need to control
the speed sometimes so that the viewer
is able to exactly see all the steps
which is being performed and this gives
you an option to control that complete
execution right so do you see the
grading here so we have somewhere from
fast to completely slow execution so the
previous demo which i showed was i
control the speed and then i executed it
so that we could see every command how
it is being executed
all right so what's the next this is
called as an address bar so whichever
whenever whenever you enter an url here
that is where you want to conduct your
test and another thing what it does is
it keeps a history of all the urls which
have used for running your test then
here is where your script is recorded so
each and every instruction is displayed
here in the order in which you have
recorded the script and then if you look
here you have something called as log
and reference
so now log is an area where it records
each and every step of your command as
in when they get executed right so if
you see here it says open https
facebook.com and ok so that means this
command was executed successfully and
after the complete test case is done it
gives you whether the test case passed
or failed so in case there is a failure
you will immediately see this test case
is filled in red color also there is
something called as reference here for
example say if i click on any of this
command the reference tab what it is
going to show me is the details of this
command which i have used in the script
it gives you the details of the command
as well as what the arguments have been
used or how how is that you need to be
using this particular command okay so
now what we'll do is let's go ahead and
write a simple script using this id so
with this you'll get an idea how do we
actually record scripts in id so for
that i have a use case here a very very
simple use case so what we will do is we
will open amazon dot in then we will
search simply search for say product
iphone and once we get that search page
where all your iphones are displayed we
will just do an asset on the title of
the page simple all right so let's do
that so first thing what i need is an
url okay so first let me go to my
firefox browser here and say amazon.com
so why i'm doing this just to simply get
the right url absolute url path here and
so that i don't make any mistakes while
typing in the url okay so i got this so
let me close all this windows i don't
need any of this let's minimize this
all right so here what i'll do in the
tests tab i'll say add a new test and
name this test as uh amazon search
done i'll say add now i'll enter this
url which i just copied it from my
browser okay and then i'll just say
start recording so what it
did was since i've entered the url in
this address box it just opened the
amazon dot in url now let's do our test
case so in my test case what i said was
i want to search for iphone once i have
this i'm just going to click on my
search button so now this gives me a
list of all iphones and then i said i
want to add an assertion on the title of
this page so for me to do that what id
gives me an option is i have to just
right click anywhere on this page and
you see the selenium id options here so
in this i will select assert title and
then i will close this browser so that
kind of completes my test case so now
take a look at all the steps which is
created for me so it says open slash
because i have already provided the url
here so either you can replace it with
your regular url or you can just leave
it as it is so what i will do since this
is going to be a proper script and i
might be using this to run it from my
command prompt also so i'll just replace
this target with the actual url and then
what it is doing it is setting a window
size then there are whatever i did on
that particular url on that website it
has recorded all the steps for me so
this is where it says type into this
particular text box which is my search
box and what did it type iphone this was
the value which i entered now there was
one more feature which i told you in
this new id which had which i said it
has a failover mechanism for your
locating techniques now that is what
this is now if you look here this id is
equal to tab search textbook this is
nothing but that search box where we
entered the text iphone and it has
certain identification through which
this ide identifies that web element and
that has multiple options to select that
particular search box so right now what
it has used is id is equal to two tab
search box however if you know the
different locating techniques you will
be able to see here that it has other
techniques also which it has identified
like the name and the css and the xpath
so how does this help in failovers say
tomorrow if amazon dot in website
changes the id of this element right you
are not going to come and rewrite the
scripts again instead by using the same
script what it will do is if this
particular id fails if it is unable to
find the element using the first locator
which is the id it simply moves to the
next available ones and it tries to
search for that element until one of
this becomes true that is what was the
failure mechanism which has got added
it's a very brilliant feature because
most of our test cases break because of
element location techniques well let's
come back to this so then we added an
assert title right so what is assert
title here it simply captures the title
of that particular page and it checks
this is all very simple test case so
what we will do now is we will stop the
recording and then i've also given a
close browser so right now what i'll do
is i'll just comment this out why
because if i just run this test case
it's going to be very fast and you might
not be able to catch the exact command
execution what has happened all right so
right now i'll just disable it so that
it will just do all these test cases and
it just stays there without closing the
browser so now i'll just say run the
current test date so your amazon in is
launched okay it is typed in the iphone
it's also clicked on the search so it is
done so now if you look here since we
are in the reference tab it is not able
to show so let's go to the log and now
let's see the log so it's going to be a
running log so if you notice here the
previous examples which we have run for
facebook is also in the same lock so we
will have to see the log from running
amazon search because that's our test
case so if you see here every command
line right was executed successfully
assert title was also done at your test
case was executed successfully so it
passed now what we will do is on this
assert title i'll just modify this
and let's say just add some text i just
add double s here now this by
intentionally i am going to fail this
test case just to show you that whenever
there is a test case failure how does
the id behaves and how do you get to
know the failures all right so i'll just
run the disk test case again so before
that let's close the previous
window all right done and now
here i'll also uncomment the close
because anyway it's a failure which i am
going to see which i should be able to
see it in the logs so i will close the
browser after the execution of test case
okay so let's simply go and run the test
case okay amazon.com is launched it
should search for iphone now yeah there
you go all right
now it should also close the browser yes
it has closed the browser and it has
failed now see here now this is the line
where our command filled why because the
expected title was not there and if you
look in the logs it says your assert
title on amazon dot in failed actual
result was something different and it
did not match with what we had asked it
for so this is how simple it is to use
your id to create your automation
scripts
so we saw all the components of id we
saw the record button then i showed you
the toolbar i showed you the editor box
and also the test execution lock so now
let's come to what are the limitations
of this id with ide you cannot export
your scripts your test scripts to web
driver scripts this support is not yet
added but it is in the works data driven
testing like using your excel files or
reading data from the csv files and
passing it to the script this capability
is still not available also you cannot
connect to database for reading your
test data or perform any kind of
database testing with selenium webdriver
yes you can also unlike selenium
webdriver you do not have a good
reporting mechanism with the ide like
say for example test ng or repotential
so that brings us to the next component
of the suite which is selenium rc
selenium remote control so selenium rc
was developed by paul hammond he
refactored the code which was developed
by jason and was credited with json as a
co-creator of selenium selenium server
is written in java it is used to write
web application test in different
programming languages as it supports
multiple programming languages like your
java c perl python and ruby it interacts
with a browser with the help of an rc
server so this rfsave server uses a
simple http get and post request for
communication and as i said earlier also
selenium rc was called as selenium 1.0
overshot but it got deplicated in
selenium 2.0 and was completely removed
in 3.0 and it got replaced by what
webdriver and we'll see why this
happened and what was that issue which
we had with the rc server so this is the
architecture of selenium remote control
at a very high level so when jason
huggins introduced selenium you know the
tool was called as javascript program
and then that was also called as a
selenium core so every html has a
javascript statements which are executed
by web browser and there is a javascript
engine which helps in executing this
command now this rca had one major issue
now what was that issue say for example
you have a test script say
test.javascript here which you are
trying to access elements from anywhere
from the google.com domain so what used
to happen is every element which is
accessible e are the elements which can
belong only to google.com domain like
say for example mail the search or the
drive so any elements from this can be
accessible through your test scripts
however nothing outside the domain of
say google.com in this case was
accessible say for example if your test
scripts wanted to access something from
yahoo.com this was not possible and this
is due to the security reasons obviously
now to overcome that the testers what
they had to do was they had to install
the selenium core and the web server
which contained your web application
which is under test on the same machine
and imagine if you have to do this for
every machine which is under test this
is not going to be feasible or even
effective all the time and this issue is
called as a same origin policy now what
the same origin policy issue says is it
prohibits a javascript from accessing
elements or interacting with scripts
from a domain different from where it is
launched and this is purely for the
security measure so if you have written
scripts which can access your google.com
or anything related to google.com these
scripts cannot access any elements
outside the domain like as we said in
the example yahoo.com this was the same
origin policy now to overcome this what
this gentleman did was he created
something called as selenium remote
control server to trick the browser in
believing that your core your selenium
core and your web application under test
are from the same domain and this is
what was the selenium remote control so
if you look at again a high level
architecture or how did this actually
work first you write your test scripts
which is here right in any of the
supported language like your php or your
java or python and before we start
testing we need to launch this rc server
which is a separate application so this
selenium server is responsible for
receiving the cellini's commands and
these selenius commands are the ones
which you have written in your script it
interprets them and reports the result
back to your test so all that is done to
your rc server the browser interaction
which happens through rc server right
from here to your browser so this
happens through a simple http
post and get request and that is how
your rc server and your browser
communicate and how exactly this
communication happens this rc server it
acts like a proxy so say your test
script asks to launch a browser so what
happens is this commands goes to your
server and then your rc server launches
the browser it injects the javascript
into the browser once this is done all
the subsequent calls from your test
script right from your test scripts to
your browser goes through your rc and
now upon upon receiving these
instruction your selenium core executes
this actual commands as javascript
commands on the browser and then the
test results are displayed back from
your browser to your rc to your test
scripts so the same cycle gets repeated
right until the complete test case
execution is over so for every command
what you write in your javascript here
or your test script here goes through a
complete cycle of going through the rc
server to the browser collecting the
results again from the rc server back to
your test scripts so this cycle gets
repeated for every command until your
complete test execution is done so rc
had definitely lot of shortcomings and
what are those so rc server needs to be
installed before running any test
scripts which we just saw so that was an
additional setup since it acts as a
mediator between your commands which is
your salinist commands and your browser
the architecture of rc is complicated
why because of its intermediate rc
server which is required to communicate
with the browser the execution of
commands takes very long it is slower we
know why because every command in this
takes a full trip from the test script
to your rc server to the core engine to
the browser and then back to the same
route which makes your overall test
execution very slow lastly the apis
supported by rc are very redundant and
confusing so rc does have a good number
of aps however it is less object
oriented so they are redundant and
confusing say for example say if you
want to write into a text box how and
when to use a type key command or just a
type command is always confusing another
example is some of the mouse commands
using a click or a mouse dot both kind
of you know almost providing a similar
functionality so that is the kind of
confusion which developers used to
create
hence
selenium rc got deprecated and is no
more available in latest selenium
versions it is obsolete now now to
overcome this shortfalls webdriver was
introduced so while rc was introduced in
2004 webdriver was introduced by simon
stevert in 2006. it's a cross-platform
testing platform so webdriver can run on
any platform like say linux windows mac
or even if you have a ubuntu machine you
can run your selenium scripts on this
machine it is a programming interface to
run test cases it is not an ide and how
does this work actually so test cases
are created and executed using web
elements or objects using the object
locator and the web driver method so
when i do a demo you will understand
what this web driver methods are and how
do we locate the web elements on the web
page it does not require a core engine
like rc so it is pretty fast why because
web driver interacts directly with the
browser and it does not have that
intermediate server like the rc hat so
each browser in this case what happens
is each browser has its own driver on
which the application runs
and this driver is responsible to make
the browser understand the commands
which you will be passing from the
script like say for example click of a
button or you want to enter some text so
through your script you tell which
browser you want to work with say chrome
and then the chrome driver is
responsible for interpreting your
instructions and to execute it on the
web application launched on the chrome
browser so like rc webdriver also
supports multiple programming languages
in which you can write your test scripts
so another advantage of webdriver is it
supports various frameworks like test ng
junit n unit and report engine so when
we talk about the limitations of
webdriver you will appreciate how this
support for various frameworks and tool
help in making the selenium a complete
automation solution for web application
so let's look at the architecture of
webdriver at a high level what is in web
drivers a web driver consists of four
major components
the first one is we have got client
libraries right or what we also call it
as language bindings
so since selenium supports multiple
language and you are free to use any of
the supported languages to create your
automation script these libraries are
made available on your selenium website
which you need to download and then
write your scripts accordingly so let's
go and see from where do we download
this so if i go to my browser
so
seleniumhq.org right so if you're
working with selenium this website is
your bible so anything and everything
you need to know about selenium right
you need to come here and use all these
tabs here in this website so right now
what we are going to look at is what are
those language binding so for that i'll
have to go to this download tab here
okay and if you scroll down here you
will see something like selenium client
and web driver language bindings and for
each of the supported language of
selenium you have a download link
right so say for example if you are
working with java here what you need to
do is you need to download your java
language binding so let us go back to
the presentation so this is where your
language bindings are available next so
selenium provides lots of apis for us to
interact with the browser
and when we do the demo i'll be showing
you some of this aps right and these are
nothing but the rest apis
and everything whatever we do through
the script happens through the rest
calls then we have a json wire protocol
what is json javascript object notation
it is nothing but a standard for
exchanging data over the web so for
example you want to say launch a web
application through your script
so what selenium does it it creates a
json payload and posts the request to
the browser driver
that is here and then we have this
browser drivers themselves and as i said
there is a specific driver for each
browser
as you know every tool has its own
limitation
so does selenium
so let's look at what these limitations
are and if there are any workarounds for
them
cannot test mobile applications requires
framework like apm
selenium is for automating web
application it cannot handle mobile
applications mobile applications are
little different and they need its own
set of automation tool
however what selenium provides is a
support for integrating this apm tool
which is nothing but a mobile
application automation tool
and using apm and selenium you can still
achieve mobile application automation
and when do you usually need this when
your application under test is also
supported on mobile devices you would
want a mechanism to run the same test
cases on web browser as well as your
mobile process right so this is how you
achieve it the next limitation so when
we talked about the components of
selenium i said that with webdriver we
can achieve only sequential execution
however in real time scenario we cannot
just live with this we need to have a
mechanism to run our test cases
parallelly on multiple machines as well
as on multiple browsers so though this
is a limitation of webdriver but what
selenium offers is something called as
grid which helps us achieve this and we
will see in shortly what the selenium
grid is all about also if you want to
know more details as how do we work with
the grid how do you want to install that
grid so do check out our video
on simply learn website on selenium grid
third limitations so limited reporting
capability so selenium web driver has a
limited reporting capability it can
create basic reports but what we
definitely need is a more
so it does support some tools like say
test ng report ng and even extent
reports which you can integrate with
selenium and generate beautiful reports
powerful isn't it
also there are other challenges
with selenium like selenium is not very
good with image testing
especially for the ones which are
designed for web application automation
but then we have other tools which can
be used along with selenium like auto it
and seculi so if you look at all this
selenium still provides a complete
solution for your automation needs and
that's the beauty of selenium and that
is why it makes the most popular tool of
today for automation
okay let's do a quick comparison between
the selenium rc and the webdriver
so rc has a very complex architecture
you know why because of the additional
rc server whereas due to direct
interaction with the browser webdriver
architecture is pretty simple
execution speed
it is slower in rc and much faster than
web driver why because in web driver we
have eliminated the complete layer of
selenium server
right that the rc server and we
established a direct communication with
the browser through browser drivers it
requires an rc server to interact with
the browsers we just talked about it and
whereas webdriver can directly interact
with the browser
so rc again we talked about this as one
of the limitations that we have lot of
redundant abs which kept developers
guessing as which api to use for what
functionality
however webdriver offers pretty clean
apis to work with
rc did not offer any support for
headless browser whereas in web driver
you do have a support for using headless
browsers
let's see the web driver in action now
now for the demo we will use this
particular use case and what this use
case says is navigate to the official
simply learn website
then type the selenium in search bar and
click on it and click on the selenium
3.0 training so we are basically
searching for selenium 3.0 training on
the simply learn website first let's do
the steps manually and then we will go
ahead and write the automation script so
let's go to my browser on my browser
what i'll do is i'll let me first launch
the simply learn website
okay and here what my use case step says
is i need to search for
selenium and click on the search button
so once i do that it is going to give me
a complete list of all kind of selenium
trainings which is available with simple
learn and what i am interested in is the
selenium 3.0 training here once i find
this on the web page i need to go and
click on that all right so this is all
the steps which we are going to perform
in this use case okay now so for writing
the test cases i'll be using an id which
is eclipse i've already installed my
eclipse and also i have installed
selenium in this instance of my eclipse
all right so if you can see the
reference library folder here you will
see all the jars which are required for
the selenium to work next another prereq
which is required for selenium and that
is your driver files now every browser
which you want to work with has its own
driver file to execute your selenium
scripts and since for this demo i'll be
working with the firefox browser i will
need a driver file for firefox now
driver file for firefox is the gecko
driver which i have already downloaded
and placed in my folder called drivers
now where did i download this from let's
go ahead and see that so if i go back to
my browser and if you go to your
selenium hq dot website you have to go
to this download tab here in the
download tab when you scroll down you
will see something like third-party
drivers bindings and plugins in this
you'll see the list of all the browsers
which is supported by selenium and
against each of this browser you will
find a link which has the driver files
now since we'll be using the gecko
driver
this is the link where you need to go to
and depending on which operating system
which you're working on you need to
download that particular file now since
i am working on mac this is the file
which i am using if you are a windows
user you need to download this zip file
and unzip it so once you unzip that you
would
get a file called gecko driver for your
firefox or a chrome driver for your
chrome browser and then what you do is
you just create a directory called
drivers under your project
and just place the driver files here so
these are the two prereqs for your
selenium one is importing your jar files
like this and then having your drivers
downloaded and keep them under a folder
where you can reference to okay so now
we'll go ahead and create a class
i already have a package created in this
project so i'll use this project and
create a new class
so i'll say create new java class and
let's call this as
search training i will be using a public
static void main and i'll click on
finish
so let's remove this auto generated
lines as we do not need them all right
now the first statement which you need
to write before even you start writing
the rest of your quotas what you need to
do is you need to define or declare your
driver variable using your class web
driver so what i would do is i'll say
web driver
driver
done all right now you will see that
this id is going to flash some errors
for you that means it is going to ask
you to import certain libraries which is
required by the web driver so simply
just go ahead and say import web driver
from
org.opensq dot selenium this is the
package which we will need all right so
you have a driver created which is of
the class webdriver and now after this
i'm going to create three methods all
right so first method i will have for
launching the firefox browser okay and
then i will write a simple method for
searching selenium training
and clicking on it
this is the actual use case what we'll
be doing and then third method i'm going
to write is just to close the browser
which i'm going to be opening right so
these are the different methods which
i'll be creating and from the public
static void main i will just call these
methods one after the other okay so
let's go ahead and write the first
method now my first method is launching
the firefox browser so i'll say public
void since my return type is null or
there is no return type for this let's
call it as launch browser
okay all right now in this for launching
any browser i need to mention two steps
now the first step is where i need to do
a system.set property okay let's do that
first and then i'll explain what this
does i'll just say system dot set
property so this accepts a key and a
value pair so what is my key here my key
here is web webdriver dot
gecko dot driver and i need to provide a
value so value is nothing but the path
to the gecko driver and we know that
this gecko driver which i am going to
use here is right here in the same
project path under the drivers folder
correct and that is what the path which
i'm going to provide here so here simply
i need to say
drivers slash
gecko driver it is g e c k o all right
done and let me close this sentence all
right now since i'm a mac user my gecko
driver installable is just the name
gecko driver if you're a windows user
and if you are running your selenium
scripts on the windows machine you need
to provide a complete path to this
including dot exe because driver
executable on your machines is going to
be geckodriver.exe all right so just
make sure that your path which you
mentioned here in the system.set
property is the correct path okay then
the next thing what we need to do is i
need to just say driver is equal to new
firefox driver okay so this command new
firefox driver creates an instance of
the firefox browser now this is also
flagging me error why because again it's
going to ask me to import the packages
where the firefox driver classes present
okay we did that now these two lines are
responsible for launching the firefox
browser form so this is done so what's
my next step in the use case now i need
to launch the website simply learn so
for that we have a command called
driver.get
driver.get what it does is whatever url
you're going to give it here in this
double quotes as an argument it is going
to launch that particular website and
for us it's a simply learn website so
what i do as a best practices instead of
typing out the url i go to my browser
launch that url which i want to test and
i simply copy it come back to your
eclipse and just simply paste it so this
ensures that i do not make any mistakes
in the url okay so done so our first
method is ready where we are launching
the browser which is our firefox browser
and then launching the simply learn
website now the next method what is my
next method in my next method i need to
give the search string to search
selenium training on this particular
website now for that we need to do few
things what are those few things let's
go to the website again all right so let
me relaunch this let's close this okay
let me remove all this and let's go to
the home page first okay this is my home
page so as you saw when i did a manual
testing of this i entered the text here
so now since i have to write a script
for this first i need to identify what
this element is for that what i'm going
to do is i'm just going to say right
click here and i'll say inspect element
all right now this element let's see
what attribute it has which i can use
for finding this element so i i see that
there is an id present so what i'm going
to do is i'm just going to simply use
this id
and then i'll just copy this id from
here go back to eclipse let's write a
method first so i'll say public void
and what do we give the method name say
search training
or just search all right now in this i
need to use a command called driver dot
find element
by id is what i'm going to use as a
locating technique and in double quotes
the id which i copied from the website
is what i'm going to paste here okay and
then what am i going to do on this
element is i need to send that text the
text which i'm going to search for which
is selenium so i'll just say send keys
and whatever text i want to send i need
to give it in double quotes so for that
selenium so this is done so now i've
entered the text here and after entering
the text i need to click on this button
so for that i need to first know what
that button is so let's inspect that
search button okay now if you look at
the search button other than the tag
which is span and the class name i do
not have anything here all right so what
i can do is i can either use the class
name or i can write an x path since this
is a demo which we have already used id
locating technique i would go ahead and
use the x path here so for me to
construct an x path uh i will copy this
class first okay
and then i already have a crow path
installed on my firefox so i'll use the
crow path and first test my x-bar so
i'll just say double slash let's see
what was that element it has a span tag
okay so i'll have to use span and at
class equal to and i'll just copy the
class name here and let's see if it can
identify that element yeah so it is able
to identify so i'll just use this x path
in my code so i'll go back to eclipse
and i'll say driver dot find element by
dot x path and the x path which i just
copied from crow path is what i'm going
to paste here and what is the action i
need to do here i need to say click
done so i have reached a stage where i
have entered this selenium okay and then
i have clicked on the search button once
i do this i know that expected result is
i should be able to find this particular
link here selenium 3.0 training okay and
i should be able to click on that so for
that again i need to inspect this so
let's inspect this selenium 3.2 all
right so now what are the elements this
has now this particular element has
attributes like it has a tag h2 then it
has got some class name and some other
attributes so i would again would like
to use a xpath here now this time while
using the x path i'm going to make use
of a text functionality so that i can
search for this particular text so i'll
simply copy this i'll go to my crow path
the tag is h2 so i'll say simply h2 okay
and here i'll say text equal to and this
is the text which i copied i missed out
that yes there so i'm just going to add
an s okay so let's first test here
whether it is able to identify that
element yeah so it is able to identify
so can you see a blue dotted line it is
able to show us which element it is
identified so i'll copy this x path now
and let's go to my ide eclipse so now
here what i need to do is i'll have to
again simply say driver dot find element
by dot x path
and paste the x path which we just did
and then again i have to do a click
operation done all right so technically
we have taken all the steps of the use
case and we have written the commands
for that
now let's add an additional thing here
say after coming to this page after
finding this we want to
say print the title of this page now
what is the title of this page if you
just hover your mouse on this it says
online and classroom training for
professional certification courses
simply now so what i will do is after
doing all these operations i will just
print out this page title on our console
so for that i have to just do this
driver dot ah so let's do a sysop so
i'll say sis out
system.out.println okay and here i would
say
let's add a text here the page title is
and then let's append it with driver dot
get title so this is the command which
we'll be using to fetch the page title
done now what is the last method i need
to add just to close the browser all
right so let me add a method here i'll
say public void close browser
and this is one single command which i
need to call i'll say driver dot quit
okay and then i need to call all these
methods from my public static void main
so i let me use my class name which is
this well i'm going to create an object
obj is equal to
new class name and then using this
object first is i need to call the
method launch browser and then i'll call
the method search
right and then i'll call the method
close process done so technically our
script is ready with all the
functionality which we wanted to cover
from our use case now there are few
other tweaks which i need to do this and
i'll tell you why i need to do this now
for example after we click here right
after we click on the search if you
observed on your website it took a
little while before it listed out all
the selenium trainings for us and
visually when you are actually doing it
you wait for the selenium 3.0 training
to be available and then you click on
that now same thing you also need to
tell your scripts to do that you need to
tell your scripts to wait for a while
until you start seeing the selenium 3.0
training or it appears on your web page
there are multiple ways to do that in
your script and it is a part of overall
synchronization what we call where we
use kind of implicit and explicit kind
of favorites now since this is a demo
for demo purpose what i am going to do
is i am going to use a command called
thread.sleep and i am just going to give
an explicit weight of say three seconds
so you can use this mainly for the demo
purposes you can use a thread dot sleep
command now this thread dot sleep comma
needs us to handle some exceptions so
i'm just going to click on add throws
declaration and say interrupted
exception now same thing i'll have to do
it in my main function also okay so
let's do that and complete it
all right so this is done so by doing
this what am i doing i'm ensuring that
before i click on the selenium three dot
training we are giving enough time for
the script to wait until the webpage
shows this link to the selenium 3.0
training that's one thing i'm doing all
right and also now since you're going to
be seeing this demo through the video
recording the script when it starts
running it is going to be very fast so
you might just miss out saying how it
does the send keys and how did it click
on the search button for us to enable us
to see it properly i'll just add some
explicit weights here just for a demo
purpose so after entering the keys right
so what i'll do is i'll just give a
simple thread dot sleep here
okay so probably a three seconds or two
seconds wait should be good enough okay
three seconds wait should be good enough
here so that we should be able to see
how exactly this works on your browser
when we execute this
okay now our complete script is ready so
what i'll do is i'll just save the
script and then we will simply run the
script so to run the script i just say
right click run as java application okay
it says ask me to select and save i have
saved the script now so let's observe
how it runs okay the
simplylearn.com the website is launched
so the selenium text has been entered in
the search box it has clicked on the
search okay all right so now it did
everything whatever we wanted it to do
all right so since we are closing the
browser you are unable to see whether
the selenium three dot training was
selected or not however what i have
given here is to fetch the title after
all these operations were complete and
if you see here the complete operations
was done and we were able to see the
page title here okay so now what i'll do
since we are unable to see whether it
clicked on the selenium 3.0 training or
not i'll just comment our the close
browser the command okay so we will not
call the close browser so that the
browser remains open and we get to see
whether did it really find the training
link or not okay so let me close this
window we don't need this firefox window
close all tabs and then i'll just
exactly execute the script so i'll say
run as java application so save the file
okay simplylearn.com is launched so
search text is entered now it's going to
click on the search button yes all right
so we've got the search results it
should click on selenium theodore
training and yes it is successfully able
to click on that all right so now it's
not going to close the browser because
we have commented on that line however
it did print us the title
here all right so this is a simple way
of using the selenium scripts
selenium grid so grid is used to run
multiple test scripts on multiple
machines at the same time with webdriver
you can only do sequential execution but
in real time environment you always have
the need to run test cases in
distributed environment and that is
where selenium grid comes into picture
so grid was conceptualized and developed
by patrick the main objective is to
minimize test execution type and how by
running your test parallelly so design
is in such a way that commands are
distributed on multiple machines where
you want to run test and all these are
executed simultaneously what do you
achieve by this methodology of course
the parallel execution on different
browsers and operating system grid is
pretty flexible and can integrate with
many tools like say you want a reporting
tool integrated to pull all the reports
from the multiple machines where you're
running your test cases and you want to
present that report in a good looking
format so you have an option to
integrate such report okay so how does
this grid work so grid has a hub and
node concept which helps in achieving
the parallel execution let's take an
example say your application supports
all browsers and most of the operating
systems like as in this picture you
could say one of them is a windows
machine one of them is a mac machine and
another one is say a linux machine so
your requirement is to run the test on
all supported browsers and operating
system like the one which is depicted in
this picture so what you have to do is
first thing is you configure a master
machine or what you also call it as a
hub by running something called a
selenium standalone server and this
talent standalone server can be
downloaded from the selenium hq website
using the server you create a hub
configuration that is this node and then
you create nodes specific to your
machine requirement and how are these
nodes created you again use the same
server which is your standalone selenium
server to create the node configuration
so i'll show you where the selenium
server can be downloaded so if we go
back to our
selenium hq website so you can see here
right on the top it says selenium
standalone server welcome everyone to
our one another demo on which we are
going to see that how exactly we can do
the installation of docker on the
windows platform specifically on windows
10. now docker is something which is
available for most of the operating
systems different different platforms so
it supports both the unix and the
windows platform as such so um linux
through various commands we can do the
installation but in the case of windows
you have to download the exe file and a
particular installer from the docker hub
websites you can simply google it and
you will get a kind of a link from where
you will be able to download the package
so let's go to the chrome and try to
search on for the windows stream uh
particular installer you will get a link
from docker hub you download it you get
the stable version you get the edge
version whichever version you want you
wish to download you can download it so
let's go back to the chrome so here you
have the docker desktop for windows so
you can go for this table or you can go
for the edge right so you also have the
comparison that what is the difference
between these two versions right
so um the particular edge version is
something which is getting releases
every month and uh the
stable version is getting the releases
every quarter so they are not doing much
of the changes to the stable version as
compared to the edge there so you just
have to double click on the installer
and that will help you to do the
installation of the process so let's get
started so you just click on the get
instable version so when you do that the
particular installer is going to install
now it's going to take like around 300
mb there so that's the kind of install
which is available so once the installer
is downloaded so what you can do is that
you can actually go ahead and you can uh
proceed with the doing the double click
on this installer when you double click
on that you have to proceed with some of
the steps like you know from the gui
itself you are going to proceed with
these steps so we'll wait for 10 to 20
seconds more and then the installer will
be done and then we can do the double
click and the installation will proceed
so another thing is that uh there is a
huge difference between the installer
like for example in case of unix the
installer is a little bit less but in
case of windows it's a gui is also
involved and there are a lot of binaries
which is available there so that's the
reason why you know the huge size is
there now it's available for free that's
for sure and it also requires the
windows 10 professional or enterprise
64-bit there so um if you are working on
some previous version of operating
systems like windows 7 and all you have
the older version called docker toolbox
so they used to call it as like docker
toolbox earlier but now they are calling
it as a docker desktop with the new
docker windows 10 support as such here
so another couple of seconds and then
the installer will be done and then we
will be able to proceed with the
installation
so let's see that how much progress is
there to the download so we'll click on
the downloads and here still we have
some particular installations or some
download going on so we'll wait for some
time and once the installation is done
then we'll go back and we'll proceed
with installation
so couple of seconds
so it's almost done so i'll just click
on this one you can go to the directory
to the downloads and you can double
click on that also but if you want to do
the installation you can click on this
one also and it will ask for the
approval yes or no you have to provide
now once that is done so um a desktop a
kind of a gui component will open there
so it will start proceeding with
installation so it's asking whether you
want to add the desktop the shortcut to
desktop so you can say okay i'm going to
click on ok so it will unpack the files
all the files which is required for
docker to successfully install that is
getting unpacked over here so it will
take some time to do the installation
because it's doing a lot of work here so
you can just wait for till the execution
of the installer to be completed and
once the installer is done you can open
your command line and start working on
the docker
so taking some time to extract the files
now it's asking us to you know do the
close and do the restart so once that is
done you will be able to proceed further
and you can just you know run the
command line and any docker command if
you can run so that will give you the
response whether the docker is installed
or not so you can see here the docker is
you know something which is installed so
you can run like docker version you will
be able to get a version of the client
when you do the restart of the machine
then at that moment of time the docker
server will also be started and then
this particular error message will go
off right now the docker daemon is not
up and running because the installation
requires a restart and when you close on
this one and go for the restart the
machine will be restarted here so this
is the way that how exactly we can go
for a docker installation and we can go
on that part so now let's begin with the
demo we'll be installing docker on an
ubuntu system so this is my system i'll
just open the terminal so the first
thing you can start with is removing any
docker installation that you probably
already have present in your system if
you want to start from scratch so this
is the command to do so sudo apt get
remove
docker
docker engine docker dot io enter your
password
and docker is removed so now we'll start
from scratch and we'll install docker
once again
before that i'll just clear my screen
okay so before i install docker let me
just ensure that all these softwares on
my system currently is in its latest
state
so sudo apt get update
great so that's done next thing we'll
actually install our docker
so type in sudo apt
get
install
docker
now as you can see here there's an error
that's occurred so sometimes it's
possible that due to the environment of
the machine that you're working in this
particular command does not work
in which case there's always another
command that you can start with
just type docker install
and that by itself will give you the
command you can use to install docker
so as it says here sudo apt install
docker dot io is a command that we will
need to execute to install docker
and after that we'll execute the suros
snap install docker so sudo apt install
docker dot io first
and this will install your docker
after that's done we will have
sudo snap install docker so snap install
docker installs a newly created snap
package
there are basically some other
dependencies for docker that you'll have
to install
of course since this is the installation
process for the entire docker io
it will take some time
great so our docker is installed the
next thing we do as i mentioned earlier
is that we need to install all the
dependency packages so the command for
that is
sudo snap install docker
enter your password
so with that we have completed the
installation process for docker but
we'll perform a few more stages where we
will test if the installation has been
done right
so before we move on with the testing
for docker let's once again just check
the version that we have installed
so for that the command is docker
version
and as you can see docker version
17.12.1
ce has been installed
next thing we do is we pull an image
from the docker hub
so docker run
hello
world
now hello world is a docker image which
is present on the docker hub docker hub
is basically a repository that you can
find online so with this command the
docker image hello world has been pulled
onto your system
so let's see if it's actually present on
your system now the command to check
this
is sudo docker images
and as you can see here hello world
repository
this is present on our system currently
so the image has been successfully
pulled onto the system and this means
that our docker is working
now we'll try out another command
sudo docker ps minus a
this displays all the containers that
you have pulled so far
so as you can see here there are three
hello world images displayed and all of
them are in exited state so i did this
demo previously too which is why the two
hello worlds which is created two
minutes ago is also displayed here and
the first hello world which has been
created a minute ago is the one we just
did for this demo now as you have
probably noticed that all the hello
world images over here all these
containers are in the exited state so
when you give the option for docker ps
minus a where minus a stands for all it
displays all the containers whether they
are in exited or running state if you
want to see only those containers which
are in their running state you can
simply execute sudo docker ps
sudo
docker
yes
and as you can see no container is
visible here because none of them are in
running state
in this presentation we're going to go
through a number of key things we're
going to compare docker versus
traditional virtual machines and what
are the differences and why you want to
choose docker over a virtual environment
we'll go through the advantages of
working with docker and the structure
and how you would build out a docker
environment and during that structure
we'll dig through the components and the
advanced components within docker at the
end of the presentation we'll go through
some basic commands and then show you
how those basic commands can be used in
a live demo so with all that said let's
get started so let's first of all
compare docker with a traditional
virtual machine so here we have the
architecture on the left and right of a
traditional virtual machine versus a
darker environment and there are some
things that you'll probably see
immediately that are big differences one
is that the virtual environment has
hypervisor layer where as the docker
environment has a docker engine layer
and then in addition to that there are
additional layers within the virtual
machine each of these really start
compounding and creating very
significant differences between a docker
environment and a virtual machine
environment so with a virtual machine
the actual memory usage is very high
whereas with the docker environment the
memory usage is very low if we look at
performance virtual machines when you
start building out particularly more
than one virtual machine on a server the
performance starts degrading and starts
getting poorer whereas with docker the
performance always stays really good
this is largely due to the lightweight
architecture used to construct the
docker containers themselves if we look
at portability virtual machines just are
terrible for portability they're still
dependent on the host operating system
and there's just a lot of problems that
happen when you are using virtual
machines for portability in contrast
docker was designed for portability so
you can actually build solutions in a
docker container environment and have
the guarantee that the solution will
work as you have built it no matter
where it's hosted finally boot up time
now the bit up time for a virtual
machine is fairly slow in comparison to
the boot up time for a docker
environment which is almost
instantaneous so we look at these in a
little bit more detail one of the other
challenges that you have with a virtual
machine is that if you have unused
memory within the environment you cannot
reallocate that memory so if you set up
an environment that has nine gigs of
memory that's being used but you have
six gigs that are free you can't do
anything with it though that whole nine
gig has been allocated to that virtual
machine in contrast with docker if you
have nine gigs and six gigs becomes free
that free memory can then be reallocated
and reused across other containers used
within that docker environment another
challenge is running multiple virtual
machines in a single environment that
can lead to instability and performance
issues whereas docker is designed to run
multiple containers
in the same environment and actually
gets better the more containers you run
in that hosted single docker engine
portability issues with a virtual
machine is the software can work on one
machine but then when you move that vm
to another machine suddenly some of the
software won't work because there are
some dependencies that haven't been
inherited correctly whereas docker
itself is designed specifically to be
able to run across multiple environments
and to be deployed very easily across
the systems and again the actual boot up
time for a vm it just takes a long time
you took about minutes in contrast to
the milliseconds that it takes for a
docker environment to boot up so let's
dig into what docker actually is and
what allows for these great performance
improvements over a traditional vm
environment so docker itself is an os
virtualized software platform and it
allows it organizations to really easily
create deploy and run applications as
what are called docker containers that
have all the dependencies within that
container very easily
and the container itself is really just
a very lightweight package that has all
the instructions and dependencies such
as frameworks libraries bins etc all
within that container and that container
itself can then be moved from
environment to environment very easily
if we to look in our devops lifecycle
the place where docker really shines is
in deployment because when you're
actually at the point of deploying your
solution you want to be able to
guarantee that the code that has been
tested will actually work in the
production environment but in addition
to that what we often find is that when
you're actually building the code and
you're actually testing the code having
a container running the solution at
those stages is also a really good plus
because what happens is that the people
building the code and testing the code
are able to validate their work in the
same environment that would be used for
the production environment so really
you can use docker in multiple stages
within your devops cycle but it becomes
really valuable in the deployment stage
so let's look at some of the key
advantages that you have with docker
some things that we've already covered
is that you can do
rapid deployment and you can do it
really fast the environment itself is
highly portable and was designed for
that in mind the efficiencies that
you'll see will allow you to run
multiple docker containers in a single
environment as compared to more
traditional vm environments the
configuration itself can be scripted
through a language called yaml which
allows you to be able to write out and
describe the docker environment that you
want to create this in turn allows you
to be able to scale your environment
very very quickly but with all of these
advantages probably the one that is most
critical to the type of work that we're
doing today is security you have to
ensure that the environment you are
running is a highly secure but highly
scalable environment and i'm very
pleased to say that docker takes
security very seriously so you'll see it
as one of the key talents for the actual
architecture of the system that you're
implementing so let's look at how docker
actually works within your environment
so docker works there is a what's called
a docker engine the docker engine is
really comprised of the two is via a
rest api the server as you can imagine
has the instructions that are
communicated out to the client and
instructs the client on what to do the
connection between the client and the
server the communication is via a rest
api
on older systems you can take advantage
of the docker toolbox which allows you
to go ahead and control the docker
compose and kitimatic so let's now go
into what the actual root components
though of docker are so let's have a
look at those key components there are
four components that we're going to go
through we have the docker client and
server we have docker images we have the
docker registry and the docker container
we're going to step through each of
these one by one so let's look at the
docker clients and server first so the
docker clients and server is a command
line instructed solution where you would
use terminal on your mac or command line
on your pc or linux system to be able to
issue commands from the docker daemon
the communication between the docker
client and the docker host and is via a
rest api
so pull command which would send an
instruction to the daemon which would
then form the interaction of pulling in
the correct components
such as an image or container or
registry to the docker client the docker
daemon itself is actually a service
which actually performs all sorts of
operating and performance services and
as you'd imagine the docker daemon is
constantly listing across the rest api
to see if it needs to perform any
specific requests if you want to trigger
and start the whole process you what you
want to do is use the command payment
and that will start all of your
performances and then you have a docker
host which actually runs the docker
daemon and registry itself so now let's
look into the actual structure of a
docker image so a docker image itself is
a template which contains instructions
for the docker container and that
template is written with a language
called yaml and yaml stands for yet
another markup language it's very easy
to learn the docker image itself is
built within that yaml file and then
hosted as a file in the docket registry
the image is really comprised of several
key layers and you start with your base
layer which will typically have your
base image and this instance is your
base operating system such as ubuntu and
then you then have layer of dependencies
above that this would then comprise the
instructions in a read-only file that
would become your docker file so let's
let you go through and look at what one
of those in sets of instructions would
look like so here we have four layers of
instructions we have a from pull run and
then command so what does that actually
look like in our layers so to break this
down the from creates a layer which is
based on ubuntu and then what we're
doing is we're adding in files from the
docker repository onto that base command
that base layer and then what we want to
be able to do is then say okay what are
the run commands so we can actually then
build the container within the
environment and then we want to be able
to then have a command line that
actually executes something within that
container and in this instance the
command is to run python so one of
things that we will see is that as we
set up multiple containers each new
container is a new layer with new images
within the docker environment each
container is completely separate from
the other containers within your darker
environment so you're able to create
your own separate read write
instructions within each layer what's
interesting is that if you delete a
layer then the layer above it will also
get deleted so what happens when you
pull in a layer but something has
changed in the the core image what's
interesting then is that the actual main
image of itself cannot be modified once
you've copied the image you can then
modify it locally but you can never
modify the actual base image itself so
here are some callouts for the
components within a docket image so the
base layer are in read-only format the
layers can be combined in a union file
system to create a single image the
union file system saves memory space by
avoiding duplication of files and this
allows a file system to appear as a
writable but without modifying the file
which is known as a copy on write the
actual base layers themselves are read
only so to be able to get around this
structure within a docker container the
docker environment itself uses what's
known as a copy and write strategy
within the images and the containers
themselves and so what this allows you
to do is you can actually copy the files
for better efficiency across your entire
container environment the copy and write
strategy does make docker super
efficient and what you're able to do all
the time is keep reducing the amount of
disk space you're using and the amount
of performance that you're taking from
the server and that's really again a key
element for docker is just this constant
ability to be able to keep improving the
efficiency within the actual system
itself all right so let's go on to item
number three which is the docker
registry so the docker registry itself
is the place where you would host and
distribute the different types of images
that you have created or you want to be
used within your environment the actual
repository itself is just a collection
of docker images and those docker images
are built on instructions that you would
write with yaml and are very easily
stored and shared and what you can
actually do is you can actually
associate specific name tags to the
actual docker images themselves so it's
easy for people to be able to find and
share that image within the docker
registry itself one of the things you
actually see as we go through the demos
you actually see us actually using the
the tag name and you'll see how it is an
alphanumeric identifying how we actually
use it to actually create the actual
container itself one of the things you
can do to as start off how you would
manage registry is you can actually use
the publicly accessible docker hub
registry which is available to anybody
but you can also create your own
registry for your own use internally the
actual registry that you create
internally can have both public and
private images that you create and this
may be for various reasons of how you
structure your environment the actual
commands you would use to actually
connect to the registry are both push
and pull push is to actually push a new
container environment that you've
created from your local manager node to
the remote registry and a pool allows
you to pull a new client that has been
created and is being shared so again
full command and it pulls and retrieves
a docket image from the docker registry
and makes it very easy for people to
share different images consistently
across teams and a push command allows
you to take a new command that you've
created a new container that you've
created and push it to the registry
whether it's docker hub or whether it's
your own private registry and allow it
to be shared across your teams some key
did you know in docker registry deleting
a repository is not a reversible action
so if you delete a repository it's gone
so let's go into the final stage here
which is the actual docker container
itself stations and its dependencies
bundled together so gives instructions
that you would have for the solution
that you're looking to run it's actually
really light because of the redundancy
that's built into how you structure the
container and the container itself is
then inherently also extremely portable
what's really good about running a
container though is that it does run
completely in isolation so you're able
to share it very easily from grouped
group and you are guaranteed that even
if you are running a container it's not
going to be impacted by any host os
peculiarities or unique setups as you
would have in a vm or a
non-containerized environment the actual
memory that you have on a docker
environment that can be shared across
multiple containers which is really
useful typically when you have a vm you
would have a defined amount of memory
for each vm environment the change you
start running into though is that you
can't share that memory whereas with
docker you can easily share the memory
and for a single environment across
multiple containers
the actual container is built using
docket images and the commands to
actually run those images is a run
command so let's actually go through a
basic structure of how you would run a
docket image so you go into terminal
window and you would write in docker run
redis
and then it would run a container called
redis so we're going to go in and if you
don't have the redis image locally
installed it will then pull it from the
registry then the new docker container
redis will be then available within your
environment so you can actually start
using it so let's look at why containers
are so light lightweight they're so
lightweight because they really have
been able to get away from some of the
additional layers that you have in
virtualization within vms and the
biggest one is the hypervisor and the
need to run on a host operating system
those are two big big elements so if you
can get rid of those then you're doing
great so let's look at some of the more
advanced concepts within the docker
environment and we're going to look at
two advanced components one is docker
compose and the second is docker swamp
so let's look at docker compose docker
compose is really designed for
running multiple containers as a single
service and it does this by running each
container in isolation but allowing the
containers to interact with each other
as was stated earlier on you would
actually write the compose environment
using yaml as the language in the files
that you would create so where would you
use something like docker compose so an
example would be if you are running an
apache server with my sql database and
you need to create additional containers
to run additional services without the
need to start each one separately and
this is where you would write a set of
files using dr compose to be able to
help balance out that demand
so let's now look at docker swarm so
docker swarm is a service that allows
you to be able to control multiple
docker environments within a single
platform
so what you actually are looking at
doing is within your docker swamp is
we're treating each node as a docker
daemon and we're actually having an api
that's interacting with each of those
nodes there are two types of node that
you're going to be getting comfortable
working with one is the manager node and
the second is the worker node and as
you'd expect the manager node is the one
sending out the instructions to all of
the worker nodes but there is a two-way
communication that is happening the
communication allows for the imagine
node to be able to manage the
instructions and then listen to and
receive updates from the working node so
if anything happens within this
environment the node can react
and adjust the architecture of the
worker node so it's always in sync it
was really great for
large scaled environments so finally
let's go through what are some of the
basic commands you would use within
docker and once we've gone through all
these basic commands we'll actually show
you a demo of how you'd actually use
them as well so if we're going to go in
probably the first command is to install
docker and so if you have yam installed
you just do yum install docker and
you'll install docker onto your computer
to start the docker daemon as you want
to do a system ctl start docker the
command to remove a docker image is
docker rmi and then the image id itself
and that's not the image name that's the
actual alphanumeric id number that you
want to uh grab the command line to
download a new image is docker pull and
then the name of the image you'd want to
pull and by default you're going to be
pulling from the docker default registry
that will then connect to your docker
daemon and download the images from that
registry khan the command line to run an
image is docker run and then the image
id
and then we have the if we wanted to
pull specifically from docker hub then
we would have a docker pull and then the
image name and colon its tag
to pull build an image from a docker
file you would do docker build dash t
and then the image name and colon tag to
shut down the container you do docker
stop container id the access for running
a container is docker exec it container
id bash
so we've gone through all the different
commands but let's actually see how they
would actually look and we're going to
go ahead and do a demo so welcome to
this demo where we're going to go ahead
and put together all of the different
commands that we have outlined in the
presentation for docker uh first is just
to list all of the docker images that we
have so we do
sudo docker images and we enter in our
password
and this will now list out the images
that we've created already and we have
three images there
so let's go ahead and pull a docker
image so to do that we'll we'll go ahead
and type sudo
docker
and actually we don't want to do image
we want to
select pull
and then the name of the image that we
want to pull which is going to be my
sequel
and by default this is actually going to
go ahead and use the latest my sequel
command my sql image that we have so
it's now go ahead and pull this image
it's going to take a few minutes
depending on your internet connection
speed it's kind of a large file that has
to be downloaded so we'll just wait for
that to download
you can see the others have completed
just waiting for this last file to
download
almost there
once that's done what we're going to go
ahead and do is we'll actually
run the docking container and create a
new container using the image that we
just downloaded but we have to wait for
this to download first
all right so the image has been pulled
from docker hub
and let's go ahead and create the new
docker container so we're going to do
sudo docker
run
dash d
dash
p
0.0.0.0
[Music]
colon
colon 80.
and then put in my sql
colon
latest so we have the latest version
and we have our new token
and that shows our new docker container
has been created
now let's go ahead and see if the
container is running
and we'll do
sudo docker
out of updation in the operating code
needs to be updated at first and as the
requirements of the company change the
infrastructure's configuration needs to
change and finally of course the people
need coordination so if you have a team
of system administrators and say person
a makes some change to the code person b
c d and so on need to be well aware when
the change is made as to why it was made
what was the change made and where
exactly this change was made so
direction here this notes pushes these
files onto the node so the complete
control lies with the server on your
right side we have the pull
configuration in case of pull
configuration the nodes pull against the
server to first check if there's any
change in the configurations required if
there is the nodes themselves pull these
configuration files chef follows pull
configuration and how it does this we'll
see further in our video another
important term often used with chef
infrastructure as code so let's
understand what this term infrastructure
as code means through this small story
so here's tim tim's a system
administrator at a large company now he
receives a task he has to set up a
server and he has to install 20 software
applications over it so he begins he
sets up the server but then it hits him
it would take him the entire night to
install 20 software applications
wouldn't things have been much simpler
if he just had a code to do so well of
course codes do make things much simpler
codes have a number of advantages
they're easily modifiable so if today
tim is told we need mysql installed on
20 systems tim simply writes a code to
do so and the very next day tim is told
we changed our mind we don't need maya
skill i think we'll just use oracle this
does not bother him because now he just
opens the file he makes a few
corrections in his code and that should
work just fine code is also testable so
if tim had to write 10 commands to do
something and at his tenth command he
realized the very first command he wrote
there was something not right there well
that would be quite tiresome wouldn't it
with codes however you can test it even
before running it and all the bugs can
be caught and corrected codes are also
deployable so they're easily deployable
and they're deployable multiple times so
now that we saw the various advantages
of having codes let's see what
infrastructure as code exactly is here's
the definition infrastructure as code is
a type of id infrastructure where the
operation team manages the code rather
than a manual procedure so
infrastructure as a code allows the
operations team to take care of a code
which automatically performs various
procedures rather than having to
manually do those procedures so with
this feature all your policies and your
configurations are written as code let's
now look at the various components of
chef so our first component is the
workstation the workstation is the
system where the system administrator
sits he or she creates the codes for
configuring your notes now these codes
which in case of chef are written in
ruby are called the recipes and you'll
have multiple number of recipes so a
collection of recipes is called a
cookbook now these cookbooks are only
created at the workstation but they need
to be stored at the server so the knife
is a command line tool so it's basically
a command that you will see us executing
in one of our demos that shifts these
cookbooks from the workstation over to
the server a second component is the
server so servers like the middleman it
lies between your workstation and your
nodes and this is where all your
cookbooks are stored because as you saw
previously the knife sends these
cookbooks over from the workstation
to the server the server can be hosted
locally that's on your workstation
itself or it can be remote so you can
have your server at a different location
you can even have it on the cloud
platform and a final components the node
so nodes are the systems that require
the configuration in a chef architecture
you can have a number of nodes oh hi is
a service which is installed on your
node and it is responsible for
collecting all the information regarding
your current state of the node this
information is then sent over to the
server to be compared against the
configuration files and check if any new
configuration is required chef client is
another such service on your node which
is responsible for all the
communications with the server so
whenever the node has a demand for a
recipe the shift client is responsible
for communicating this demand to the
server since you have a number of nodes
in a chef architecture it's not
necessary that each node is identical so
of course every node can have a
different configuration let's now have a
look at the chef architecture so here we
have a workstation one server machine
and two nodes you can have any number of
nodes first things first the system
administrator must create a recipe so
the recipes that are mentioned in our
chef architecture are just dummy recipes
we look into actual functioning recipes
later in our demo so you have one recipe
two recipes three recipes and a
collection of recipes forms a cookbook
so guys if you look at the recipe in
source you have simply learn three dot
erb erb is the extension for your ruby
files so the cookbooks are only created
at the workstation they now need to be
sent over to the server where they are
stored and this is the task of the knife
knife is a command line tool which is
responsible for transferring all your
cookbooks onto the server from the
workstation here's the command for
running your knife knife upload simply
db where simply dash db is the name of
the cookbook we then move on to our node
machines at our nodes we run the ohi
service the ohi service will collect all
information regarding the current state
of your notes and send it over to the
chef client when you run the chef client
these informations are sent over to the
server and they are tested against the
cookbooks so if there is any discrepancy
between the current state of your nodes
and the cookbook that is if one of the
notes does not match the configurations
required the cookbook is then on the
server and executed at the node this
sets the note to the right state there
are various flavors of chef read through
these first we have chef solo with chef
solo there's no separate server so your
cookbooks are located on the node itself
now this kind of configuration is used
only when you have just a single node to
take care of the next flavor is the
hosted chef with hosted chef you still
have your workstation and your node but
your server is now used as a service on
the cloud this really makes things
simple because you don't have to set up
a server yourself and it still performs
all the functioning of a typical chef
this is the configuration you will
notice that we'll be using in our demo
chef client server with shift client
server you have a workstation you have
server and you have n number of nodes
now this is the traditional chef
architecture this is the one we have
used for all the explanations previously
and finally we have private chef private
chef is also known as enterprise chef in
this case your workstation server and
node all are located within the
enterprise infrastructure this is the
main difference between chef client
server and private chef in case of shep
client server all these three machines
could be dispersed the enterprise
version of chef also provides the
liberty to add extra layers of security
and other features and we reach the
final part of our video where we'll have
the hands-on so before we dive into our
demo let me just quickly give you an
introduction to it we'll be using two
virtual boxes both sent to s7 one will
be used as workstation while the other
will be a node so we are just using one
node to make things simple the server
will be used as a service on the cloud
now these are the steps we'll be
performing during our demo we'll first
download and install the chef dk on our
workstation we then make an empty
cookbook file and we'll write a recipe
into it we need to then set up the
server so as i mentioned earlier server
will be a service on the cloud so you'll
have to create a profile but this will
be completely free we then link the
workstation to the server and will
upload the recipe to the server the
notes will now download the cookbooks
from the server and configure themselves
so now that you have some idea about
what we'll be doing let's move on to the
actual demo we begin our demo
here's my oracle vm virtualbox manager i
have two machines here i've already
created my workstation and node both of
these are sent to s7 machines
just for you to differentiate this is my
terminal and for my workstation it's a
black background with white text and as
of my note it's a black background with
green text
the first thing you do is you go to your
workstation box and open a web browser
search for chef dk installation
go to the first link which is your
chef's official page a very warm welcome
to all our viewers i'm anjali from
simply learn and today i'll be showing
you how you can install the
configuration management tool ansible so
let's have a brief about why one would
use ansible and what exactly is ansible
so if you consider the case of an
organization it has a very large
infrastructure which means it has more
than probably hundreds of systems and
giving one or even a small team of
people the responsibility to configure
all these systems makes their work
really tough repetitive and as you know
manual work is always prone to errors so
ansible is a tool which can automate the
configuration of all these systems with
ansible a small team of system
administrators can write simple code in
yaml and these codes are deployed onto
the hundreds and thousands of servers
which configures them to the desired
states so ansible automates
configuration management that is
configuring your systems it automates
orchestration which means it brings
together a number of applications and
decides an order in which these are
executed and it also automates
deployment of the applications now that
we know what ansible does let's move on
to the installation of ansible so here
is my oracle vm virtualbox manager i'll
be using two systems there's the node
system which is basically my client
system and there's the server system or
the master system so let's begin at our
server system
so this is my master system guys so the
first thing we do is we download our
ansible tool
so one or puppet ansible is a push type
of configuration management tool so what
this means is that the entire control
here lies with your master or your
server system this is where you write
your configuration files and these are
also responsible for pushing these
configuration files onto your node or
client system as and when required
creates our ansible tool is installed
now we need to open an ansible host file
and there we'll specify the details of
our node or client machine
so this is a ansible host file as you
can see here the entire file is
commented but there's a certain syntax
that you'd observe for example here we
have a group name web servers under
which we have the ip addresses a certain
host name so this is about how we'll be
adding the details for our client system
first we need to give a group name
under this group basically we add all
the clients which require a certain type
of configuration since we are using just
one node we'll give only the details for
that particular node first we need to
add the ip address of our client machine
so let's just go back to our client
machine
and this here is the ip address
192.168.2.11
once you have typed in your ip address
give a space and then we'll specify the
user for our client machine
so all communications between the server
or the master system and the client or
the node system takes place through ssh
ssh basically provides a secure channel
for the transfer of information
follow this up with your password
in my case it's the roots password
and that's it we are done so now we save
this to our terminal
so now that our hosts file is written
the next thing we do is we write our
playbook so playbook is the technical
term used for all the configuration
files that we write in ansible now
playbooks are written in yaml yaml is
extremely simple to both write and
understand it's in fact very close to
english
yaml first starts with three dashes this
indicates the beginning of your file
next thing we need to give a name to our
playbook
so name
and i'm going to name my playbook sample
book
we next need to specify our host systems
which is basically the systems at which
the configuration file or the playbook
in our case will be executed so we'll be
executing this at the client machines
mentioned under the group ansible
servers so we had just one client
machine under it we'll still mention the
group name
we next need to specify the username
with which we'll be logging into our
client machine
which is root in my case
and become true specifies that you need
to become the root to execute this
playbook so becoming the roots called a
privilege escalation
next we need to specify our tasks so
these are basically the actions that the
playbook will be performing so you would
have noticed everything so far is
aligned that is name host remote user
become and task because these are at one
level now whatever comes under task will
be shifted slightly towards the right
although yaml is extremely simple to
understand and read both it's a little
tricky while writing because you need to
be very careful about the indentations
and the spacing
so my first task is install httpd which
is basically apache server
so now my command yum and this will be
installing the httpd package
and the latest state of it will be
installed so that's our first task
now our second task would be running our
apache service
so name
run httpd
and the action which is service
will be performed on httpd hence the
name httpd
and state
must be started
now we come to our third task
so here we'll create a very simple web
page that will be hosted
so create content is the name of our
task
and the content that we are creating
here will basically be copied
to our note system at a particular file
location that we'll provide
our content will be congrats
and then we'll provide the destination
at which this file will be copied
so this is the default location for all
our html files
and that's it we are done writing our
playbook just save this and go back to
your terminal
before we execute the playbook or push
the playbook onto our note system let's
check the syntax of our playbook so the
command for doing so is
and if everything is fine with your
playbook the output would be just your
playbook name so our syntax is perfectly
fine now we can push on the playbook to
our node or the client machine
and that's the syntax for doing so now
as your playbook is being sent over to
the client machine you can see that
first the facts are gathered that is the
current state of your client machine is
first fetched to check what all is to be
changed and what is already present so
the first thing is installing httpd so
our system already had http so it says
ok because this does not need to be
changed our next task was running httpd
now although our system had the apache
service it was not running so that is
one thing that was changed the next was
there was no content available so the
content was also added so two tasks were
changed and four things were okay now
everything seems fine and before you
move any forward it is very important
that you check this one line of
documentation provided by ansible you
have all kind of information available
here regarding which all tasks were
executed
if your client machine was reachable or
unreachable and so on so now that
everything's fine here we can move on to
our note system
and we'll just go to our browser so if
our playbook has been executed here what
should happen is that the httpd service
must be in the running state and the web
page that we created should be hosted so
let's just type localhost
and great everything is working fine so
our webpage is displayed here so we come
to an end for our installation and
configuration video for the
configuration management tool ansible if
you have any doubts please post them in
the comment section below and we'll
definitely get back to you as soon as
possible ansible today as one of the key
tools that you would have within your
devops environment
so the things that we're going to go
through today is we're going to cover
why you would want to use a product like
ansible what ansible really is and how
it's of value to you in your
organization the differences between
ansible and other products that are
similar to it on the market and what
makes ansible a compelling product and
then we're going to dig into the
architecture for ansible we're going to
look at how you would create a playbook
how you'd manage your inventory of your
server environments and then what is the
actual workings of ansible as a little
extra we're going to also throw in
ansible tower one of the secret source
solutions that you can use for improving
the speed and performance of how you
create your ansible environments and
finally we're going to go through a use
case by looking at hootsuite social
media management company and how they
use ansible to really improve the
efficiency within their organizations so
let's jump into this
so the big question is why ansible so
you have to think of ansible as another
tool that you have within your devops
environment for helping manage the
service and this definitely falls on the
operations sides of the dev ops equation
so if we look here we have a picture of
sam and like yourselves sam is a system
administrator and he is responsible for
maintaining the infrastructure for all
the different servers within his company
so some of the servers that he may have
that he has to maintain could be web
servers running apache they could be
database servers running uh mysql and if
you only have a few servers then that's
fairly easy to maintain i mean if you
have three web servers and two database
servers and let's face it would we all
love just to have one or two servers to
manage it would be really easy to
maintain the trick however is as we
start increasing the number of servers
and this is a reality of the
environments that we live and operate in
it becomes increasingly difficult to
create consistent setup of different
infrastructures such as web servers and
databases for the simple reason that
we're all human as if we had to update
and maintain all of those servers by
hand there's a good chance that we would
not set up each server identically now
this is where anspo really comes to the
rescue and helps you become an efficient
operations team ansible like other
system solutions such as chef and puppet
uses code that you can write and
describe the installation and setup of
your servers so you can actually repeat
it and deploy those servers consistently
into multiple areas so now you don't
have to have one person redoing and
re-following setup procedures you just
write one script and then each script
can be executed and have a consistent
environment so we've gone through why
you'd want to use ansible let's step
through what ansible really is
so you know this is all great but you
know how do we actually use these tools
in our environment so
ansible is a tool that really is
note and then within quotes insert the
host name of your note system
so my note system's host name is client
the package you wish to install which in
our case is httpd
and the action to be performed
and that's it a very small and simple
code save this file
now let's go back to our node system
and let's pull the second version of the
same configuration file so every time
you execute this command as we did
previously to what happens is that the
agent service so the agent service
basically checks on your master system
if there's any new configuration file
added or if there's any change to the
previous configuration file made if so
then the catalog is applied once again
so now our catalog's applied in 1.55
seconds so now to check if our catalog
served its purpose let's just open a
browser
just type localhost here
and as you can see if your httpd package
has been successfully installed the
apache testing page will appear here so
in this session what we can do is we're
going to cover what and why you would
use puppets what are the different
elements and components of puppet and
how does it actually work and then we'll
look into the companies that are
adopting puppet and what are the
advantages that they have now received
by having puppet within their
organization and finally we'll wrap
things up by reviewing how you can
actually write a manifest in puppet so
let's get started so why puppet so here
is a scenario that as an administrator
you may already be familiar with you as
an administrator have multiple servers
that you have to work with and manage so
what happens when a server goes down
it's not a problem you can jump onto
that server and you can fix it but what
if the scenario changes and you have
multiple servers going down so here is
where puppet shows its strap with
puppets all you have to do is write a
simple script that can be written with
ruby and write out and deploy to the
servers your settings for each of those
servers the code gets pushed out and to
the servers that are having problems and
then you can choose to either roll back
to those servers to their previous
working states or set them to a new
state and do all of this in a matter of
seconds and it doesn't matter how large
your server environment is you can reach
to all of these servers your environment
is secure you're able to deploy your
software and you're able to do this all
through infrastructure as code which is
the advanced devops model for building
out solutions so let's dig deeper into
what puppet actually is so puppet is a
configuration management tool maybe
similar tools like chef that you may
already be familiar with it ensures that
all your systems are configured to a
desired and predictable state public can
also be used as a deployment tool for
software automatically you can deploy
your software to all of your systems or
to specific systems and this is all done
with code this means you can test the
environment and you can have a guarantee
that the environment you want is written
and deployed accurately so let's go
through those components of puppet so
here we have a breakdown of the puppet
environment and on the top we have the
main server environment and then below
that we have the client environment that
would be installed on each of the
servers that would be running within
your network so if we look at the top
part of the screen we have here our
puppet master store which has and
contains our main configuration files
and those are comprised of manifests
that are actual codes for configuring
their clients we have templates that
combine our codes together to render a
final document and you have files that
would be deployed as content that could
be potentially downloaded by the clients
wrapping this all together is a module
of manifest templates and files you
would apply a certificate authority to
sign the actual documents so that the
clients actually know that they're
receiving the appropriate and authorized
modules outside of the master server
where you'd create your manifest
templates and files you would have
public client is a piece of software
that is used to configure a specific
machine there are two parts to the
client one is the agent that constantly
interacts with the master server to
ensure that the certificates are being
updated appropriately and then you have
the fact that the current state of the
client that is used and communicated
back to through the agent so let's step
through the workings of puppet so the
puppet environment is a master slave
architecture the clients themselves are
distributed across your network and they
are constantly communicating back to a
master server environment where you have
your puppet modules the client agent
sends a certificate with the id of that
server back to the master and then the
master will then sign that certificate
and send it back to the client and this
authentication allows for a secure and
verifiable communication between client
and master the factor then collects the
state of the client and sends that to
the master based on the facts sent back
the master then compiles manifests into
the catalogs and those catalogs are sent
back to the clients and an agent on the
client will then initiate the catalog a
report is generated by the client that
describes any changes that have been
made and sends that back to the master
with the goal here of ensuring that the
master has full understanding of the
hardware running software in your
network this process is repeated at
regular intervals ensuring all client
systems are up to date so let's have a
look at companies that are using puppet
today there are a number of companies
that have adopted puppet as a way to
manage their infrastructure so companies
that are using public today include
spotify google att so why are these
companies choosing to use puppet as
their main configuration management tool
the answer can be seen if we look at a
specific company staples so staples
chose to take and use puppet for their
configuration management tool and use it
within their own private cloud the
results were dramatic the amount of time
that the it organization was able to
save in deploying and managing their
infrastructure through using puppets
enabled them to open up time to allow to
experiment with other and new projects
and assignments a real tangible benefit
to a company so let's look at how you
write a manifest in pocket so so
manifests are designed for writing out
in code how you would configure a
specific node in your server environment
the manifests are compiled into catalogs
which are then executed on the client
each of the manifests are written in the
language of ruby with a dot pp extension
now if we step through the five key
steps for writing a manifest they are
one create your manifest and that is
written by the system administrator two
compile your manifest is compiled into a
catalog three deploy the catalog is then
deployed onto the clients four execute
the catalogs are run on the client by
the agent and clients are configured to
a specific and desired state if we
actually look into how manifest is
written it's written with a very common
syntax if you've done any work with ruby
or really configuration of systems in
the past this may look very familiar to
you so we break out the work that we
have here you start off with a package
file or service as your resource type
and then you give it a name and then you
look at the features that need to be
said such as ip address then you're
actually looking to have a command
written such as present or start the
manifest can contain multiple resource
types if we continue to write our
manifest and puppet the default keyword
applies a manifest to all clients so an
example would be to create a file path
that creates a folder called sample in a
main folder called etc the specified
content is written into a file that is
then posted into that folder and then
we're going to say we want to be able to
trigger an apache service and then
ensure environment that you're looking
to manage that will determine which of
these four tools you should use the
tools themselves are open source so go
out and experiment with them there's a
lot of videos our team has done a ton of
videos on these tools and so feel free
to find out other tools that we have
then covered so you can learn very
quickly how to use them but consider the
requirements that you have and consider
the capabilities of your team if you
have ruby developers or you have someone
on your team that knows ruby your
ability to choose a broader set of tools
becomes much more interesting if however
you're new to coding then you may want
to consider yaml-based tools again the
final answer is going to be up to you
and will be really interested on what
your decision is
monitoring as the term says you're
monitoring you're watching you're the
logging your production environment so
of course there are a whole bunch of
monitoring tools so they become an
important part of your production
environment and a lot of these
monitoring tools are also i've seen them
also being used especially in your uac
environment
and
you can optionally have them for some
time even in your uh you know
development environment
no not not development different
development services are usually not
very uh
high-end configurations but you know
maybe a decent uh development slash
integration
server especially if you have uh
long-running scripts and if you have uh
programs that use a lot of
servers uh you know maybe cpu or
processing power
so then you can have monitoring tools
when you're writing such scripts and you
know
uh you are
doing the uh unit testing for those
scripts
so that you know to see uh what kind of
server utilization
happens when you run this script you
know if you will put this in production
will it actually you know slow down your
production server and what kind of
impact that you have on the you know
your rest of your application
or other applications running on that
server
but
this particular chapter is more in
context with production environment so
these tools to basically monitor your
server they monitor your switches of
course they monitor your application
then any services that you have deployed
on your servers
and they generate alerts when something
goes wrong and that's the whole job of
monitoring it just continuously watching
continuously looking at what is running
what is happening what is going up what
is going down
when is the cpu peaking when is memory
peaking and all that so that you can uh
you typically send limits for these uh
all these different parameters and
anytime any of these parameters goes
outside of that limit you know even more
than that or less than that
these monitoring tools usually send out
an alert
uh and these alerts could again be sms
alerts email alerts and there are there
are usually people monitoring
these monitoring tools
to look uh look out for any
issues reported
and they also generate alerts when the
problem has been dissolved so it will
work both ways
so nagios
is an open source monitoring tool
and it can
even monitor your network services
there's a little diagram here which
is too small
but here is najib somewhere what i can
read
and
status
these are different devices
i think no no no yeah these are
different devices to which nagios is
sending the status there's a browser
there's an sms there's an email
and then there's a graph also
and these are different objects
that nigel is basically monitoring this
is an smtp server i can read smtp
i don't know dcpip no i don't know some
database server okay this is a database
server and this is an application server
this is a switch router okay okay i can
read that now so these are the different
kind of objects these are different kind
of servers that nagios
monitors
and these are the different kind of uh
devices or statuses that it can send
so it helps monitor your cpu usage your
disk usage and you know even your system
logs
and it uses the plug-in script that can
be written you know in
any scripting language actually
do not use remote plug-in executors are
basically agents that allow remote
scripts
to be executed as well and
these scripts are usually executed to
monitor
again
your cpu just you say number of users
logged in who is logged in who's logged
in at what time logged out at what time
and all uh
so all these monitoring tools work on
the concept of polling uh so
polling is more like you know they
so the nrp agent is a program that will
continuously keep pulling a machine for
certain parameters that are configured
in nagios to be monitored so this
program continues to keep pinging the
server bringing the program
uh you know to keep checking for what it
has been asked to check so in case of uh
logged in users you keep checking uh at
a you know like maybe every 30 seconds
or every one minute
you keep uh pinging
to see how many users have logged in
onto this server and who are the users
who have logged in what time they logged
in what time they logged out and things
like that
so now just poll agents on remote
machines this is what basically it means
has asian programs that can you know
help you
pull
or ping even remote machines
the nigeria's remote data processor is
an agent that allows the you know
flexible data transports and you know it
uses uh http and
xml protocols to do that
and we'll be talking about uh
essentially your databases and uh
data server usages like you know within
if you have an oracle database how many
database instances are there you know
how
your load balancing is set up on that
data is moving
between different uh
database servers within oracle
and how
data is moving within the load balancers
and um there's always a drp uh there's
always a backup with database so that's
why you see me mention trp as soon as i
say the word database
and uh if there's a
backup plan you know
uh
how how's the data moving how much time
does did the backup take did you take
too much time
and why you know why did it take so it
helps you do all those kind of
monitoring
the ns client is basically mainly used
to monitor windows machines and
typically when we talk about servers uh
we end up
talking more about you know unix on
linux servers
of course now with a lot of microsoft
technologies being uh robust to dancing
itself and there are some small checks
that needs to be done
so and by default jenkins launches on
the port 8080 so let me just open up
localhost 8080.
there's a small checking that will be
done as a part of the installation
process wherein i need to type in the
hash key all right so there's a very
very simple hash key that gets stored
out here so i'll have to just copy this
path
if at all you're running as a war file
you would see that in your logs
all right so this is a simple hash key
that gets created every time when you do
a jenkins station so as a part of the
installation it just asks you to do this
so if that is not great it will crib
about it but this looks good so it's
going ahead
all right one important part during the
installation so you would need to
install some recommended plugins
what happens is the plugins are all
related to each other so it's like the
typical rpm kind of a problem where you
try to install some plugin and it's got
a dependency which is not installed and
you get into all those issues
in order to get rid of that what jenkins
recommends there's a bunch of plugins
that is already recommended so just go
ahead and blindly click that
install recommended plugin so if you see
there is
a whole lot of plugins which are bare
essential plugins that is required for
jenkins in order to run properly so
jenkins as a part of the installation
would get all these plugins and then
install it for you
this is a good combination to kind of
begin with and mind you at this moment
jenkins needs
lots of bandwidth in terms of network so
in case your you know your network is
not so good few of these plugins would
kind of fail
and these plugins are all you know on
available on openly
or or mirrored sites and sometimes some
of them may be down so do not worry in
case some of these plugins kind of fail
to install you'll get an option to kind
of retry installing them but just ensure
that you know at least most or 90 95 of
all these plugins are installed without
any problems let me pause the video here
for a minute and then get back once all
these plugins are installed
my plugin installation is all good there
was no failures in any of my plugins so
after that i get to create this first
admin user again this is one important
point that you got to remember
keen given any username and password but
ensure that you kind of remember that
because it's very hard to get back your
username and password in case you forget
it all right so i'm going to create a
very very simple username and password
something that i can remember
i will
that's my name and
an email id is kind of optional but it
doesn't allow me to go ahead in case i
don't so i just given an admin and i got
a password i've got i remember my
password this is my full name
all right i say save and finish
all right that kind of completed my
jenkins installation
it was not that tough was it
now that i have my jenkins installed
correctly let me quickly walk you
through some bare minimal configurations
that is required these are kind of a
first time configuration that is
required so and also let me warn you the
ui people to wrap their head around it
specifically the windows guys
but if at all you're a java guy you know
how painful it is to write ui in java
you will kind of appreciate you know all
the effort that has gone into the ui
bottom line you are a little hard to you
know wrap your head around it but once
you start using it possibly you'll start
liking it
all right so let me get into something
called as managed in cans
this can be viewed like a
main menu for all jenkins configuration
so i'll get into some of those important
ones
something called as configure system
configure system this is where you kind
of put in the configuration for your
complete jenkins instance
few things to kind of look out for this
is a home directory this is a java home
where all the configurations all the
workspace anything and everything
regarding jenkins is stored out here
system message you want to put in some
message on the system you just type in
whatever you want and it's probably show
up somewhere up here on the menu number
of executors very very important
configuration this just lets jenkin know
at any point in time how many jobs or
how many threads can be run you can kind
of visualize it like a thread that can
be run on this particular instance as a
thumb rule if at all you're on a single
core system number of executors two
should be good enough
in case at any point in time there are
multiple jobs that kind of get triggered
at the same time in case the number of
executors are less compared to the
number of jobs that have that woken up
no need to panic because they will all
get queued up and eventually jenkins
will get to running those jobs just bear
in mind that whenever a new job kind of
you know gets triggered the cpu usage
and the memory usage in terms of the
disk right is very high on the jenkins
instance
so that's something that you got to kind
of keep in mind all right but number of
executors 2 for my system is kind of
good label for my jenkins i don't want
any of these things usage how do you
want to use your jenkins this is good
for me because i only have a primary uh
server that is running so i want to use
this node as much as possible quite
pretty each of these options have got
some pair minimal
help kind of a thing that is that is out
here by clicking on these question marks
you will get to know as to what are
these particular configurations
all right so this all look good what i
want to show you here is there's
something regarding the docker
timestamps git plugin svn
email notifications
i don't want that what i want the yes i
want this smtp server configuration
remember i mentioned earlier that i
would want jenkins to be sending out
some emails
and what i've done here is i've just
configured
the smtp details of my personal email id
in case you are in a in organization you
would have some sort of an email id that
is set up for a jenkins server so you
can specify the smtp server details of
your
company so that you know you can
authorize jenkins to kind of send out
emails but in case you want to try it
out like me i have configured my
personal email id which is on my gmail
for sending out notifications so the
smtp server would be
smtp.gmail.com i'm using the smtp
authentication i have provided my email
id and my password i'm using the smtp
port which is 465 and i'm you know reply
to address is the same as mine i can
just send out an email
and see if at all this configuration
works again gmail would not allow you to
allow anybody to send out notifications
on your behalf so you'll have to lower
the security level of your gmail id so
that you can allow a programmatically
somebody to send out email notifications
on your behalf so i've done already that
i'm just trying to see if i can send a
test email with the configuration that
i've set in
yes
all right so the email configuration
looks good
so this is how you configure your
you know your gmail account in case you
want to do that if not put in your
organization smtp server details which
are for the valid username and password
and it should all be set
all right so no other configurations
that i'm going to change here all of
these look good
all right so i come back to managing
kens okay one other thing that i want to
kind of go over is the global tool
configuration
imagine this scenario look at it this
way jenkins is a is a continuous
integration server it doesn't know what
kind of a code base it's going to pull
in what kind of a tool set that is
required or what is the code that is
going to be understandably you want to
restart jenkins once in a while but as a
good practice whenever you do some sort
of big installations or big patches on
your jenkins instance just ensure that
you kind of restart it otherwise there
would be a difference in terms of what
is installed on the system and what is
there on the file system you will need
to flush out few of those settings later
on but for now these are all very small
plugins so this would run without any
problems but otherwise if at all there
are some plugins which would need a
restart you know kindly go and restart
your jenkins instance but for now i
don't need that it looks good i've
installed the plugin so where do i see
my plugin i install the plugin that is
specific to the user control or the
access control so let me go into
yes
global security and uh i would see this
role-based strategy showing up now
all right so this comes in because of my
installation of my role-based uh plugin
so this is what i would want to enable
because i already have my own database
set up and for the authorization part in
the sense that who can do what i'm going
to install i mean i've already installed
a role based strategy uh plugin and i'm
going to enable that strategy all right
i would say save
okay
now i've installed the role based access
plugin i would need to just set it up
and check that you know i would go ahead
and create some roles and ensure that i
assign users as per these roles all
right so let me go to
manage keynes where is this configure
configure global security is that where
i create my roles
nope not here
yes manage and assign roles
okay again you would see these options
only after you install these plugins so
for now i've just enabled the plugin i
have enabled role-based access control
and i would go ahead and create some
rules for this particular jenkins
instance so i would say first
manage rules
so i would need to create some roles
here and the roles are at a very high
level these are global rules and there
are some project rules and there are
some slave rules i'll not get into
details of all of this at a very very
high level which is a global role let me
just create a role a role can be kind of
visualized like a group so i would
create a role called developer typically
the jenkins instance or the ca instance
are kind of owned up or controlled by qa
guys so qr guys would need to provide
some sort of uh you know limited access
to developers so that's why i'm creating
a role called developer
and i'm adding this role at a global
role level so i would say add this here
and you would see this developer role
that is there and each of these options
if we hover over it you would see some
sort of a
help on what what are these you know
permissions specific to so what i want
is like you know it sounds a little
different but i would want to give very
very little permissions for the
developer so from an administration
perspective i would just want him to
have a read um kind of a role
credentials again i would just want to
view kind of a rule i don't want him to
create any agents and all that stuff
that's looks good for me
for a job i would want him to just
possibly
read i don't want him to build i don't
want him to cancel any jobs i don't want
him to configure any job i don't even
want him to create any job i would just
want him to read few things i would not
give him possibly a role to the
workspace as well i mean i don't want
him to have access to the workspace i
would just want him to
read a job
check you know i have read only access
to the job run
no i don't want him to give him any any
particular access which will allow him
to run any jobs view configure yeah
possibly create yeah
delete i don't want to read yes
definitely
and this is the specific role so what
i'm doing i'm just creating a global
role called developer and i'm giving him
very very limited roles
in the sense that i don't want this
developer to be able to run any agents
nor create jobs or build jobs or cancel
jobs or configure jobs at the max i
would just want him to read a job that
is already put up there
okay
so i would save
now i created a role
i still don't have any users that is
there on the system so let me go ahead
and create some user on the system
that's not here how sick configure
managements manage users
okay let me create a new user
i would call this user as yeah
developer1 sounds good
some password
some password that i can remember
okay his name is developer1
d at
t dot com or something like that
okay so this is the admin with with
which i kind of configured or brought up
the system and developer one is a user
that i have configured so still have not
set any rules for this particular user
yet so i would go to manage and gains
i would say
manage and assign roles i would say
assign roles
okay so if you see what i'm going to do
now is assign a role that is specific to
that particular i will find the
particular user and assign him the
developer role that i have already
configured
the role shows up here i would need to
find my user whoever created and then
assign him to that particular rule so if
you remember the user that i created was
developer1 i would add this particular
user and now this particular user what
kind of a role i want him to have
because this is the global rule that had
created so developer i would assign this
developer 1 to this particular global
rule and i would go ahead and save my
changes
now let me check the permissions of this
particular user by logging out of my
admin account and logging back as
developer one
if you remember this role was created
with very less privileges
so
there you go i have jenkins but i don't
see a new item i can't trigger a new job
i can't do anything i see these jobs
however i don't think so i'll be able to
start this job i don't have the
permission set for that the maximum i
can do is look at the job see what was
there as a part of the console output
and stuff like that so this is a limited
role that was created and i added this
developer to that particular role which
was a developer role
so that the developers don't get to
configure any of the jobs because the
jenkins instance is owned by a qr person
he doesn't want to give developer any
administrative rights so the rights that
he set out by creating a developer role
and anybody who is tagged any user who's
tagged as a part of this developer role
would get the same kind of permissions
and this permissions can be you know
fine grain it can be a project specific
permissions as well but for now i just
demonstrated the high level permission
that i had set in
let me quickly log out of this user and
get back
as the admin user because i need to
continue with my demo with the developer
role that was created i have very very
less privileges one of the reasons for
jenkins being so popular as i mentioned
earlier is the bunch of plugins that is
provided by users or community users who
don't charge any money for these plugins
but it's got plugins for connecting
anything and everything so if you can
navigate to or if you can find jenkins
plugins
you would see index of over so many
plugins that is there all of these are
wonderful plugins whatever connectors
that you would need if you want to
connect jenkins to an
or the war file gets created properly
okay
wonderful so it built a war file and if
you see it all shows you
what is the location where this war file
was generated
so this will be the workspace if you see
this this war file was successfully
built now i need to grab this particular
war file and then i would need to deploy
it into tomcat server again i would need
a small plugin to do this because i need
to connect tomcat with my jenkins server
let me go ahead and
install the plugin for the container
deployment so i will go to manage
plugins
available
type in container
container container
deploy to container okay so let's put
this the plugin that i would need i will
install it without a restart
right seems to be very fast
nope sorry it's still installing
okay
it installed the plugin so if at all you
see this
if you go to my workspace
okay in the target folder
i would see this web application war
file that is already built
so i would need to configure this plugin
to pull up this war file and deploy it
onto the tomcat server for deploying
onto the tomcat server i will use the
credentials of the user that i've
created
okay so let me go to configure this
particular project again
and um okay all this is good
so the package is good i'm gonna just
create a package that's all fine
now
add a post build step so after the war
file is built as a part of this package
directive let me use this
deployment to container now this will
show up after you install the plugin so
deploy this one to the container
now what is that you're supposed to
specify you're supposed to specify the
what is the location
okay so this is a global uh you know
configuration that is there that will
allow you to
from the root folder it will pick up the
war file that is there so star star
forward slash star dot war that's good
for me
okay what is the context path context
path is nothing but just the name of an
application that you know under which it
will get deployed into the tomcat server
i will just say mvn web app
that's the name of my thing now i need
to specify what kind of a container that
i'm talking about
all right so the deployment would be for
this tomcat 8.5 is what i need
okay because the server that we have is
a tomcat 8.5 server that i have so this
would be the url so the credentials yes
i need to add a credential for this
particular server so if you remember i
had created a credential
for my web application so let me just
find that
my tomcat server yes configuration of
this
okay so deployer and deployer username
is deployer password is deployer
okay so let me use that credential
i would say i would say add a new
credential jenkins credential the
username is deployer and the password is
deployer
so i would use this deploy credentials
for that and what is the url of my
tomcat instance
so this is the url of my tomcat instance
so take the war file that is fine found
in this particular
folder
and then you know context path the same
when we have used the deployer
deployment credentials and get into this
local host which is there
8081 this is the tomcat server that is
running on my system and then go ahead
and deploy it
okay so that is all that is required so
i would say just save this
and let me run it now
okay it builds successfully built the
war file it is trying to deploy it and
looks like the deployment went ahead
perfectly well
so
the context path was mvn web app so if i
type in this
if at all i go ahead into my tomcat
server there would be a web apps folder
you would see the
you know the date timestamp so this is
the file that get got recently copied
and this is the explorer version of our
application
so the application was built the source
code of this application was pulled from
the github server it was built locally
on the jenkins instance and then it was
pushed into a tomcat server which is
running on a different port which is
808.1 now for this demo i'm running
everything locally on my system but
assuming that you know this particular
tomcat instance was running on some
other server with some other different
ip address all that you've got to go and
change is the url of the server
so this would be the server in case you
you already have that you know if you
have a tomcat which is running on some
other machine that's all fine with a
different ipa that's all good enough the
whole bundle or the war file that was
built as a part of this jenkins job gets
transferred onto the other server and
gets deployed that's the beauty of
jenkins and automatic deployments or
other deployments using jenkins and
maven
distributed build or master slave
configuration in jenkins as you would
have seen you know we just have one
instance of jenkins server up and
running all the time and also i told you
that whenever any job that kind of you
know get started on the jenkins server
it is little heavy on in terms of disk
space and the cpu utilization so which
kind of you know if at all you are in an
organization wherein you're heavily
reliant on the jenkins server you don't
want your jenkins server to go down so
that's wherein you kind of start
distributing the load that is there on
the jenkins server so you primarily have
a server which is just a placeholder or
like a master who will take in all kind
of jobs and what you'll do is based upon
trigger that has happened to the job or
whichever job needs to be built he if at
all he can delegate these jobs onto some
other machines or some other slaves you
know that's a wonderful thing to have
okay use case one use case two assuming
that you know if you have a jenkins
server that is running on a windows box
or on a linux one and if at all you have
a need where you need to build based
upon operating systems you have multiple
build configurations to support maybe
you need to build a windows you know
windows based dot net kind of a projects
where you would need a windows machine
to build this particular project you
also have a requirement where you want
to build linux linux based systems you
also have a mac you you support some
sort of an apps or something that is
built on mac os you would need to build
you know mac based system as well so how
are you going to support all these needs
so that's where in a beautiful concept
of master slave or you know primary and
delegations or agent and master comes
into play so typically you would have
one jenkins server who will just save
and then i would say
back him up
so this would run a bunch of you know
steps and all the files that is required
as a part of this is pretty fast but
then if at all you have too many things
up on your server for now we didn't have
too many things up on our but in case
you had too many things to kind of
backup this may take a while so let me
just pause this
recording and get back to you once the
backup is complete so there you go the
backup was successful
created a backup of all the workspace
the configurations the users and you
know all that so all this is kind of
hidden down in this particular
zip file so at any instance if at all i
kind of crash my system for some
instance or say hard disk failure and i
bring up a new instance of jenkins i can
kind of use the backup plugin for
restoring this particular
configurations
so how do i do that i just come back to
my managing cans
come back to
backup manager and i will say restore
that's an or
jenkins configuration so devops today is
being implemented by you know most of
the major organizations whether it's a
financial organization whether it's a
kind of a service organization every
organization is somehow looking forward
for the implementation and the
adaptation of devops because it totally
redefines and automate the whole
development process all together and
whatever the manual efforts you were
putting earlier that is simply or gets
automated with the help of these tools
here so this is something which get
really implemented because of some of
the important uh feature like a cicd
pipeline because cicd pipeline is
responsible for delivering your source
code into the production environment in
large duration of time so cicd pipeline
is ultimately the goal which really
helps us to deliver more into the
production environment when we talk
about from this perspective
now let's talk about that what exactly
is a ca cd pipeline now when we go into
that part when we go into that
understanding so cicd pipeline is a
basically continuous integration and
continuous delivery concept which is
used or which is considered as a
backbone of the overall devops approach
now it's one of the prime approach which
we implement when we are going for a
devops implementation for our project so
if i have to go for a devops
implementation the very first and the
minimum implementation and the
automation which i'm looking forward is
actually from the uh particular ci cd
pipelines here so cicd pipelines is
really a wonderful option when we talk
about the devops here
so what exactly is the pipeline term
all about so pipeline is in series of
events that are connected together with
each other it's kind of a sequence of
the various steps like you know
typically when we talk about any kind of
deployment so we have like you know
build process like we compile the source
code which under the artifacts we do the
testing and then we deploy to a specific
environment all these various steps
which we use to do it like manually that
is something which we can do it into a
pipeline so pipeline is nothing but a
sequence of all these steps
interconnected with each other executed
one by one into a particular sequence
now the pipelines is responsible for
performing a variety of tasks
like building up the source code running
the test cases uh probably the
deployment can also be added up in when
we go for the continuous integration and
continuous delivery there so all these
steps are being done into a sequence
definitely because sequence is very
important when we talk about the
pipeline so you need to talk about the
sequence the same way in which you are
working on the development and in a
typical world the same thing you will be
putting up into a specific pipeline so
that's a very important aspect to be
considered now let's talk about what is
the continuous integration here now
continuous integration is also you know
known as the ci uh pretty much you can
see that a lot of
tools are actually named as ci but they
are referring to the continuous
integration only so continuous
integration is a practice that
integrates the source code into a shared
repository and it used to
automate the verification of the source
code so it involves the build
automations test cases automation so it
also helps us to detect the issues and
the bugs quite easily and quite faster
that's a very early mechanism which we
can do as such if we want to resolve all
these problems now continuous
integrations does not eliminate the bugs
but yes it definitely helps them uh you
know easily to find out because we we
are talking about the uh automated
process we are talking about the
automated test cases so definitely that
is something which can help us to uh
find out the bugs and then you know the
development can help on that and they
can you know proceed with those bugs and
they can try to resolve those things one
by one so it's not a kind of automated
process which will eventually remove the
bugs bugs is something which you have to
recode and you have to fix it by
following the development practice but
yes it can really help us to find those
bugs quite easy and help them to remove
now what is the continuous delivery here
so continuous delivery also known as cd
is in kind of a phase in which the
changes are made uh into the code before
the deployment now in this case what
happens that uh it's
something which we are discussing or we
are validating that what exactly we want
to deliver it to the customer so what
exactly we are going ahead or we are
moving to the customer so that's what we
typically do in case of continuous
delivery and the ultimate goal of the
pipeline is to make the deployments
that's the end result because
coding is not the only thing you code
the programs you do the development
after that it's all about the
deployments like how you're going to
that to perform the deployment so that
is a very important aspect you want to
go ahead with the deployments that's
right you can go there and that's a real
beauty about this because it it's in
kind of a way in which we can identify
that how the deployments can be run or
can be executed as such here
right so the ultimate goal for the
pipeline is nothing but to do the
deployments and to proceed further on
that
right so when both these practices are
placed in together in an order so all
these steps could be referred as in
complete automated process and this
process is known as cicd so when we are
talking about like when we are working
on this automation so in that case what
happens that we are looking forward that
how the automation needs to be done and
since it's in kind of a ci cd automation
which we are talking about so it's
nothing but the uh end result would be
like build and deployment automation so
you will be taking care of both the
build and the test case executions and
the deployments as such when we talk
about as such the cacd here
the implementation of chcd also enables
the team to do the build and deploys
quite quickly and uh efficiently because
these are things which is you know
happening automatically so there is no
manual efforts involved and there is no
scope of human error also so we have
frequently seen that while doing the
deployments we may miss some binaries or
some miss can be there so that is
something which is you know completely
removed as such when we talk about this
the process makes the teams more agile
productive and the uh confident here
because um the automations definitely
gives a kind of a boost to the
confidence that yes things are going to
work perfectly fine and free definitely
you can add on your credentials but this
is a public repository a personal
repository so i don't have to put any
kind of credentials but you can always
add the credentials with the help of add
here and that can help you to you know
set up whatever the credentials private
repositories you want to configure now
once you save the configuration here
now what it's going to do is that you
it's going to give you a particular page
related to build now uh if you want to
run if you want to delete the pipeline
if you want to reconfigure the pipeline
all these different options are
available there so we are going to click
on the build now here and when i do that
immediately the pipeline will be
downloaded and will be processed now you
may not be able to get the complete
stage view as of now because it's still
running so yeah you can see that the
checkout code is done then it's going on
to the build okay that's one of the step
which is there now once the build will
be done so it will continue with the
next steps with the next for the steps
there so you can also go to the console
output log here like you can click on
this or you can click on the console
output to check the complete log which
is happening there or in fact you can
also see the stage wise logs also
because that is also very important when
you go for the complete logs uh it may
you know have a lot of steps involved
and you know a lot of logs will be
available there but if you want to see a
specific log of a specific stage that's
where this comes into the picture and as
you can see that all the different uh
steps like test cases executions the
scenar cube analysis the archive
artifacts deployment and in fact the
notification so all this is a part of a
complete pipeline this whole pipeline is
done here and you know you get a kind of
a stage view it's success over here and
the artifacts is also available to
download so you can download this war
file is a web applications as such over
here so this is what our typical
pipeline looks like that how the
automation the complete automations
really looks like as such over here now
this is a very important aspect because
it really helps us to understand that
how the pipelines can be configured can
be done and pretty much with the same
steps you will be able to automate any
kind of pipelines as such so that was
the demo to build a simple pipeline as
such with the jenkins and uh pretty much
in this one we understood that how
exactly the cicd pipelines can be
configured and we can use them and we
can get hold on that part so there are
approximately seven sections that we
cover in devops we go from general
devops questions source code management
with tools such as git continuous
integration and here we'll focus on
jenkins continuous testing with tools
such as selenium and then you also have
the operation side of devops which is
your configuration management with tools
such as chef puppet and ansible
containerization with docker and then
continuous marching with tools such as
nagios so let's just get into those
general devops questions so one of the
questions that you're going to be asked
is how is devops different from agile
and the reality is is that devops is a
cultural way of being able to deliver
solutions that's different from agile if
we look at the evolution of delivery
over the last five to ten years we've
gone from waterfall based delivery to
agile delivery which is on uh sprint to
where we are with continuous integration
and continuous delivery around devops
the whole concept of devops is
culturally very very different from
agile and the difference is is that
you're looking at being able to do
continuous releases what does that mean
the difference is is that you want to be
able to send out code continuously to
your production environment that means
the operations team the development team
have to be working together that means
that any code that gets created has to
be able to go to production very quickly
which means you need to be testing your
code continuously and then that
production environment must also be able
to be tested continuously and any
changes or any errors that come up have
to be communicated effectively and
efficiently back to the dev and op team
another area in which i see that devops
is different is really the response that
we have for how we engage with the
customer so the customer is coming to
your website to your mobile app to your
chat bot or any digital solution that
you have and has an expectation when
you're going through and actually doing
a dev ops paradigm the old model would
be that you would capture requirements
from the customer then you do your
development then you do your testing and
there would be these barriers between
each of those as we move faster through
from waterfall to agile what we saw is
that with agile we're able to respond
much faster to customer demands so
instead of it being weeks or months
sometimes in some cases years between
releases of software what we saw it
would was a transition to weeks and
months for releases on software now we
see with devops is that the release
cycle has shrunk even further with the
goal of continuously delighting the
customer how further has that release
cycle shrunk to there are companies that
have gone from having releases of once a
week or once every two weeks or once a
month to now having multiple releases a
day indeed some companies have up to 50
releases a day this isn't something to
also bear in mind is that each of those
releases are tested and verified against
test records so that you can guarantee
that the code that's going to production
is going to be good continuous code so
what are the differences between the
different phases of devops so
effectively there are two main phases of
devops there's the planning and coding
phase and then there's the deploying
phase and you have a tool such as
jenkins that allows you to integrate
between both environments some of the
core benefits that you may have to
devops are going to be some technical
benefits and some business benefits so
when somebody asks you what are the
benefits of devops you can reply that
from a technical point of view you're
able to use continuous software delivery
to constantly push out code that has
been tested and verified against scripts
that have been written and approved you
can be able to push out
smaller chunks of code so that when you
have an issue you're not having to go
through massive blocks of code or
massive projects you're going through
just very small micro services or small
sections of code and you're able to
detect and correct problems faster on
the business side the benefits are
absolutely fantastic
from a customer that's coming to your
website and or to your mobile app
they're going to see responses happening
continuously so that the customer is
always aware that you as a company are
listening to their demands and
responding appropriately you're able to
provide a more stable environment and
you're able to scale that environment to
the demands of the number of customers
that are using your services so how you
approach a project that needs to
implement devops so this is really an
exciting area for you to be in so there
are effectively three stages when it
comes to actually working in a devops
the first stage is an assessment stage
and think of this as the back of the
napkin ideation stage this is where you
are sitting with a business leader and
they're giving you ideas of what they
would like to see from feedback that
they've had from their customers this is
blue sky opportunity this is thinking of
big ideas that second stage and this
often comes as a fast follow to stage
one is actually proving out that concept
so developing a proof of concept and a
proof of concept can actually be a
multiple different things so it could be
something as simple as a wireframe or it
could be something that is as complex as
a mini version of the final application
depending on the
remote repository and in the example you
may want to talk about using the command
get remote add origin and then the
actual path to a github repository you
could if you want to actually at this
point also talk about other repositories
such as git lab that you can also work
with or a private git repository that
would be used just for the development
team once you've actually then added the
local repository into your local
computer then the second action you want
to use is a push which is to actually
push your local files out to the master
environment so you use the command git
push origin master so one question you
may be asked is what is the difference
between a bare repository and a standard
way of initializing a get repository so
let's look through what is the standard
way so the standard way using git init
allows you to create a working directory
using the command git in it and then the
folder that creates is the folder that
creates all the revision history related
to the work that you're doing in
contrast using the bear way you have a
different commands for setting that up
so it would be git init dash dash bear
and it does not contain any working or
checked out source files locally on your
machine in addition the revision history
is actually stored in the root folder
versus a subfolder that you would have
with the normal git in it initialization
so which of the following cli commands
would you be used to rename a file so we
have git rm git mv get rm r or none of
the above well in this instance it would
be gate mv a question that you'll be
asked around commit is going to be what
is the process to revert a commit that
has already been pushed and made public
and there are two ways you can address
this the first is to actually address
the bad file in the new commit and you
can use the command git commit dash m
and then put in a comment for why that
file is being removed the second is to
actually create a new commit that
actually undoes all the changes that
were made with the bad commit and then
to do that you would use git revert and
then the commit id and the commit id and
it could be something such as 560
0938f but you'd have to find that from
the the commit that you had made but
that would allow you to revert any bad
files that you had submitted so the two
ways of being able to get files from a
get repository and you're going to be
asked to explain the difference between
git fetch and get paul so get fetch
allows you to fetch and download only
new data from a new repository it does
not integrate any of the new data into
your working files and it can be undone
at any time if you wanted to break out
the remote tracking branches in contrast
git pull updates the current head branch
with the latest changes from the remote
server so you get all of the files and
downloaded it downloads new data and
integrates it with the current working
files you have on your system and it
tries to merge remote changes with your
local ones so one of the questions
you'll get asked about get is what is a
git stash so as a developer you will be
working on the current branch within a
solution but what happens if you come up
with an idea where it's something that
will take a different amount of time for
you to be able to complete but you don't
want to interrupt the mainline branch so
what you can actually do is you can
actually create a branch that allows you
to start working on your own work
outside of the mainline branch and this
is called git stash allows you to be
able to modify your files without
interrupting the mainline branch so you
once you start talking about branching
and git be prepared to answer and
explain the concept of branching so
essentially what it allows you to do is
have a mainline master branch that has
all the code that the team is checking
in and checking out against but allows
you to have an indefinite number of
branches that allows for new features to
be built in parallel to the mainline
branch and then at some point be
reintroduced to the mainline branch to
allow the team to add in new features
and so if we look through the merge and
get rebase these are the two features
that you'd be using continuously to be
able to talk about how you take a branch
and merge it back into the mainline
branch so on the left hand side we have
git merge which allows you to take the
code that you're creating and merge it
back into the master on the right hand
side what you have is a slightly
different approach this is for projects
where you reach a point in a project
where you go okay we're going to
effectively restart the project at this
point in time and we want to ignore the
complete history that's happened before
that and that's called get rebase and
that would allow you to rewrite the
project history by creating a brand new
mainline branch that ignores all other
previous branches that have happened
before it you can if you want to very
quickly and easily find out all the
files that have been used to make a
particular commit so when somebody asks
you the question how do you find a list
of files has been changed in a
particular commit you can actually say
that all you have to go is find the
command get diff dash tree dash r and
then the hash that you would use for the
commit and that would actually then give
you a breakdown of all the files that
have been made with that particular
commit a question you'll be asked when
you're talking about merging files is
what is a merge conflict in git and how
can it be resolved so essentially a
merge conflict is when you have uh two
or more branches that are competing with
commits in git and you have to be able
to determine which is the appropriate
files that need to be submitted and this
is where you would go in and to actually
help resolve this issue you'd actually
go in and manually edit the conflicted
files to select the changes you want to
keep in the final merge so let me go
through the steps that you would take to
be able to illustrate this when you're
talking about this particular question
in your interview now there are
essentially four stages the first would
be under the repository name you want to
select a pull request and uh you want to
be able to show how that pull request
would be demonstrated inside of github
so within the pull request there's going
to be a highlight of conflict markers
and you'll be able to select which
conflicts and you want to keep on which
you want to merge and which ones you
want to change so it's a step through
how you would actually resolve a merge
conflict and the first step would be
under github you want to be able to pull
the repository name and then the pull
request around that repository in the
pull request list click the pull request
with a merge conflict and that you'd
like to be able to resolve they'll pull
up a file that will list out all of the
conflicts for you near the bottom of
that file will be a list of the requests
that need to be resolved and then if you
need to make a decision on which
branches you want to keep or which ones
you want to change that will have to be
something you have to put in
instructions inside of the file you'll
actually see that there are conflict
markers within the instructions which
are going to ask you which files you
want to change which ones you want to
keep if you have more than one merge
card does not return any parameters but
just returns a string value so you want
to be able to capture that stream value
and discuss about it a question you'll
be asked around selenium is can you
handle keyboard and mouse actions using
selenium and the answer is yes you can
but you have to make sure that you're
using the advanced user interaction api
and the advanced user interaction api is
something that can be scripted into your
tests and allows you for
capturing methods such as a click and
hold and drag and drop mass events and
then keyboard down or keyboard up key
release events so that if you want to to
capture say the use of control shift or
a specific function button off the
keyboard you'd be able to capture those
of the following four elements which of
these elements is not a web element
method a get text b
size
c get tag name d send keys and it's b
size you're going to be asked to explain
what is the difference for when we use
find element or find elements and so if
we look at find element find element
finds the first element in the current
web page that matches the specified
locator value in contrast find elements
finds all of the elements on the web
page that matches the specified value
when using web driver what are the
driver close and driver quit commands
and these are two different methods used
to close a web browser session in
selenium so driver close will close the
current web browser which your focus is
set and driver quick closes all the
browser windows and ends the webdriver
session completely the final question
that you are likely to be asked in using
selenium is how can you submit a form
using selenium well in this instance
that's relatively easy the following
lines of code will let you submit a form
in selenium which would be web element
el equals driver dot find element and
then you put in the id and the element
id and then l submit open close
parentheses semicolon so let's just get
into the first section which is
configuration management so one of the
questions that you'll get asked right
away is why do you have ssl certificates
used for chef really fundamentally your
immediate answer should be security ssl
provides for a very high level of
private security and private and public
key pairing this really is essential to
ensure that you have a secure
environment throughout your entire
network the second part should be that
if you're using ssl and you're using the
private public key model within ssl
you're able to guarantee the systems on
your network that the chef that you'll
be able to validate that the nodes
within your network that chef is
validating against actually are the real
nodes themselves not imposters so you
will also be asked um some questions
such as the following which is the
following commands would you use to stop
or disable the http service when the
system boots and you'll typically get
four responses and they'll be hashtag
system ctl disable
httpd.service or is it system disable
http.service system disable httpd or the
final option which is system ctl disable
httpd.service
your answer should be the first one
which is hashtag system ctl disable http
dot service so chef comes with a series
of tools that allow it to function
effectively and one of the tools that
you're going to be asked about is what
is test kitchen and test kitchen is
essentially a command line tool that
allows you to be able to test out your
cookbook before you actually deploy it
to a real node so some of the commands
that you would use are for instance if
you want to create an instance of test
kitchen you would do kitchen create if
you want to destroy an instance after
you created it you do kitchen destroy
and if you want to be able to combine
multiple instances you would do kitchen
converge so a question you'll get is
around chef is how does chef apply
differ from chef client so fundamentally
the difference between them is that chef
apply will validate the recipe that
you're working on whereas chef client
looks to apply and validate the entire
cookbook that's run in your server
environment so one is focused on the
recipe and the other is focused on the
entire cookbook
so there are some differences when
you're working with different command
lines so for instance when you're
working with puppets and you're working
with one version of puppets and you want
to do what is the command to sign a
requested certificate the top example
here is for public version 2.7 whereas
the lower option here is for puppet
version 3. now something to bear in mind
when you're going through your interview
process is that the tools that are used
within a continuous integration
continuous delivery devops model do vary
and so you want to be able to talk
knowledgeably about the different
versions of the tools so that when
you're talking to your interviewer
you're able to show the deep knowledge
that you have which open source or
community tools do you use to make
puppet more powerful and essentially
this question is going to be asking you
to look beyond the core foundation of
puppet itself and so the three options
you have is uh being able to track
configurations with jira which you
should be doing anyway but it's a great
way to be able to clearly communicate
the work that's being done with puppet
our version control can be extended with
get and then the changes should be
passed through jenkins so the three
tools you want to be looking at
integration with jira git and jenkins so
what are the resources in puppet well
fundamentally there are four the
resources are basic unit of any
configuration management tool they are
the features of the nodes they are the
written catalog and the execution of the
catalog on a node so as we dig deeper
into puppet one of the things that you
are likely to be asked regarding puppet
is what is a class in puppet and so a
class in public is really the name
blocks in your manifest that contain the
various configurations and this can
include services files and packages and
we have on the screen here an example of
what a class would look like when you
write it out and you may want to
memorize just one class don't memorize
just a whole set of classes just
memorize one the person that's
interviewing you is just really looking
for someone who has a working knowledge
they're not looking for you to have
memorized complete massive classes but
having one small class to be able to
illustrate the experience you have is
extremely valuable to the interviewer
particularly if it's a technical
interview so as we move into ansible one
of the things that you're going to be
asked around ansible is what is ansible
role so a role is an independent block
of tasks and variable files and
templates embedded with inside of the
playbook so example we have here on the
screen actually shows you one role
within a playbook and in this role it is
to install tomcat on a node again as
with a previous question within puppets
of a class it's probably good to have
memorized just one or two roles so you
can talk knowledgeably about ansible
when you're having your interview so
when you're working with ansible when
should you be using the curly brackets
and so just as a frame of reference uh
there's often two different ways that
these kind of brackets are referred to
now they're either referred to as french
brackets
and the additional plugins that you
would use for your network connect with
the remote resources and the negative
web interface to be able to run status
checks on a predefined schedule so what
do you mean by nagios remote plugin
executor or the mpre of nagios so mpre
allows you to execute plugins on linux
unix machines that allow you to do
additional monitoring and machine
metrics such as disk usage cpu load etc
what are the ports used by nagios for
monitoring purposes in this example
there are three and they're easy to
remember so i would memorize these three
but they're essentially ports five six
six six
five six six seven and five six six
eight so there are two types of checks
within nine years so you will be asked
for what is an active and passive check
in nagios so an active check and is
initiated by the nagios process and is
run on a regular schedule a passive
check is initiated and formed by an
external application or process so this
may be where a system is failing and
checks our results are submitted to
nigeria's for processing and to continue
with this for what is an active and
passive check active checks are
initiated by the check logic within the
nagios daemon negas will execute a
plug-in and pass information about what
needs to be checked plug-in will then
check the operational state of the host
oil service and then process the results
of the host or service check and send
out notifications in contrast with the
passive check it is an external
application that initiates the check it
writes the results of the check to an
external command line file and i guess
reads the external command file and
places the results of all passive checks
in a queue for later processing so you
can go back and revalidate and then
negotiate may send out notifications log
alerts etc depending on the results that
they get from checking the information
so you're going to be asked to explain
the main configuration file and its
location in nagio so the main
configuration file consists of a number
of directives that affect how nagios
operate so consider this as the
configuration file that's read by both
nagios processor and the cgis so this
will allow you to be able to manage the
main configuration file that's placed
into your settings directory so what is
the nagios network analyzer and again
hold out your four fingers because there
are four options here so the nagios
network analyzer r1 provides an in-depth
look at all your network traffic source
and security threats 2 allows system
admins to gather high-level information
on the health of your network 3 provides
a central view of your network traffic
and bandwidth data and then four allows
you to proactive in resolving outages
abnormal behavior and threats before
they affect critical business processes
so what are the benefits of http and ssl
certificate monitoring with nagios so
with http certificate monitoring it
allows you to have increased server and
services and application availability
obviously very important fast detection
of network outages and protocol failures
and allows web transaction and web
service performance monitoring the ssl
certificate monitoring allows you for
increased website availability frequent
application availability and provides
increased security
so explain virtualization with nagios so
in responses the first thing you should
be able to talk about is how nagios
itself can run on many different
virtualization platforms including
microsoft visual pc vmware zen amazon
ec2 et cetera et cetera so just make
sure you get that right off um the bad
neighbors it was able to provide
capabilities tomorrow and assortment of
metrics on different platforms it allows
for ensure for quick detection of
service and application failures and has
the ability to be able to monitor
against many metrics including cpu usage
memory networking and vm status so name
the three variables that affect
recursion inheritance in nagios and it
is name use and register so name is a
template name that can be referenced in
other object definitions use specifies
the name of the template object that you
want to inherit its properties and
variables from and register indicates
whether or not the object definition
should be registered to nagios and on
the right hand side of the screen we
have an example of what that script
would look like again you may want to be
able to memorize this as it's something
that you can actually write down and
show someone if you're going through a
technical interview so why is nagios
said to be object oriented and
fundamentally comes down to the object
configuration format that you can use in
your object definitions it allows you to
inherit properties from other object
definitions and this is typical of
object oriented development and is now
applied for the nagios environment so
some of the objects that you can inherit
are surfaces hosts commands and time
periods so finally explain what is state
talking in nagios and so there are
really four options here when you're
talking about state stalking so state
stalking is used for logging purposes in
nagios it allows you to enable for a
particular host or service that nagios
will watch over very carefully it will
log any changes it sees in the output of
the check results and then finally helps
the analysis of log file and with that
we have reached the end of day one so
far we have learned the introduction of
devops in detail on day two of devops
learning week we will reveal the next
stage where you get to master the two
leading and important tools in devops
which are none other than the docker and
kubernetes so don't miss them out thanks
for watching stay tuned for more from
simply learn
you